Na hast du mitgefiebert mit der Mannschaft?
Nein, ich boykottiere Fußball seit meiner Geburt.
Wie kommt's?
Mich hat das nie interessiert. Mich hat die WM auch überhaupt nie interessiert. Ich nehme davon nichts wahr. Ich kenne einige Spieler dadurch, dass ich regelmäßig mir bei Bild Online irgendwelche Boulevard-Meldungen durchlese. Aber da geht es meistens um die Spielerfrauen oder die Nicht-Mehr-Spielerfrauen. Mich interessiert das Ganze nicht. Ich habe also immer schon boykottiert, würde aber auch sagen, dass ich es zum einen nachvollziehen kann, dass boykottiert wird. Zum anderen aber sprechen wir heute, wo wir gerade seit 24 Stunden einen neuen Gasdeal mit Katar haben. Oder wie man jetzt ja neuerdings sagt, sagt Katar. Das hat sich gewandelt, weiß auch nicht, es ist so gekommen. Ich bleibe mal beim alten Katar.
Wie fassen wir also das Bürgergeld zusammen? Ich denke mit dem alten Witz von Radio Jerevan. Du kennst den Witz vielleicht, Radio Jerevan, da gibt es eine Anfrage. Stimmt es, dass Ivan Ivanovich in der Lotterie ein rotes Auto gewonnen hat? Und die Antwort lautet im Prinzip ja. Und jetzt wäre unsere Frage, ist Hartz IV wirklich abgeschafft worden? Im Prinzip ja. So, dann geht es aber weiter. Aber es war nicht Ivan Ivanovich, sondern Piotr Petrovic. Und es war kein rotes Auto, sondern ein blaues Fahrrad. Und er hat es auch nicht gewonnen, sondern es wurde ihm gestohlen. Wir machen weiter mit Claudia, denn wir sprechen ja gerade über Staatsbürgerschaft. Und was ist da ganz wichtig für die neuen Staatsbürger, dass sie zum Beispiel auch Deutsch sprechen, lernen, dass sie an entsprechenden Schulen sind. Und dafür braucht man gutes Personal, so eine zum Beispiel wie Claudia.
Claudia Gräsner arbeitet als Lehrerin an einer Schule für Erwachsenenbildung in Hamburg-Harburg. Sie ist studierte Germanistin und unterrichtet Deutsch als Fremdsprache. Claudia Gräsner arbeitet in Vollzeit. Sie gibt so viele Stunden wie Lehrer an allgemeinbildenden Schulen. Lehrer der Erwachsenenbildung sind Fachkräfte, die gerade händeringend gesucht werden.
Dieser Beruf bedeutet, dass man nicht nur die deutsche Sprache vermittelt, Menschen, die in unser Land kommen und dann hier leben wollen und arbeiten wollen, sondern dass man auch alles andere, was unser Land, unsere Gesellschaft, unser System ausmacht, mitvermittelt. Und sie vor allen Dingen auch willkommen heißt. Also das ist für mich immer auch so eine Herzenssache.
Ich habe doch heute Morgen einen Tweet gelesen von einem Wolfram, der meinte, die Ausländer sollen sich auch integrieren und auch Ja sagen zu unserem Lebensstil. Nur wenn sie das machen und gleichzeitig fährt man hier oben sagt, du sagst, wie man hier so lebt und so. Nee, mach mal bitte nur den Deutschunterricht und so. Können wir das mal zurecht stutzen?
Wir schauen uns mal an, zu welchem Lebensstil sollen die denn eigentlich dann Ja sagen?
Bezahlt wird Claudia Gräßner vom Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge, dem BAMF. Früher waren Lehrerinnen in der Erwachsenenbildung meist fest angestellt und wurden nach Tarif bezahlt. Heute arbeiten viele als sogenannte Honorarkräfte. Sie weiß nie genau, wie viel sie verdient. Im letzten Jahr kam sie nach Abzug der Steuern auf etwa 2.300 Euro monatlich.
2.300 Euro, aber sie muss sich selbst versichern. Sie muss vor allem damit überbrücken, die Phasen, wenn sie gerade keinen Job hat oder nicht genügend Stunden bekommt. Das ist immer die Frage, wie viele Stunden können tatsächlich stattfinden. Während der Ferien werden die nicht bezahlt. Und dann sieht das doch sehr, sehr kläglich aus.
Sie hat keine Absicherung bei Krankheit, keinen bezahlten Urlaub, keine Sicherheit. Und sie muss sich komplett selbst versichern. Von ihrem Einkommen bleibt kaum etwas übrig. Sie zahlt Rentenversicherung, Kranken- und Pflegeversicherung. Dazu kommen Warmmiete, Rundfunkbeitrag, Internet, Handy, Monatsticket für den Nahverkehr. Am Ende bleiben ihr etwa 200 Euro für Lebensmittel, Drogerieprodukte und Kleidung. So wie ihr geht es vielen aus der unteren Mittelschicht. Dazu zählen Haushalte, die zwischen 1.300 und 2.600 Euro zum Leben haben.
200 Euro bleiben dann für Lebensmittel und Kleidung. Sie soll aber zugleich noch dort eine Willkommensstimmung verbreiten, neben dem Spracherwerb, den sie vermitteln soll.
Warum ist das so? Haben wir zu wenig Geld in Deutschland?
Das ist jetzt angestellt vom BAMF. Das BAMF sorgt dafür, dass die Leute, die ganz entscheidend dazu beitragen, dass Menschen integriert werden, so prekär leben, dass sie nur 200 Euro noch übrig haben und müssen schauen, dass sie ja wieder die Kurse vollbekommen im nächsten Jahr, denn sonst haben sie gar nichts.
Also die eine zuständige Ministerin in Sachsen hat ja damals ein Buch geschrieben, integriert doch erstmal uns. Und ich finde, das ist ein guter politischer Imperativ für alle fast. Für das halbe Land integriert doch erstmal mich. Integriert doch mal mich, weil das ist also mit 200 Euro im Monat und da sind noch keine Lebensmittel, kann man sich nicht integrieren. 200 Euro, das ist das nicht mal zwei Opernbesuche. Da ist man sozusagen außen vor.
Ja, aber im studentischen Leben kennt man das. Aber wir haben es ja hier mit einer erwachsenen Frau zu tun, die sagt, es ist nichts möglich für sie. Sie kann nicht mal sich in einen gebrauchten Kleinwagen oder sowas leisten. Es ist viel, viel zu wenig.
Also, weil du sagst, die Studenten im Studentenalter kennt man das, stimmt. Weshalb eigentlich jedes vernünftige Land in Europa mittlerweile 400, 500 Euro für Studenten Kulturgeld gibt, damit die einfach dann trotzdem das machen. Obwohl sie nicht genug Geld haben.
Es soll kommen, wird dann wahrscheinlich auch so klein gerechnet, bis am Ende nichts mehr da ist.
Also Spanien und Frankreich lagen da nieder. Ja. Und die haben es einfach gemacht. Die haben es einfach eingeführt. Und da gab es es einfach.
Und ich kann das sagen, ich war ja jetzt sehr viel unterwegs und war da sehr viel in studentischen Kreisen. Die finanzielle Situation war, ohne dass ich danach gefragt habe oder irgendwas dahin geschoben habe, immer Thema. Es geht fast allen, die studieren, schlecht.
Das finde ich auch sehr gut. Offen darüber reden, die Schicksalsgemeinschaft bilden, statt sich selber wieder durchzumogeln. Nein, nein, mir geht es ganz gut und so, sondern das gleich zum Thema machen. Was ich mich hier wieder frage. Dieser Film im NDR, eine Doku Mittelschicht in der Krise, besteht daraus, dass Journalistinnen mit einer Kamera zu Menschen gehen und sie einfach nur fragen, das ist nicht besonders investigativ oder so.
Es geht auch darum zu zeigen, wie generell sich die Vermögensverteilung in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten entwickelt hat. Das heißt, das habe ich jetzt weggelassen, weil wir das schon wissen. Zum Beispiel wird sehr deutlich gemacht, dass das Geld zu den Vermietern transferiert wird und dergleichen. Also das ist schon gut aufgearbeitet, nur wird es dann an den Fällen konkret gemacht.
Genau, und was ich mich frage, warum ist es wieder Julia Friedrichs, die für so einen Film verantwortlich ist? Ist sie das? Ja, ich habe extra nochmal nachgegoogelt gerade. Das verstehe ich nicht in Deutschland. Haben wir nicht neun Milliarden Betrieb, bei dem man denkt, so mindestens zwei Journalisten könnten das mal machen oder so gestandene Redaktion, wo man nicht...
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich würde mal tippen, dass Julia Friedrichs einen großen Namen hat und sie es überhaupt schafft, mal einen solchen Film durchzubekommen. Ich sehe nämlich solche Filme nicht allzu häufig, deswegen bin ich jetzt drauf gestoßen und auch hängen geblieben. Es ist ein Film, der auch sehr zornig macht und da kann man froh sein, dass Julia Friedrichs da offenbar auch einen sehr langen Atem hat und immer wieder kämpft, dass solche Themen da stattfinden. Und ja, es gäbe sicherlich journalistische Kapazität dafür, aber offenbar ist der Wille nicht so groß, solche Dokumentation zu machen. Und warum das vielleicht so ist, das können wir jetzt sofort, du hast die Überleitung jetzt gebastelt, sehen, wenn wir uns das große Interview mit Frank-Walter Steinmeier ansehen, das Tina Hassel geführt hat.
Hast du es dir angesehen?
Glückwunsch, aber wir werden das jetzt machen. Aber ich verspreche, wir hören ganz wenig Steinmeier, aber ganz viel Tina Hassel.
Erstmal Begrüßung.
Herzlich willkommen zu einem besonderen Bericht aus Berlin, hier aus dem Schloss Bellevue mit einem ganz besonderen Gast, dem Bundespräsidenten. Wir freuen uns, dass wir zum Auftakt der ARD Themenwoche wir gesucht, was hält uns zusammen, mit dem man sprechen können, dessen Aufgabe, aber auch dessen persönliches Herzensanliegen es ist, Brücken zu schlagen über gesellschaftliche Gräben. Dabei wollen wir keine Sonntagsreden, sondern möglichst konkrete Ideen, wie der erste Mann im Staat der Spaltung entgegenwirken will, zwischen Stadt und Land, Jung und Alt oder Ost und West. Herzlich willkommen, Herr Bundespräsident.
Da fehlt doch schon was, Alt und Jung, Ost und West. Arm und Reich ist nicht aufgekommen, das wollten wir nicht noch nennen.
Wieso verstehen die nicht selber, dass man das nur satirisch... Wir haben ja eh schwierig. Man kann ja kaum noch etwas nicht ironisch machen. Man geht zu Backstreet Boys, Tokyo Hotel und so weiter, alle Touren.
Ich hörte da so einiges.
Genau, man macht es ja ironisch, aber am Ende findet man es trotzdem. Ja, ich wäre einmal Monsoon auch in Echthörn. Und hier, das verstehe ich nicht, wieso die ARD es nicht merkt. Also die gehen in eine Konferenz rein zum Thema. Okay, wir haben ja die Themenwoche schon festgelegt. Letztes Jahr und so weiter, das sind ja alles lange Vorläufe. Das wir irgendwie. Dann debattieren sie eine Stunde, was sie machen und kommen raus mit dem Entschluss, okay, als allererstes ein Interview mit dem Bundespräsidenten. Warum verstehen die nicht, dass das albern ist? Oder sogar kontraproduktiv.
Ich müsste den ganzen Tag lachen, wenn ich abends noch den Bundespräsidenten interviewen müsste.
Also es gibt gerade in Deutschland eine Debatte zum Thema, wie macht man den Kampf gegen Antisemitismus richtig, jetzt wo die letzten Zeitzeugen des Holocaust nicht mehr da sind. Man hat dann irgendwann festgestellt, nee, das ist irgendwie blöd, wenn wir immer das Thema ganz oben aufhängen. Also wenn wir immer sagen, als erstes Mal reden wir mit dem Bundespräsidenten über Antisemitismus, weil nämlich dann ganz viele, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer sagen, ich hasse den Bundespräsidenten, zum Beispiel weil er mich in Armut gestürzt hat, sagen, ach so, jetzt kämpft er gegen Antisemitismus, ich bin jetzt Antisemit. Und zwar nur, um dem eins auszuwischen. Ich gehe jetzt auf die Straße, weil das provoziert die. Am Ende kriege ich sogar noch eine Redestunde mit dem Bundespräsidenten, weil ich vorher so viele Thebes auf der Straße gemacht habe. Diese Einladungspolitik gibt es ja auch im Schauspiel, die ist ja völlig Banane. So und das ist ja hier auch wieder so. In dem Moment, wo die ARD sich sagt, wir wollen ja nicht verwechselt werden mit dem Staat, wir sind ja total unabhängig, aber als allererstes holen wir uns den Gesprächspartner, den Staat, dann ist das kontraproduktiv. Dann ist man gerade nicht da, wo Tina Hassel ja, wir wollen es aber ganz konkret machen. Sie fordert jetzt vom Bundespräsidenten, es ganz konkret zu machen, geht aber selber als allererstes zum Bundespräsidenten. Das muss denen doch auffallen, dass das nicht zusammenpasst. Dass sie selber nicht zu Claudia und Ilona geht wie Julia Friedrichs.
Es sei denn, man glaubt, dass es die primäre Aufgabe des Journalismus ist, den Bürgern zu erklären, warum die Mächtigen das tun, was sie tun.
Genau.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein Punkt. Mein lieber Freund Ole hat mich auf einen Artikel aufmerksam gemacht vom Gegenstandpunkt, der ja marxistisch staatskritisch ist. Und da gab es vor Jahren einen Artikel über WikiLeaks. Und der leitete aber damit ein, dass man mal so klärte, was dann in Deutschland so das Demokratieverständnis von Journalisten ist und was das Verständnis auch ist, was Journalismus tun sollen. Und man liest das erst und denkt, na, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen sehr überspitzt. Und dann hört man sich dieses Interview an und sagt, nee, es trifft genau zu. Ich werde eine Passage später daraus vorlesen. Wir wollen erst mal reingehen. Wie kriegen wir denn das Wir wieder zusammen?
Nur 33 Prozent der Menschen hierzulande halten den Zusammenhalt für gut. Aber 48 Prozent der Menschen halten den Zusammenhalt für eher schlecht und sogar 16 Prozent für sehr schlecht. Wie sehr beunruhigt sie das?
Ja, die Antwort können wir uns natürlich ersparen.
Also halten sie den Zusammenhalt für schlecht oder dass es keinen Zusammenhalt gibt, ist schlecht? Sie hat es ja auch falsch formuliert.
Ja, sie hat es falsch formuliert. Gemeint ist wohl, dass viele Menschen nicht so sehr den Zusammenhalt spüren.
Wie Jean-Philippe sagt, der Spalt in Deutschland trifft auf Unwohlsein.
Was soll denn dieses Zusammenhalten sein? Zusammenhalten kann ich ja im direkten Umkreis erfahren. Ich kann zusammenhalten, abstrakter erfahren, dass ich, wenn ich arbeitslos werde, nicht in Armut gestürzt werde. So kann ich vielleicht noch abstrakt zusammenhalten erfahren. Aber Zusammenhalt von diesem Wir im Sinne meiner Volksgemeinschaft, das ist ja nicht das, was man eigentlich will. Steinmeier hat einen tollen Satz mitgebracht.
Dass das Ich in der Demokratie immer ein Wir ist.
Ja, solche Sätze sagt er. Er führt endlos aus, wo er überall in Deutschland unterwegs war, mit wem er alles gesprochen hat. Er wird auch angesprochen darauf, dass er ja eine Rede gehalten hat. Und bei dieser historischen Rede aber doch gar nicht der Bundeskanzler und andere wichtige aus der Führungsriege zu Gast waren. Also man macht ein Interview über das Wir und verhandelt aber eigentlich nur so Berlin Talk. Warum waren denn Scholz nicht da oder hätte nicht auch Habeck und was? Und dann sagt er ja, aber was mich besonders gefreut hat, es waren noch viele junge Menschen im Publikum, wo man denkt, warum soll er da, als Vertreter der Jugend wahrscheinlich. So wir wollen jetzt überleiten zu einem Bericht.
Sie wollen ja, Herr Bundespräsident, ein Bundespräsident zum Anfassen sein und nicht nur mit der Berliner Blase sprechen. Deshalb verlegen sie ihren Amtssitz ab und an ins Land. Zuletzt waren sie in Neustrelitz in Mecklenburg. Und wo die Menschen und wie die Menschen, die sie da treffen, so drauf sind, das können sie ja gar nicht vorher wissen. Ein Bericht von Moritz Rödle.
Jetzt gibt es einen Bericht zu sehen.
Wie er in Neustrelitz ist.
Wie er dort ist und noch mal auf Leute trifft. Ich habe nur ein Clip mitgebracht.
Ich fühle mich von Ihnen nicht vertreten.
Das ist jetzt die dritte Behauptung, von denen ich Ihnen sage, sie stimmt einfach nicht.
Dieser Dame, wer immer sie ist, man sieht wirklich nur diesen kurzen Ausschnitt, der kann man sagen, das ist völlig richtig, dass sie sich nicht vom Bundespräsidenten vertreten fühlen. Wer sich glaubt, vom Bundespräsidenten vertreten zu fühlen, sollte mal was Ideologie-Kritisches lesen oder einen Arzt aufsuchen.
Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht. Das ist ja wirklich nur gesagt, um ihn zu provozieren. In einer Kategorie, die sie nur aus dem Fernsehen kennt. Der Bundespräsident spricht für mich, was für ein Quatsch. Nein, man wird nicht vom Bundespräsidenten vertreten.
Der vertrete nicht die Anliegen, die diese Frau haben kann. Denn diese Frau wird eher sich mit Ilona und Claudia verbinden können.
Also, er nennt das ja Ortszeit. Der Bundespräsident ist dann drei Tage irgendwo. Tilo hatte ja im Aufwachen-Podcast Berichte aus Neustrelitz mitgebracht. Da wurde ja zum einen, also zweimal spielte der Marktplatz dort eine Rolle. Zum einen kam der Bundespräsident mit seiner Entourage, die größer war als der Markt selbst. Also ja, da standen auch drei Buden und haben was verkauft. Aber er kam da irgendwie mit 50 Leuten und alle so mit Steadycams um ihn rum, um ihn auch wackelfrei zu filmen und so. Und dann gab es eine sehr witzige Szene, wie er dann mit so einer Bäcker-Bachfachverkäuferin da sprach. Und dann sie so, ja, das ist alles so teuer und das Gas, wir müssen ja auch hier in den Ofen und so. Und er dann, ja, aber sie werden es ja mitbekommen, wenn dann die Erleichterungen durch die Regierung kommen. Auch wenn sie es jetzt noch nicht spüren, sie werden es mitbekommen. Ich glaube, ich kann ihnen das versprechen oder so irgendwie. Und dann hat er aus Dankbarkeit ein Brot gekauft. Und der deutsche Journalismus hat er dann nichts anderes auf Lager, als so abzumoderieren, der Bundespräsident verstreutet Zuversicht und kaufte ein Brot. Und dann ging so die nächste Szene. Und die nächste Szene war dann, der Marktplatz freigeräumt, da ja die ganze, was auch immer der Bundespräsident so macht, dann in Neustrelitz stattfand für drei Tage, fand da auch ein Staatsbesuch statt. Da ist also die ganze Berliner Musikkompanie der Bundeswehr nach Neustrelitz gefahren. Dann haben sie den Marktplatz einmal abgesperrt, damit da fünf Neustrelitzer in 100 Meter Entfernung irgendwie auch noch mal gucken können, wie der Bundespräsident mit einem Staatsgast den roten Teppich entlangläuft und dazu Musik gespielt wird. Und das war so eine Kaiser des Neuen Kleiderszenerie irgendwie. Wenn es dann heißt, im Amtsblatt veröffentlicht, ja hier ist Ortszeit, Staatsbesuch so und so, 11 Uhr. Da wird aber schon abends 20 Uhr alles abgesperrt und so. Also man kann dann seine eigene Stadt nicht verwenden, weil der Bundespräsident gerade da ist. Und dann sieht man das so, was eigentlich Fernsehbilder sind und die eigentlich völlig aus der Zeit gefallen sind. Und das sieht man dann so vor sich und denkt sich, warum? Das ist die einzige Frage. Warum machen wir das hier gerade? Das ist doch totaler Quatsch. Aber es wurde sehr schnell eingefangen, da im Nordmagazin.
Man hat auch den Eindruck, man macht das für ihn, weil er doch jetzt diese Jahre am Bundespräsident sein wie alle anderen vorher auswöhnen muss. Und dann sagt man, wie haben wir eigentlich immer den König froh gemacht? Wir lassen so ein paar Narren auftreten, ein paar Musiker und Gaukler. Und gerne ist er auch mal auf dem Lande. Ja, da machen wir noch eine kleine Landtrafie. Also gerade dieses Einkaufen fände ich schön, wenn ich vielleicht so ein Shopping-Repräsentant werde, dass ich vielleicht jeden Tag im Auftrag des Bundes Geschäfte aufsuche und dort was kaufe, ein Foto mache. Lange schön, wunderbare Qualität, großartig.
Du musst dann alles nochmal zeigen, den Stoff, den Fisch.
Dann hoffen wir, dass die Unterstützung bald bei ihnen ankommen.
Es war teuer, den Fisch zu räuchern, aber die Unterstützung wird ankommen. Ich verspreche es ihnen, aber ich bin nur drei Tage hier. Also sie müssen mit meinem Versprechen ein Vorlieb nehmen.
Ganz neue Perspektiven. Wir hören jetzt diesen Off-Kommentar von dem Bericht aus Neustrelitz.
Der Bundespräsident unterwegs. In Neustrelitz kann Steinmeier seine Stärke ausspielen. Das persönliche Gespräch. Auch wenn es ihm schwerfällt, mit allen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern ein gemeinsames Wir-Gefühl zu entwickeln.
Ein gemeinsames Wir-Gefühl mit einem Mann, der mal kurz dahin kommt, mit einem Sicherheitsgruppe und sonst was. Also dann, wenn du sagst, ich habe mit Tokyo Hotel ein Wir-Gefühl entwickelt, dann kann ich das noch eher dir abkaufen, wenn du die in Frankfurt oder sonst wo erlebst, als wenn da jemand mit dem Bundespräsidenten steht. Weiter.
Aber reicht eine Rede, um der Nation ein neues Wir-Gefühl zu geben?
Kommunikation ist in einer Krise besonders wichtig. Die Menschen suchen an vielen Stellen nach Orientierung, auch nach Hoffnung und er könnte und müsste so etwas wie ein kommunikativer Wegweiser sein in einer Zeit, in der sich viele verunsichert fühlen.
Sorry, das ist so falsch. Das ist wirklich kaum auszuhalten.
Das ist ein Kommunikationswissenschaftler, Hill hier.
Was soll er sagen? Er ist Kommunikationswissenschaftler, aber ich als und ich sage mal, ich habe in Altenrepublik viel über den Zusammenhalt. Es ist nicht das Gerede, sondern es sind die wirklich ökonomisch unterfütterten Gesten, die wir haben. Das ganz un... also Kommunikationsbegriff ist weit, aber hier verengeln die das ja auf das gesprochene Wort. Das ist völlig falsch. Das gesprochene Wort bringt überhaupt gar niemanden zusammen.
Da sind wir aber ja inzwischen angekommen. Das war ja auch der Vorschlag eigentlich von Ferda Attermann. Wir müssen jetzt nur noch mal neue Worte für Armut und Arme finden, damit wir die nicht mehr diskriminieren. Dann brauchen wir die Armut gar nicht mehr abschaffen. Ich würde auch sagen, es ist mir vollkommen egal, wie Leute mich ansprechen und was sie sagen und mich tätowieren. Ich will einfach das doppelte Honorar.
Geld und Geselligkeit. Und nicht Gerede.
Ilona und Claudia, wenn die irgendein WIR-Gefühl empfinden sollen, ich würde sagen, viele Leute brauchen das auch gar nicht, aber wenn sie es empfinden sollen, dann brauchen die ein paar hundert Euro mehr zum Leben. Dann haben die ein WIR-Gefühl. Dann gehen die nämlich irgendwo hin, wo Gesellschaft stattfindet, auf Marktplätzen, in Bars, in Theatervorstellungen, Konzerten, was auch immer. Und dort erleben sie ein WIR. Alles andere ist reines Geschwätz. Aber noch einmal der Off-Kommentator.
Eine Nation auf der Suche nach Orientierung. Wie kommen wir gemeinsam gestärkt durch die Krise? Auch auf den Bundespräsidenten wird es weiter ankommen.
Kompletto abschaffen, alles.
Wir wollen den Bundespräsidenten abschaffen.
Und die Fernsehanstalten, die ihn so beobachten.
Wir lieben ja das Öffentlich-Rechtliche, aber das Radio und das ist Staatsfunk. Das muss man sagen. Ich möchte diesen bösen Begriff jetzt mal in den Mund nehmen und zitiere deswegen jetzt aus dem Gegenstandpunkt diesen Part. Da heißt es, auf diese Weise erbringen Journalisten ihre gesetzlich geschützte Vermittlungsleistung zwischen der Herrschaft und ihrem Volk, auf das sie sich als ihre Basis und ihr Mittel bezieht. Indem sie die Politik kritisch beobachtend begleiten, ihre Kundschaft mit den Sorgen der Regierenden befassen und sie, ohne dass es für diese Berufsausübung einer parteipolitischen Absicht bedürfte, mit parteilicher Information über die Welt versorgen. Sie pflegen mit Zustimmung und Dissens zur laufenden Politik den Standpunkt der staatsbürgerlichen Anteilnahme und wirken als entschiedenen demokratischer Nachrichtendienst nach Kräften daran mit, die Gegensätze zwischen Regierung und Regierten ideell aufzuheben, die informierten Bürger für die Drangsaale der Obrigkeit zu vereinnahmen und den Zusammenhang und Zusammenhalt zwischen dem Vorstand des Gemeinwesens und seinen gewöhnlichen Mitgliedern der Gestalt zu stärken, das erfolgreiche Öffentlichkeitsarbeit den Herrschaftskarakter demokratischen Regierens glatt zum Verschwinden bringt. Das ist aus dem Gegenstandpunkt. Das ist diese marxistische Zeitschrift, die damals das schrieb im Zuge von WikiLeaks. Und ich finde, in dieser Überspitzung ist es zumindest, was das Interview hier anbelangt, treffend, treffender könnte es gar nicht sein. Nochmal Tina Hassel.
Will jetzt überhaupt nicht treiben. Aber wenn wir jetzt nochmal, weil wir kommen zum Schluss, wenn man sagt, braucht unsere Demokratie mehr direkte Beteiligung? Bräuchte es Bürgerräte, bräuchte es einen Bürgerrat im Bellevue z.B. der Siebelräte?
Ich finde es ganz toll, diese Debatte über Bürgerräte, weil sie ja eine Debatte ist, die im Kern darüber geht, die können wir mehr Engagement für Demokratie generieren.
Bürgerräte, unser Lieblingsinstrument zur Rettung der Demokratie.
Sagen wir Ilona Bescheid ab sofort, Mittwoch abends per Zoom Bürgerrat zwei Stunden.
Und wir hören uns noch die Abmoderation an, die einen in meinen Augen Eigenlob beinhaltet.
Danke, Herr Bundespräsident. Das war nämlich unser Bericht aus Berlin mit dem Bundespräsidenten hier aus dem Schloss Bellevue schon wieder. Das waren große Fragen in zunehmend rauen Zeiten.
Große Fragen? Oh, das ist wirklich toll. Danke, Tina Hassel, für die großen Fragen. Also bei Katar, da man sich darauf verständigt im ZDF, wir machen das aus Mainz, weil sonst zu viel Nähe. Mit welcher Selbstverständlichkeit man hier das Schloss Bellevue einfach zu seinem Fernsehstudio macht für diese Szenerie, ist auch komplett hinterfragungs- und kritikwürdig. Denn das darf man gar nicht machen.
Eine ökonomische Ungleichheit, die so massiv ist und man spricht das nicht an. Man spricht nur über solche kommunikativen Fragen.
Das ist pure Ideologie.
Ich sag mal so, um es ganz kritisch zu sagen, diese Sache fand statt, so wie Matthias Döpfner sich sagte, ich hätte gerne mal ein Gespräch mit Mark Zuckerberg. Was mache ich? Ich mache eine Themenwoche. Bei Springer ist jetzt Silicon-Valley-Woche und es gibt einen Silicon-Valley-Springer-Preis, keine Ahnung, und wir zeichnen Mark Zuckerberg aus, weil dann kommt er dafür her und dann kann ich mit ihm eine Stunde reden. So war das ja hier auch. Die Redaktion entscheidet sich, kommt, wir machen jetzt eine Themenwoche zum Thema WIR und dann fragen wir den Bundespräsidenten auch bei uns. Und dann kann er ja nicht nein sagen. Also haben wir dann ein Gespräch mit dem Bundespräsidenten, das ist auch cool, weil dann haben wir sonntags 18 Uhr, da war noch immer dieser Bericht aus Berlin, läuft, was zu senden. Also es ist einfach inhaltliche Programm Gestaltung, die hier gemacht wird, sozusagen auf sicheren Grund, da wo sich alle wohlfühlen, weil sie wissen, der Bundespräsident muss dann schon liefern. Irgendwie wir stellen ihm große Fragen und dann ist das ein Selbstläufer. Jetzt wechseln mir nicht das Medium, aber das Genre. Die Tagesthemen berichten über die Jugend. Und wir hören mal raus, das wurde hier nämlich, das wird dann mal so ein bisschen verschleiert. Ingo Zamparoni informiert uns jetzt auch darüber, warum sie dieses Thema auswählen.
Corona, Klimawandel, Krieg in Europa, es sind nicht gerade leichte Zeiten, die wir in jüngster Vergangenheit erleben. Und eine besondere Belastung stellt dieser Riesen- und Katastrophenkanon offenbar für Jugendliche hierzulande dar, die auf die Frage, wie geht es denn so, vielfach wohl so antworten würden. Das zeigen zumindest die heute veröffentlichten neuesten Ergebnisse der Langzeitstudie Jugend in Deutschland, die seit 2020 regelmäßig die Gefühlslage abfragt. Und dieses Mal ist sogar eine für viele ziemlich neue Belastung hinzugekommen.
So, wir sahen Smileys, die hier traurig oder sauer dreienblicken.
Das mal als ästhetische Anmerkung. Jugend, ach komm, mach Smileys hinten rein, ein paar Emojis. Und der Aufhänger für diese Berichterstattung ist, irgendwer hat halt eine Studie gemacht. Eine Agenturmeldung kam und meinte, hier liegt eine Studie vor. Dann dachten wir uns, da stehen bestimmt Zahlen drin. Also haben wir das jemandem gegeben und er hat uns das mal kurz aufbereitet. Und dann hat noch die Technik gesagt, wir können noch Smileys hinten einblenden. Ja, also das hat nichts mit, wir als Redaktion haben festgestellt, dass, und es gibt so ein Gerede und dann, ja, die Mütter bei uns in der Redaktion sind auch ganz betroffen, was ist denn mit den Kindern los und so. Nee, es ist halt morgens einfach aufgeblockt, so in der inhaltlichen Agentursauce. Also haben sie sich gedacht, na gut, wir haben mehr Ressourcen, wir fahren mal los, sie besuchen irgendeine Schule und sie haben zum Beispiel noch junge Menschen gefunden, die noch Pfleger werden wollen, obwohl wir ja schon mitgekriegt haben, okay, die sind ja alle total besorgt, wenn man nur kurz reinschnuppert in den Pflegeberuf, zum Beispiel, weil der Bundespräsident einen verpflichtet, sich jetzt der Gesellschaft nochmal anzudienen.
Nur ganz kurz, dafür hat er sich auch nochmal ausgesprochen.
Das ist jetzt sein Thema.
Das ist sein Thema und er möchte auch, dass die Debatte nicht so schnell verendet. Er möchte, dass sie jetzt beherzt geführt wird.
Er hat ja wenigstens anders als die CDU nicht mehr nur die Jugend. Das ist ja eine kleine Neuerung.
Auch die Älteren.
Mal gucken. Jetzt sind wir hier bei der Jugend. Es gibt noch Menschen, die Pfleger werden wollen.
Ihr Job wird es bald sein, sich um andere Menschen zu kümmern. Hier in Mönchengladbach werden sie zu Pflegerinnen und Pflegern ausgebildet. Auch wenn sie sich um einen Job keine Sorgen machen müssen, so haben sie trotzdem Angst vor der Zukunft wie viele ihrer Generation.
Das finde ich ziemlich gut. Ich werde ja auch häufiger gefragt. Aber wenn es so wenig Jugendliche gibt, dann werden die ja schon mal nicht arbeitslos. Dann sage ich, ja das stimmt, sie werden nicht arbeitslos. Aber sie machen sich trotzdem Angst, weil sie jetzt schon sehen, also die Ilona, die mich hier ausgebildet hat, die kriegt nur 200 Euro im Monat. Was kriege ich denn dann? Und sie sind ja in den Schulen unterwegs. Was ist der größte Druck, der auf den Jugendlichen lastet, dass zu wenig mit ihnen über den Zusammenhalt gesprochen wird oder ökonomische Zwänge? Wir hören mal nach.
Für 71 Prozent der Befragten der neuen Jugendstudie sind steigende Preise die größte Belastung.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt Angst, dass es noch teurer wird alles. Und gerade jetzt, wo ich noch in der Ausbildung bin, natürlich in zwei Jahren bin ich fertig, aber in der Zeit habe ich natürlich auch nicht so viel Geld. Und da muss man auch wirklich die Münzen dreimal drehen, wenn man den Supermarkt geht und gucken, kaufe ich jetzt den Käse für vier Euro oder lasse ich lieber?
Ja, das sind genau die Aussagen, die ich jetzt zwei Monate lang eingesammelt habe bei jeder Veranstaltung, die ich gemacht habe.
Ob der Bundespräsident noch irgendwas zum Thema Zusammenhalt sagt, ist allen Beteiligten komplett Schnuppe egal.
Man sieht ja auch so schön, es wird ja dann immerhin in den Tagesthemen aufgegriffen. Wo findet es gar nicht statt? Bei Funk, bei dem Ländler, der sich an junge Leute richtet, die genau davon betroffen sind, die sich diese Fragen auch alltäglich stellen. Kann ich mir den Käse leisten oder nicht? Da findet das gar nicht statt.
Wir brauchen ja nach der Klima-RF nicht auch noch eine Inflations-RF, die auf die Straße geht und sagt, ich klebe mich mal am Supermarkt fest, bis mir Sachen gegeben werden. Weil du sagst, hier wird das thematisiert. Wir gucken gerade den ganzen Bericht. Ach so, das war es dann schon. Sonst mache ich ja immer Clips aus Sachen, aber in dem Fall habe ich einfach nur Schnitte reingemacht, weil ich ja auch nichts wegschmeißen wollte. Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir hier noch eine halbe Stunde drüber reden, sondern das ist auch leider in zwei Minuten schon vorbei. Also wir hören uns hier weiter an der Schule um.
Viele junge Menschen haben das Gefühl, im Dauerkrisenmodus zu leben. Auch hier in einer Gesamtschule in Köln empfinden das viele Schüler. 64 Prozent der befragten jungen Deutschen beschäftigt vor allem der Krieg in der Ukraine und die Dauerkrisen. Sie klagen über eine hohe psychische Belastung.
Was mich so am meisten eigentlich gerade beschäftigt, ist so dieses, dass immer mehr kommt. Aber dann passieren halt einfach so verheerende Dinge. Also ich weiß, also klar Klimawandel sowieso, aber jetzt auch im Iran, Katar, das sind alles so Dinge, die mich einfach so sehr beschäftigen, so wütend machen. Ukraine, klar, total, das ist, also ich komme da auch gar nicht mehr mit.
Ja, und hier steckt ja auch immer drin Zukunft sozusagen. Diese Krisen gehen ja nicht einfach wieder weg, nur weil Christian Lindner sagt. Also das finde ich auch witzig, wir haben jetzt 30. November. Wir sind also noch 31 Tage davon weg, dass wir einen Weltzustand haben, von dem Christian Lindner sagt, die Krisen sind vorbei, wir haben die Schuldenbremse wieder ein. Das ist jenseits von allem, aber das ist so der gängige Tenor gerade im politischen Berlin und hier hat man mal einen Gesamtschüler besucht. Und jetzt, und das finde ich wirklich gut, wir haben ja nicht nur Carla Hinrichs gehabt, sondern egal wo man hinschaut mittlerweile, wenn eine Kamera läuft, sind die Jugendlichen in der Lage, Auskunft über sich zu geben und zwar ordentlich. Ich würde sagen, wir hören jetzt hier eine Kandidatin, liebe Tina Hassel, die kann man mal einladen. Zu der kann man nach Hause fahren, das Wohnzimmer in ein Studio umbauen und dann kann man mit der mal eine halbe Stunde reden. Nicht nur so ein O-Ton oder so eine Wortspende, sondern einfach mal eine halbe Stunde reden.
Wir gehen auf Demos anstatt irgendwie in Discos. Eigentlich darf man in der Jugend ausprobieren, Fehler machen, frei sein, dumme Sachen auch machen. Und dass unsere Generation total bedacht ist und reflektiert, wo ich nicht sage, dass es schlecht, aber in dem Ausmaß, das es angenommen hat, finde ich es problematisch.
Genau der richtige Punkt.
Und es ist ja nicht nur so, dass wir hier Elsa hören, die das über sich sagt, sondern üblicherweise schauen ja die ARD und WDR und wer auch sonstigen, die NDR-Journalisten, wenn nicht Julia Friedrichs unterwegs ist, die könnten ja sogar mit den Eltern dieser Kinder reden und würden dann hören, das ist total crazy, ich wünsche mir, dass mein Kind mal über die Stränge schlägt, mal was Verbotenes macht, mal irgendwie.
Wir hatten ja genau diesen Clip und wir wussten, wir hatten ja eine Bundesregierung, die sagt, bleibt auf dem Sofa und wir hatten Journalisten, die dann noch Beifall geklatscht haben zu dieser Aktion und dann hatten wir einen Supermarkt, der einen Werbespot gemacht hat von einer Mutter, die sich für ihren Sohn wünscht, dass er mal rausgeht, was Dummes tut, sich verliebt, dass Herz gebrochen wird und lebt.
Weil eigentlich sind die alle so abgeklärt wie sie. Ich wünsche mir Disco, aber muss auf eine Demo gehen, um, wie Karl Heinrich sagt, diesen Kack hier weiterzumachen, nur weil die Bundesregierung nichts sieht. Also es ist wirklich dramatisch. Wir hören hier einen Studienautor, der seine eigenen Ergebnisse noch mal einschätzt.
Diese Krisen tragen dazu bei, dass Jugendliche sich fühlen, als würden sie aus einem Tunnel gar nicht mehr herauskommen, erklärt eine der Studienautoren Simon Schnetzer. Bei vielen Jugendlichen mache sich ein Gefühl der Hilflosigkeit breit.
Wenn hier nach einer Krise keine Ruhephase kommt und es kommt wirklich eine Krise auf die nächste, das zehrt an diesen Abwehrkräften und das ist, was diese Dauerbelastung so schwierig macht. Und im extremen Fall eben auch zu diesen schwierigen Ergebnissen führt wie Suizidgedanken und Hilflosigkeit.
So, wir nähern uns zum Ende dieses Berichts. Übrigens 21.11. in den Tagesthemen, kann man, weil es immer jemand nachschauen will. Als ich jetzt diese Annivilsendung mit Carla Hinrichs auf YouTube besprochen habe, kamen so ganz viele, die dann dieses provokative, ja aber die wissen, also die fragt ja Anniville zurück, haben sie denn eine Idee, was man machen kann? Also die haben sozusagen selber keine Idee, war dann so der Vorwurf.
Ja, man muss es jetzt noch gerade erklären für die Leute, die es nicht gesehen haben. Es ist so, dass Anniville sagt, die Mehrzahl der Deutschen ist gegen die Proteste von letzter Generation, aber eine große Mehrheit ist dafür, mehr für den Klimaschutz zu tun. Müsste man dann nicht andere Aktionen machen, die alle mitnehmen und dann sagt Carla Hinrichs, ja welche denn sagen sie es mir, dann machen wir das. Und dann schaut sie nur groß, leider redet dann Hinrichs weiter, man müsste wirklich dieses Schweigen dann mal aushalten und sagen, ja dann sagen sie doch mal bitte, was sollen wir dann machen? Denn es ist ja erstaunlich, wie jetzt auch, Fridays for Future rezipiert wird. Vor zwei Jahren war der Tenor, das sind die, die die Schule schwänzen, die sich nicht einbringen, die sollen noch mal lieber innovativ werden. Und jetzt sagen die Bürgerlichen, ja Fridays for Future, das war ja was ganz anderes, also das fanden wir ja gut, aber jetzt mit der letzten Generation, das geht zu weit. Es ist so erstaunlich, wie sehr das Gedächtnis auf ganz kurze Intervalle getrimmt ist und man gar nicht mehr diese Perspektive einnehmen will. Und es ist umso erstaunlicher, dass das in den Talkshows noch immer so durchgeht, dass man eigentlich da eine Protagonisten hat, die dann auch erst mal noch lang und breit erklären muss, dass sie auf den Fundamenten dieses Rechtsstaates steht. Also sie muss sich erst mal selbst erklären, dass sie keine Terroristin ist. Und dann beginnt die Debatte mit drei Politikern, die nichts zu sagen haben. Oder wenn sie was sagen, dann ist es höchst bedenklich. Und eigentlich müsste man sagen, man redet jetzt nur mit solchen Aktivisten und würde das andere völlig raus drängen und würde nur sagen, wir machen hier diese Veranstaltung. Wir müssen nicht das große Wir herstellen als Journalisten. Wir müssen nicht jetzt den informierten Bürgern sagen, so ticken eure Regierenden und deswegen habt ihr das zu akzeptieren. Sondern man muss eigentlich sagen, wir machen hier Journalismus. Wir zeigen die Problemlage. Wir empfehlen den Leuten in Berlin, in der Regierung sonntags abends eins zu schalten, damit die wissen, was da los ist. Und dann können die ja mal schauen, ob sie ihre Politik daran anpassen.
Genau. Und das ist nämlich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Einige haben dann versucht, mich auf Twitter zu provozieren, oder auch andere, mit diesem Hinweis, das ist gar nicht der Fernsehmoment des Jahres, weil Clara Hinrichs zeigt ja nur, dass sie selber keine Rezepte hat, weil sie muss ja Anne Will fragen. Das war auch nicht der Punkt. Die Jugendlichen demonstrieren ja nicht unbedingt für Klimaschutz im Sinne von, sondern sie demonstrieren ja gegen die nicht handelnde Regierung. Und das ist ja ein kleiner Unterschied. Wenn man die Jugendlichen fragt, wie würdet ihr denn das Klima schützen, die haben ja alle Ideen bis hin zu, ja wir haben ja sogar völkerrechtliche Verträge, um deren Einhaltung wir uns einfach nur kümmern, oder für die wir uns einsetzen. Und deswegen war die Frage an Anne Will so richtig, denn die Frage, die im Raum stand, war ja, warum gibt es eine Bevölkerung, die eigentlich Klimaschutz will, und warum handelt die Regierung trotzdem nicht? Und die Antwort ist ja, weil es im Fernsehen falsch dargestellt wird, weil Anne Will nicht über das Klima redet, sondern immer nur über irgendwelche Politiker, oder das so zum Thema macht. Und dann haben wir ja gesehen, irgendwie das Tagebuch des Bundespräsidenten in Neustrelitz und der ganze Quak. Was aber nicht vorkommt, ist die nicht handelnde Regierung. Und das gibt es jetzt hier noch mal zu strapazieren, diesen Punkt, dass die Jugendlichen Ideen haben, wie man das Klima rettet und schützt. Und wahrscheinlich sogar so extrem drauf sind, dass sie sagen, ich akzeptiere auch zwei Stunden am Tag Stromausfall. Das muss nur in meinen Tagesablauf eingeplant werden, aber dann kann ich damit arbeiten. Dann weiß ich, okay, jetzt mache ich mal nicht die Waschmaschine an. Ich kann auch fürs Klima bis morgen früh damit warten. Alles eingepreist. Und in diesem Clip wird jetzt noch mal der Klimawandel thematisiert. Und wie sehr die Jugend zum Zuschauer der nicht handelnden Politiker und gar nicht für sie interessierenden Medien ist.
Eine dieser Dauerkrisen, der Klimawandel. Er beschäftigt 55 Prozent der Jugendlichen weiterhin stark.
Meine Ängste liegen eher so, dass ich nicht weiß, ob es die Zukunft überhaupt gibt und nicht, was für einen Job ich kriege. Na ja, seit Jahren wird auch darüber geredet, dass Klimakrise und wir müssen alle aufhören, mehr Auto zu fahren, CO2 zu sparen. Aber irgendwie macht es niemand. Ich fühle mich da schon hilflos, weil ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann nichts machen.
Sie kann gar nichts machen. Sie kann nicht wählen. Sie kann nicht Auto fahren. Sie kann nicht anders wählen. Und sie kann nicht aufhören mit Autofahren, weil sie fährt nicht Auto und sie kann nicht wählen. Und sie erlebt aber eine Gesellschaft um sie herum, die ihr alles zerstört.
Und selbst wenn man wählen kann, merkt man ja, wie sehr man ausgeliefert ist.
Wenn man dann erst mal wählen kann, dass man schon an der dritten Bundestagswahl teilnimmt und immer noch zu den jüngsten 10 Prozent gehört in Deutschland.
Ja, und dann merkt man, dass die Dinge ja nicht umgesetzt werden. Siehe GASTI mit Katar.
Genau. Also wir haben hier ein Ausgeliefertsein der Jugend einer Welt, in der sie gar keine Wirksamkeit entfalten können. Und im Moment, wo sie mal eine Straße blockieren, ist dann gleich Weltuntergang angesagt. Also das fällt alles komplett aus dem Rahmen. Es läuft komplett aus dem Ruder. Und als Antwort hier im Bundespräsidenten zu haben, und die Redaktion, die meint, da müssen wir mal mehr drüber reden mit dem Bundespräsidenten, über das Wir, ist die völlig falsche Antwort. Wir haben ja noch das Fazit des Berichts.
Am Ende wünschen sie sich vor allem eines, dass sie mit ihren Ängsten und Sorgen wahrgenommen werden und ihre Stimmen mehr Gewicht bekommen in der Politik.
Und um das abzuschließen, ein Clip, der mich wirklich ein bisschen schockiert hat, weil das dann auch so unter ferner liefen irgendwie läuft. Wir haben jetzt eine Lage, in der die Jungen politisch aus dem Spiel genommen sind. Also sie können nicht wählen, sie können nicht aufhören mit Auto fahren, sie haben gar keine Wirksamkeit, sitzen in ihren Klassenräumen, auch ihre Lehrer erzählen ihnen nur, ja, es ist halt so und so und es ist alles schlimm und leider können wir alle gar nichts machen und auf die Schule hört ja sowieso keiner. Und um das noch mal zu komplettieren, mit dem ökonomisch ausgeliefert sein, diese jungen Menschen brauchen in, sagen wir mal fünf Jahren Wohnungen für sich, weil irgendwann will man das Elternhaus mal verlassen und so weiter, das eigene Leben dann begründen. Und wir hören jetzt jemanden von der kommunalen Baugesellschaft in Ludwigshafen, also ein Bauherr, der städtisch ist, staatlich, der also alle Sicherheiten mitbringen kann, die man institutionell so, weil er vertritt die Stadt. Und er sagt jetzt gerade mal, wie die Bautätigkeiten so laufen.
Wir sind ausgebremst dadurch, dass wir im Moment kein einziges Projekt vernünftig kalkulieren können. Wir finden keinen Generalunternehmer, der eine Festpreisbindung eingeht. Wir finden auch keine Bank, die zu einem annehmbaren Zinssatz eine Zinsgarantie über mehrere Jahre ergibt.
Was bedeutet das für die Leute, die auf der Suche nach Wohnraum sind?
Dass sie im Moment von uns nichts angeboten kriegen können. Das ist, denke ich, auch unser größtes Problem, dass Bauen über viele Jahre hinweg teurer, wesentlich teurer wird, als es heute ist. Der Boom am Bau ist vorbei.
Die Lage auf dem Immobilienmarkt dürfte sich weiter verschlechtern.
Also hier ist nicht der Boom am Bau vorbei, sondern hier wird gerade gar nichts gebaut. Die urbanen Zentren sind, wie sie sind.
Selbst die schrecklichen Wohnungsgesellschaften bauen ja nicht. Diese Zinserhöhungen sorgen dafür, dass die Eigenheime nicht realisiert werden, sorgen aber auch dafür, dass die Leute sagen, bei solch hohen Zinsen, also die Unternehmer sagen, es lohnt sich das nicht mehr, Bauprojekte auf den Weg zu bringen. Hinzu kommen dann noch Arbeitskräftemangel, und Energiepreise. Und damit sind diese herren Ziele, die da mal gesteckt wurden, wie viel neue Wohnungen entstehen werden, kann man eigentlich jetzt schon ablasen. Und das ist auch wiederum ganz, ganz eng gebunden an das politische Handeln. Also das mit dieser Zinspolitik, die ja die ganze Zeit eingefordert wurde, dass man jetzt damit eine solche Situation geschaffen hat. Also es ist noch nicht mal dieses kapitalistische Bauen mehr für die sinnvoll erscheint und dann baut man lieber nichts. Also das ist ja auch interessant. Also es wird dann lieber weiter mit der Knappheit gearbeitet, weil da kann man ja, wenn diese Knappheit dann großes, immer noch Leute ausbringen, dass sie für 35 Quadratmeter 1200 Euro zahlen müssen.
Genau. Die jungen Menschen, die wir da gerade in der Schule gesehen haben oder die sich gerade festkleben, die dachten, die haben nur mit Klimawendel zu kämpfen, aber die werden politisch und ökonomisch einfach ins Niemandsland entlassen. Ohne Handlungsmöglichkeit, ohne Handhabe, in irgendeiner Richtung. Es wird für sie keine Wohnung geben, es wird für sie keine politische Mitbestimmung geben, selbst wenn sie dann ins Wahlalter aufrücken. Sie werden mobilitätsmäßig ausgebremst, Autos werden sich nicht leisten können. Dieses Monatsticket kostet dann 50 Euro statt 10.
Das ist ja übrigens auch ein Inflationsgebot. Das ist ja auch so erstaunlich.
Genau, der Inflationsausgleich.
Bürgergeld hat man nicht an die Inflation gebunden. Aber das 49-Euro-Ticket, da soll es dann einen Inflationsausgleich geben. Das kostet dann in drei Jahren wahrscheinlich schon 56 Euro.
Wie kann man denn an eine Maßnahme, die man macht, um die Inflation zu senken, einen Inflationsausgleich dranhängen? Das ist doch so dumm. Das versteht niemand.
Ja, das ist wie Bier ohne Alkohol, aber mit Alkohol.
Niemand versteht das, was hier gerade passiert. Es ist wirklich verrückt. Also ich verstehe es jedenfalls nicht. Und es ist auch schwer, also ich kann, sag mal so, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass mir das jemand so erklären kann, dass ich das verstehe. Nee, der Bundespräsident hat es mir auch nicht erklärt.
Ja, dann müssen wir vielleicht mal, wenn der Bundespräsident hier nach Frankfurt kommt, dann gehen wir mal hin und fragen das mal genau nach.
Da soll man eine Ortszeit geben.
Der soll uns das erklären. Vielleicht kann er uns auch noch irgendwas abkaufen. Vielleicht möchte er dann Salonmitglied werden.
Das wäre doch mal was fürs WIR. Das Neue Zwanziger WIR.
Wir schenken dem Bundespräsidenten zu Weihnachten einen Salon.
Es ist jedenfalls genau das richtige Jahrzehnt, um Schicksalsgemeinschaften zu gründen, im Salon oder sonst wo. Ich glaube, das ist nicht gut.
Es wird jetzt nicht besser, es wird jetzt global schrecklich. Und zwar müssen wir über das Militär sprechen. Und ich bin durch Zufall darauf gestoßen. Dieser Zufall sieht so aus. Ich lese in der Bahn immer vorwiegend zwei Zeitungen als erstes. Ich kaufe mir dann immer, bevor ich in die Bahn einsteige, Zeitungen. Und zwar das Handelsblatt und die junge Welt. Dann hat man eine ganz gute Übersicht über das, was im globalen Kapitalismus so läuft. Und da las sich in der jungen Welt von einem Auftritt von Charles A. Das ist ein wichtiger Mann im amerikanischen Militär. Und der hat bei so einer Konferenz eine Rede gehalten, die dann an die Öffentlichkeit ging in Form von Statements. Das heißt, diese Rede gibt es nicht irgendwo ganz zu erleben. Und normalerweise findet die Konferenz auch ganz ohne Öffentlichkeit statt. Aber hier hat man sich entschieden, dass es so wichtig ist, was gesagt wird, dass man das offiziell veröffentlicht hat. Und wir hören da jetzt mal rein.
Die US-Navy Admiral Charles A. Kommandeur der US-Strategie Kommandos ist, hat seine Ansichten an die Naval Submarine Leagues 2022 annualen Symposium und Industrie-Updates- November und wurde verabschiedet durch DOD, das ist die Vorgabe.
Am 3.
November hast du aber eine sehr tolle Vortragsweise für das Thema.
Das ist aus so einem YouTube-Channel, der sich nur mit Militär und Defense und sowas auseinandersetzt.
Klingt so, als wäre da so ein kleiner Themenfanatist dran.
Ist ein Nerd. Ich habe den Text dann, also dieses Statement dann auch abgerufen. Es ist also korrekt, was er da zitiert. Also es geht jetzt um Charles Anthony Richard, genannt Chess, Jahrgang 1959. Er ist Admiral bei der Navy und ist seit 2019 United States Strategic Command. Und er war früher bei der U-Boot-Flotte und ich sage mal so, er sieht nicht gerade wie ein Spaßvogel aus. Und das hören wir jetzt auch mal hier.
Ja, Richard sagt, diese Ukraine-Krise, die wir jetzt innen sind, ist nur ein Wärmeup, die große, also ein Konflikt mit China, kommt. Und es wird nicht sehr lange dauern, bevor wir in Wegen, die wir schon lange nicht getestet haben, werden.
Das ist nun das Warm-up, das wir jetzt erleben. Der eigentliche Konflikt ist mit China. Jetzt verwundert uns das nicht besonders, aber verwundern darf einen, dass jemand in dieser militärischen Position das so explizit ausspricht. Das ist ja auch schon eine Drohung, die sich in die Zukunft richtet. Weiter heißt es dann in dieser Rede von Richard.
Er sagte, wir müssen einige rapide, fundamentale Veränderungen in der Art, wie wir die Gefahr dieser Nation, die USA, in der Art, dass Konflikt mit China ein anderer Kaliber von Konflikten zu Russlandes All-Out-Invasion von Ukraine, das begann im Februar. Es sinkt langsam, aber es sinkt, weil sie, China, die Möglichkeit in den Feld schneller als wir sind.
Das finde ich interessant, denn wir haben ja jetzt im November auch dieses G-20-Treffen gehabt, wo sich Xi und Biden getroffen haben und danach unterschiedliche Kommunikäse von jeder Seite und von der einen Seite hieß es dann Biden, der hat ja auch eine Pressekonferenz dazu gemacht. Ja, wir sind in einem Konflikt, aber werden ihn sozusagen anständig austragen, in der Hoffnung. China will das auch. Während China dann gleich schriftlich nachschob in dem Gespräch, wurde thematisiert, dass die Amerikaner ihre Demokratie haben und wir unsere, die chinesische Demokratie. Also du würdest sagen, der Systemstreit, ja, wir sind hier in einem offenen Systemstreit. Wir sagen zwar beide, das ist ihr Demokratie, aber da unterscheiden wir uns sehr. Alle bleiben bei ihren Positionen und, Chia hat ja sogar noch mal den Anspruch auf Taiwan untermauert und dass man da auch militärisch keine Rückzieher macht oder so. In der Ansicht ist das interessant, dass diese High-Level, also semiöffentliche Kommunikation, die noch mal so auf, ja, es ist ein Systemstreit, aber nicht unbedingt kriegerisch, man bleibt einfach nur auf seinen Positionen, aber versucht es dann sozusagen friedlich zu lösen, hier noch mal nachgeschoben wurde, so in einer Art Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, dass man sich auch militärisch, auf amerikanischer Seite...
Das Ministerium auf der Seite veröffentlicht, also nicht irgendwo geleakt, sondern ganz offiziell veröffentlicht. Und ich war auch etwas verwundert, als ich die Süddeutsche las, die auch dieses Treffen zusammenfasste. Und da gab es die Schlagzeile, Kalter Krieg ist jetzt doch nicht... Ne, wie war das? Ist aufgeschoben oder findet doch nicht statt. Und dann dachte ich mir, ne, wir erleben eigentlich eine ganz dramatische Zuspitzung. Klar, die chinesischen Militärausgaben sind hoch. 2010 hat man noch 106 Milliarden ausgegeben. Inzwischen ist man bei knapp 300 Milliarden anbelangt. Es gibt Prognosen, so wurde das zum Beispiel in der Wirtschaftswoche publiziert, dass es 550 Milliarden 2030 sein könnten. Zugleich muss man aber sagen, ist Amerika immer noch das Land mit den allerhöchsten Militärausgaben, also sehr, sehr mit weitem Abstand. Dann kommt China und dann kommt weiter abgeschlagen, Indien, Großbritannien, Frankreich und dann kommt Deutschland 2, 7 Prozent und so weiter. Es ist aber so, dass tatsächlich die Kriegsschiffe und wir haben ja hier das mit einem Navy-Mann zu tun, sich jetzt nicht mehr, also die Chinesen haben mehr Kriegsschiffe als die Amerikaner. Und auch bei den Panzern nähert man sich wohl an Nuklearsprengköpfe, natürlich nicht, da gibt es einen großen Abstand. Aber wozu hier jetzt aufgerufen wird, ist eigentlich diesen System Wettstreit zu erkennen. Und wir müssen auch da ja fragen, von welchem Wettstreit reden wir? Denn zunächst einmal ist ja das tatsächlich so, diese Staatsform in China ist eine sehr andere als die im Westen oder in den USA. Aber das geht ja zunächst einmal aneinander vorbei. Die Frage ist, worum geht es jetzt in diesem Konflikt? Geht es in diesem Konflikt, was ist, wenn die Taiwan erobern? Also geht es um die Menschen in Taiwan, würde ich in Zweifel ziehen. Es geht natürlich da um eine geopolitische Absicht, dass, wenn die erstmal in Taiwan sich nehmen, was kommt dann als nächstes? Und es geht ja auch um diese berühmte Tokididis-Falle. Ist es möglich, dass ein Reich aufsteigt wirtschaftlich, während das andere absteigt oder zumindest nicht weiter wächst und dass es irgendwann Pari Pari steht oder die einen stärker plötzlich sind? Also die Chinesen stärker sind als die Amerikaner. Und damit ist man wirtschaftlich geschwächt und natürlich dann auch nicht mehr so souverän. Aber das ist natürlich alles, wenn man in diesen Doktrinen denkt der Staaten, die sich immer konfrontativ gegenüberstehen müssen. Das ist ja eine, sagen wir mal so, nicht besonders aussichtsreiche Zukunft für Elsa, Clara und auch für uns beide im Übrigen nicht. Für niemanden. Wenn man jetzt sagt, gut, die erhöhen die Militäretats, die anderen auch. Und jetzt gibt es diesen Aufruf, wir müssen schneller, schneller, schneller werden. Es wird hier vielleicht auch nicht alles nur der Abschreckung nur dienen, sondern die Frage ist auch, schlittern wir da in einen Konflikt hinein, der dann kriegerisch wird.
Richard hat sich über die Abhebung der USA mit dem Umfang der nuklearen Deterrenz gegen China beitragen können, die das kommunistische Regime mit einer all-outen Invasion von Taiwan verhindern.
Der nukleare Krieg, den wir jetzt thematisiert haben im Hinblick auf die Ukraine, ist eine permanente Betrohung und diese Betrohung wird wirklich größer. Was mich eigentlich, nachdem ich diese ganzen Clips geschnitten habe, so gewundert hat, ist, dass wir zwar verschiedene Klimaproteste haben, aber wir haben gar keine Proteste zur Abrüstung. Und damit meine ich nicht diese alte Generation, die da jetzt nochmal rauskommen soll, sondern dass bei den jungen Menschen offenbar dieses Problem so gar nicht da ist. Denn ja, das mit dem Klimawandel wird schlimm werden, aber es ist nicht gleich der Feuerball, in den sich die Erde verwandelt. Während wir wissen, wenn es zum Nuklear-Krieg kommt, dann brauchen wir nicht mehr über Stromsparen nachdenken.
Also vielleicht ist es schwierig, gerade eine einheitliche Linie zu finden, in der Hinsicht, dass man sich beim Klima doch einig ist, die Regierung macht so wenig. Und die, die das nicht finden, sind so ein paar Erstwähler, die die FDP vorziehen und die dann so darüber lächeln, aber jetzt keine Gegenpositionen einnehmen. Während man bei diesen Kriegsthemen schwierig zu argumentieren ist, hat Richard David Brecht zum Beispiel erlebt, wie es ist, für Abrüstung oder irgendwie so einen pazifistischen Einschlag zu haben, wie man da doch auf den Deckel kriegt die ganze Zeit. Wahrscheinlich haben sie da Formulierungsschwierigkeiten. Da kann man nicht einfach sagen, Paris kommt völkerrechtlich, ich hab's doch schon unterschrieben.
Aber eigentlich bräuchte man neben so einem Paris-Abkommen, das dann nicht eingehalten wird, auch wieder ein Abrüstungsabkommen. Sowas gibt es natürlich und da gibt es immer wieder Tagungen. Aber wenn wir da weiter hingehen, also ich bringe mal noch einen Clip von Richard, den vor zwei Monaten ist er dann öffentlich aufgetreten bei einem Symposium und das gibt es auch bei YouTube zu sehen. Hier ein kurzer Auszug.
We don't know where China's gonna wind up. Things are changing on us very rapidly. And then finally, as we like to say a lot around STRATCOM, all ahead flank.
Volle Kraft voraus.
Also, ich sag mal so, ich will jetzt nicht klein machen das Thema. Aber also die Kriegsgefahr da auf diesem Level, weil Qi, also sag mal so, uns droht kein irrationales Handeln wie bei Putin. Dass man einfach so ein Land überfällt, ohne vorher genau zu wissen, werde ich von meinen Generalen gerade belogen über meine eigene Mannesstärke auf dem Felder oder nicht. Das droht hier bei Qi nicht. Da gibt es auch viel Korruption und wahrscheinlich wissen die auch nicht so ganz genau, wie kampffähig sie gerade sind. Aber nach Taiwan sind 160 Kilometer See. Und See, klar, mit einem großen Schiff kann man fahren, aber man braucht zehn Jahre um Schiff zu bauen und die Rakete muss nur einmal richtig treffen und dann kommt man keinen Meter mehr weiter und liegt da irgendwie unfähig im Wasser. Also das ist alles total leicht zu zerstören, hat man damals schon ein paar Harber gesehen. Die fliegen einfach hin und machen die halbe Flotte kaputt. Und die Chinesen, also gerade Qi mit seinem großen Projekt, er ist ja jetzt, er weiß ja jetzt, er ist noch für mindestens fünf Jahre chinesisches Schicksal verantwortlich und vielleicht sogar noch mehr. Und er hat jetzt gesehen, okay, meine erste Strategie einfach Wirtschaftswachstum zu sorgen, ging nicht auch. Dann kam zum Glück Corona und ich kann jetzt mit Corona-App-Repression das so weitermachen, geht auch gerade nicht besonders gut auf. Und er braucht jetzt so einen dritten Weg, vielleicht schafft er es wieder mit, okay, dann impfen wir euch jetzt alle im halben Jahr durch, dann öffnen wir und dann machen wir wieder das mit dem Wirtschaftswachstum, um euch zu befrieden. Irgendwie so. Also die innenpolitische Problemlage ist gerade so groß, dass man glaube ich nicht das Land gerade auf so einen Weg einrichten kann. Und auf der anderen Seite, kühl durchkalkuliert, kann man wirklich mit einem Krieg mehr erreichen, als wenn man so nach und nach die nächsten 30 Jahre einfach Taiwan ökonomisch übernimmt, so wie man auch in Hongkong. Einfach ökonomisch. Ja, indem man einfach sagt, dann öffnen wir jetzt so eine Art Finanzströmung und machen hier noch so eine Art chinesischen IWF. Und dann kaufen wir so langsam Hongkong auf und so weiter und so nach und nach. Und die Welt, ja gut, passiert halt und so. Und dann wird sogar Hongkong umgedreht, weil man fährt aus Hongkong raus und ist direkt in Shenzhen, wo es ja auch wieder ein bisschen moderner zugeht. Wir haben es ja gelesen, wo man nicht direkt im Hardcore China Mainland ist. Und so ist das ja auch bei Taiwan.
Das halte ich auch für möglich. Nur gibt es ja noch neben Taiwan oder anderen Grenzkonflikten diese Frage der Tukidides-Falle, ob das aushaltbar ist für ein System, wenn eines Weltreichs, wenn es sehr reich ist und dann ein Aufsteigendes da ist und dieses andere tatsächlich den Aufstieg schafft, stehen die sich auf Augenhöhe dauerhaft gegenüber oder führt das notwendigerweise, so wie bei Tukidides beschrieben, in den Krieg? Und kann man dieser Falle in irgendeiner Weise entkommen, wenn wir aber jetzt in einer Konstellation leben, wo alle und die Rüstungsausgaben steigen in allen Ländern, sagen wir müssen uns bis an die Zähne bewaffnen, wo alle auf diesem sehr hart konfrontativen Kurs sind, wo man auch gerade von alten Militärexperten hört, Naja, so im Kalten Krieg, da waren diese Kanäle doch eigentlich noch besser zwischen Russland und Amerika zum Beispiel. Da stelle ich mir schon Fragen für die Zukunft. Und dann ist das gar nicht, wer übertritt da jetzt gerade eine Landeskanzlerin, sondern das ist eher dann so, dass sich das strukturell ergibt.
Also es gehört dazu, dass es so ein Kräftegleichgewicht geben muss, was ja dann wieder bedeutet. Ja, man formuliert für sich immer den Wunsch, den anderen zu üben, und irgendwann schafft es auch der andere nicht mehr mitzuhalten. Also ja, das Sowjetunion so weit passiert, als dann irgendwann Star Wars angesagt war und so, war man dann ökonomisch dann doch relativ am Ende. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Amerika so weit abschwächelt, dass die irgendwie... Ich bin von ihren 700 Milliarden WER-Etat abgerücken. Und die Lücke ist ja nun noch groß, bis China da auf dem Niveau auch aufgeholt hat. Deswegen bleibt für mich als Kriegsgefahr eigentlich nur dieses irrationale Moment. Und das sehe ich eigentlich nur in Amerika. Wenn dann Ron DeSantis oder so der Präsident wird.
Und der ja nicht der liberalere Trump ist oder so.
Und das ist Trump im Quadrat, ja. Wir gehen nachher noch mal auf die Midterm-Election zu sprechen. Also da sehe ich bei Amerika. Aber am Ende, die haben ja diesen Militärapparat. Wir hören ja gleich noch Milley, den du dankenswerterweise uns hier mal vorführst. Ich glaube, da arbeiten relativ viele Leute, die es eigentlich wissen, um was es geht. Und das ist ja auch bewusst Öffentlichkeitarbeit von den Politaritzen.
Ganz sicher. Und es ging hier schon um Geschwindigkeit. Und um Geschwindigkeit geht es auch Mark Milley. Dass Mark Milley jetzt hier in diesem Podcast vorkommt, liegt auch nur daran, dass ich bei dieser Lektüre der Jungen Welt las, dass Mark Milley Interessantes gesagt habe zum ersten Weltkrieg im Vergleich zur Gegenwart. Dazu kommen wir zum Schluss. Es gibt wirklich ein grandioses Finale möchte ich.
Sehr gut.
Das liegt nicht an mir, sondern an Mark Milley. Und wir beginnen aber damit.
Müssen wir noch sagen, wie Mark Milley ist? Weil es ja wirklich eine wahnsinnige Insanführung.
Genau, sag kurz, wer Mark Milley ist.
Also Mark Milley ist der Chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff. Also während wir eben hier einen Chief of Staff gehört haben, nämlich Richard als, in welcher Funktion, Central Command oder so.
Genau, United States Strategic Command.
Es gibt ja irgendwie sieben oder acht Waffengattungen, neuerdings Trump hat ja eingeführt, auch noch Weltraum und so. Und die Spitzen dieser Waffengattungen jeweils, also die militärischen Oberbefehlshaber dieser militärischen Sanktionen, führen gemeinsam ein Beratergremium, das direkt dem Präsidenten als Superchef des Militärs untersteht. Und diesem steht Mark Milley vor. Und er ist damit auch der Sheriff von Washington DC weil Washington DC ist ja unter Bundesverwaltung, was man ja mit Berlin auch mal machen könnte, damit es da ein bisschen vorwärts geht. Und dann gab es ja interessante Szenarien, wie zum Beispiel Trump braucht eine freie Straße, um irgendwie eine Fotoshow vor der einen Kirche da zu machen. Und dann ist Mark Milley dafür zuständig, die Straße freizuräumen und patrouilliert dann noch so. Also das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Er hat sich dafür dann entschuldigt, dass er das gemacht hat.
Genau, dass er sich da Fernsehbilder, Medien, also Werbebilder für Trump produziert hat und so. Er hat sich also da immer Unabhängigkeit gewahrt. Und ich glaube, es lohnt sich noch zu sagen, während Trump regierte, stand er im intensiven telefonischen Austausch mit der Mehrheitsführerin im Repräsentantenhaus, Nancy Pelosi. Weil Kriegsangelegenheiten sind ja Kongressangelegenheiten. Das hat ja erst mit George W. Bush, der dann irgendwie Patriot-Akt und so weiter, dass dann der Amerikaner so auch auf Befehl des Präsidenten irgendwie anfühlt. Aber so richtige Kriegseinsätze sind Kongressangelegenheit, wozu auch der Einsatz von Atomwaffen gehört. Und dann gibt es eine sehr interessante Szene, wie Mark Milley Nancy Pelosi sagt, wir können dem Befehl eines Präsidenten entgegennehmen, geben den aber nur mit inhaltlicher Würze weiter. Also wenn wir nicht davon überzeugt sind, dass geben wir die entsprechende Anweisung so weiter, dass unklar ist, wie es der Befehl auszuführen, aber der nicht ausgeführt. Also da gibt es Stolpersteine. Der amerikanische Präsident kann nicht einfach so eine amerikanische Atomwaffe abschließen, ohne das Militär nochmal inhaltlich darüber schauen zu lassen. Und bis hin zu, und das ist dann auch eine Szenerie, die Nancy Pelosi schilderte, wenn wir einen Befehl bekommen, den wir nicht unterstützen wollen, haben wir uns untereinander schon vereinbart, dann treten wir in dem Moment, wo wir den Befehl bekommen, zurück. Was da bedeutet, da muss erst mal der nächste aufrücken, aus dem Stellvertreteramt ins Amt. Das kostet Zeit. Wenn der dann im Amt ist und den Befehl bekommt, tritt der auch sofort zurück. Und dann hat man so eine Kaskade organisiert, dass es irgendwie sieben Tage dauern würde, bis so ein Befehl wirklich der Militär ankommt, und dann ist eh vorbei und so. Also diese ganzen Vorsichtsmassnahmen.
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass du das nochmal hier so sagst, denn es geht hier ja um den nuklearen Krieg und die Ernsthaftigkeit des Krieges. Das ist so ein furioser Auftritt bei dem Economic Club of New York. Da war er zu Gast. 3000 Klicks bei YouTube. Es wurde in den Medien ein bisschen, in den amerikanischen, reportiert.
Ich habe auch nichts davon mitbekommen, obwohl ich echt ein Sensorium für Mark Milley habe.
Wir hören jetzt erstmal etwas, was er sagt zur Natur und zum Charakter des Krieges.
Wir sind in der grundlegenden und profunden Veränderung in dem, was ich den Charakter des Krieges nennen, in der menschlichen Geschichte. Die Natur des Krieges ist nahe. Die Fog der Kriege. Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht verändern.
Deswegen auch von dir, ich hab ihn auch gesehen, im Westen nichts Neues. 2022 unterscheidet nichts von 1914, 15, 16, 17. Man liegt drei Jahre in einem Schützengraben, am Ende hat man 200 Meter Raumgewinn gemacht. Genau das sehen wir gerade in der Ukraine. 100.000 Tote auf jeder Seite für nichts. Und das, sagt er hier, Nature of War, das ist genau so. Da werden die Waffen ausgetauscht und 100 Jahre sind in das Land gezogen. Ansonsten ist das alles dasselbe.
Was sich ändert, ist der Charakter des Krieges.
Ich habe einen Fitbit, einen GPS-Watch, wir haben alle kinds, wir haben Mikrofone, wir haben alle kinds von Elektronik in dieser Runde. Die andere Sache ist deine Möglichkeit zu schießen.
Das Sehen hat sich verbessert. Alles kann gesehen werden. Und alles, was man sehen kann, kann man auch treffen. Die Präzision hat zugenommen. Das ist der Wandel des Krieges, des Charakters. Und jetzt geht er einen Schritt weiter. Was kommt auf uns zu?
Add in to that artificial intelligence. So add in to that, one of the key things in warfare is decision making and the ability to process massive amounts of information and to do that at speeds faster than your enemy. You want to get there first as with the most. So Napoleon was famous for waking up at like two in the morning, writing his operations orders at two in the morning, delivering him to his field marshal.
Wir haben eben schon Admiral Richard gehört. Schnelligkeit ist das entscheidende. Er sagt genau das auch noch mal mit historischem Bezug. Napoleon morgens früh, die die Krete verfasst und die Briten waren noch beim Tee und wussten gar nicht, wie ihnen geschah.
Ja, wir haben ja in, also wir reden ja immer noch über schwere Waffen und so, als ob das den großen Unterschied in der Ukraine macht. Dabei sind es diese kleinen Drohnen. Als jetzt die Russen auch mit diesen Drohnen anfingen, war das ja plötzlich Thema. Ja, aber ohne noch mal darauf hinzuweisen, dass die Ukraine auch schon die ganze Zeit mit diesen lauernden Drohnen, die einfach schon in der Luft sind, also wo die Geschwindigkeit so schnell ist, weil die ist einfach schon da. Und in dem Moment, wo sie sieht, zielt sie und schießt und stört sich einfach darunter. Also das ist nur noch 500 Höhenmeter, die sie bewältigen muss. Ziel erledigt.
Und die These von Milley ist jetzt mit KI, mit Robotik, werden wir eine so große Beschleunigung haben, aber nicht nur westliche Staaten, sondern alle Staaten, die da investieren, dass es sehr schwer wird, diesen Wettlauf zu gewinnen. Da es sich so rasend schnell dann verändert, dass man nicht mehr sagen kann, wir müssen also auch sehen, dass wir das übernächstes Jahr entwickelt bekommen, sondern dann ist übernächstes Jahr der Vorsprung schon so weit, man liegt so weit zurück, wir kennen das ein bisschen von der Ship-Produktion, dass man da nicht mehr hinterherkommt. Das ist etwas, was ihn umtreibt, er führt das dann länger aus, wie dann auch so ein soldatenloser Krieg stattfinden könnte. Aber das bedeutet immer, dass es noch Opfer gibt, also diese Natur des Krieges bleibt. Und jetzt geht es noch mal um diese zeitliche Perspektive, was sich verändert hat. Er vergleicht jetzt mal einen Soldaten im alten Rom und einen im Mittelalter.
Aber du hättest keine Ahnung, was du in der Jahrzehnt 2000 ansehen würdest. Ich würde sagen, dass die Zeit in der Kurve der technologischen Entwicklung, der industriellen Entwicklung, auf einer vertikalen Kurve war.
Das ist, es ist unglaublich, dass wir hier so einen großen Philosophen in diesem Amt haben. Aber eben im Amt. Und wir haben ja schon davon gehört, dass die Chinesen Auslandspolizei Filialen betreiben, um hier einfach nachzugehen, wenn hier irgendwas ist. So wie ja auch Putin mutmaßlich, das wurde ja gerichtlich jetzt auch bestätigt, irgendwelche Mörder durch Berlin laufen lässt, die sich dann einfach jemanden schnappen oder Saudi-Arabien plötzlich in der Türkei da jemanden ermorden lässt und so weiter. Was ja genau diese Kriegshandlungen eigentlich sind, die wir immer noch verbuchen unter ja das ist so der Terror oder sonst irgendwas. Wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht genau, was hat es denn damit auf sich.
Oder den kann die Hackerangriffe, die ja auch wo sie staatlich sind, eigentlich Souveränität verletzen.
Genau, damals der Eingriff in diese iranischen Aufbreitungsanlagen, wo dann auch Schirrmacher nochmal bei Frank Rieger fragte, kannst du uns das mal aufschreiben? Da haben die irgendwie so ein bisschen Code abgedruckt und so, um das mal zu zeigen, wie das so läuft. Das sind alles Kriegshandlungen. Und ja, so ein Typ, der, sehen wir ja auch im Westen nichts Neues, kommen erstmal in eine Kraserne, ziehen sich so an, holen sich ein Bahnticket, gehen so los. Also die wissen für sich, wie sie einen Krieg erkennen, nämlich auch da, wo man aus dem Zug aussteigt, in den Schützengraben geht und dann geht der Dienst los, 8 Uhr morgens, nach dem Befehl vom Balkon oben, zieht man drei Kilometer ins Land, steigt in den Graben und dann ist Krieg. Und ja, 2000 Jahre später, also Krieg ist mittlerweile überall.
Nun wird ein Eishockeyspieler zitiert, Wayne Kretzky, kenne ich natürlich nicht, scheint aber sehr berühmt zu sein.
Und die Geschwindigkeit, bei der diese Dinge uns kommen, die Militär, die die schnellste und schnellste, und du musst nicht perfekt sein. Und du wirst es nicht richtig bekommen. Wir müssen zugeben, dass wir es nicht richtig bekommen. Nicht wo der Puck ist. Das stimmt.
Das ist, was er jetzt dem Militär auf die Fahnen schreibt.
Das ist das, was wir jetzt immer hören in Katar. Er kann das Spiel gut lesen.
Ach ja.
Spielt blind ab. Er weiß, sein Kollege ist neben ihm. Er spielt einfach rüber, ohne nochmal zu gucken. Und trotzdem kommt er bei ihr an. Im Sport sieht man es ja häufiger. Bedeutet hier aber auch, gerade in dieser Verbindung mit dieser Technologie, kürzester Intelligenz und so weiter, die Yvonne Hofstetter hat ja ein Buch darüber geschrieben. Sie wissen alles oder so heißt das. Genau. Und das ist sehr gut. Weil das auch mit so einer Kriegsszenerie beginnt. Da war halt ein U-Boot und da ist ein Passagierflugzeug und da hat man einfach geschossen und dann später festgestellt, ach so. Und die Logik, wenn man es ökonomisch ausbeutet für die Werbeindustrie, heißt ja einfach nur, wir brauchen halt 51 Prozent, müssen wir recht haben. Da machen wir das alles ganz oft und ganz schnell und dann fällt halt eine Marge von ab. Diese Technologie auf Krieg übertragen heißt aber, wir liegen um 49 Prozent der Fälle tödlich falsch. Und das ist natürlich ein Problem. Wenn er hier so zugesteht, ja, wir werden es wahrscheinlich nicht immer richtig machen, wir wollen einfach nur schnell sein. In Verbindung mit dieser Werbetechnologie, wo ja dieses ganze Targeting und so weiter herkommt, ist natürlich blöder, wenn da einfach die 41-49-Prozent-Losung übernommen wird.
Das wird dann Kollateralschaden genannt und sein Selbstverständnis ist da ganz klar. Und da frage ich mich schon, wenn das mal keine Tucki, die das Falle ist.
Das ist eine sehr finstere Zukunft.
Wenn man so daran denkt, dass ja nicht man sagt dann immer so, wir müssen unsere Sicherheitsarchitektur stärken. Aber das bedeutet, dass man sich darauf einstellt, für unsere gesamte Lebenszeit, also die wir haben und wie alle, die uns hier zuhören haben, dass man in einem ständigen Szenario ist, wo man aufpassen muss, dass nicht etwas eskaliert. Das ist eine sehr unangenehme Situation. Ich finde es jetzt auch berühgend, dass Xi offenbar weniger irrational ist als Putin. So mutmaßen wir, wenn ich mir Siro-Covid ansehe, bin ich mir zum Teil auch wieder nicht sicher, aber so mutmaßen wir, dass es da um was anderes geht. Aber es ist eine sehr, sehr schwierige Perspektive. Wir sind jetzt gerade dankbar, dass man dann jemanden hat wie Milley, der sehr verantwortungsvoll ist, wie wir jetzt gleich besonders merken werden, wenn es um das Nukleare geht. Aber man ist auch extrem ausgeliefert. Also wir hatten jetzt eben die jungen Menschen, die ihr ausgeliefert sein bemerken, weil sie gar nicht wählen und sonst was können. Aber wir sind als Bürger dem extrem ausgeliefert, wenn man denkt, ja, es wäre jetzt doof, wenn dann mal nicht so ein Mark Milley sitzen würde, sondern jemand, der ein bisschen heißblütiger unterwegs ist.
Und das ist ja nochmal ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Wir haben ihn jetzt so als Philosophen dargestellt, ist er ja auch. Aber es hat natürlich mehr so eine praktische Aussagekraft. Der ist ja kein Philosophe. Er ist ja ein Soldat. Was bedeutet, sein Thema ist nicht irgendwie so eine Vernunft oder sowas, sondern Rationalität. Wenn du jetzt sagst, wir wünschen uns irgendwo keine Irrationalität, wir kennen ja seine Rationalität. Er will einen Krieg gewinnen. Das ist sein Rational. Und so kennen wir das auch bei Qi. Wir wissen, er möchte in diesen Geschichtsbüchern stehen. Wenn er Vergangenheit ist, so wie heute Mao, soll immer noch an ihn gedacht werden können. Das, was immer Putin unterstellt wird von irgendwelchen Ukrainern, die sagen, er muss ja noch Putins Geschichte schreiben sollen können, also kann er die nicht wegbomben mit einer Atombombe. Das würde ich sagen, das gilt dann bei Qi schon. Dass er dann doch das Geschichtsbuch mit seinem Namen drinnen, dem Weltuntergang vorzieht.
Würdest du, wenn du ein Versicherungsunternehmen wärst, dir da eine Versicherung geben?
Am Ende müssen wir es irgendwie machen.
Ja, wir sind dem ausgeliefert.
Wir sind dem komplett ausgeliefert.
Und wie kontrastreich die Welt ist, will ich nur mit einem ganz kurzen Clip zeigen. Wir sehen diesen Clip, weil er auf Russisch ist und aber englische Untertitel hat. Dieser Clip ist reine russische Staatspropaganda vorgetragen von Vladimir Solovyov, der bekannt ist.
Man kennt ihn mittlerweile, glaube ich.
Inzwischen, als der Propagandist, der Putin noch übertrifft, wie man jetzt zum Beispiel hier sieht. Wir versuchen das mal zu übersetzen.
Darauf wird Bezug genommen.
Dass Deutschland sich auch vorbereitet oder solche Worst-Case-Szenarien mal durchspielt, wie wäre das, wenn man nuklear angegriffen wird. Und dieser Propagandist sagt nun, but I think there is no problem to use tactical nuclear weapons against Germany in case war is declared. Und dann sagt jemand, der ihm widerspricht, aber da gibt es ja kein Ziel und dann sagt er noch mal, there is a target, a very simple one, Germany is the target.
Also nicht Stuttgart, sondern ganz Deutschland.
Ja, ganz Deutschland ist dann das Ziel der Nuklearn. So wird darüber gesprochen. Es ist ja widerwärtig, anders kann man es nicht sagen. Deswegen gehen wir zurück zu jemand, der vernünftig ist, zu Mark Milley. Wieder bei diesem Forum wird er gefragt, wie das denn nun sei mit diesen Nuklearentrohungen aus Russland.
Ein weiterer Frage aus Ukraine. Wie ernsthaft wirst du in der US-Militär das Nuklearengut nehmen?
Das sind interkontinentale Ballistikmissile, große Megatonnen-Typen. Wenn du über niedrige, oder nonstrategische, oder taktische Nuklearengutwaffe sprichst, dann sprichst du über Dinge, die in 1-2 Kilotonnen sind. Das sind 10-15 Kilotonnen. Eine 1-Kilotonnen-Waffe wird den Blast und den Feuer bis zu etwa 500 Meter zerstören.
Diese strategischen nuklearen Waffen sind also auch Waffen, die ein flächendeckendes Desaster bedeuten. Das ist nicht.
Ja, es gibt vor allem dadurch, dass es so Strahlung hinterlässt.
Ja, es gibt keinen taktischen Einsatz.
Das kann man ja nochmal verbinden mit dieser Zeitkomponente, die Mark Milley vorher nannte. Die Amerikaner haben ja immer, wenn die Drohung kam, das wieder so ein bisschen runtergedampft, in denen sagten, na wir beobachten jedenfalls keine Vorbereitung russischer Waffen, Atomwaffen, was ja auch wieder bedeutet, es dauert wahrscheinlich eine Weile, bis sie bereit wären und in dem Moment würde sich Amerika auch bereit machen, dann würde der Charakter des Krieges sich selbst der Natur des Krieges ausliefern, weil dann macht einer Fehler und dann fliegen die halt automatisiert aufeinander zu. Aber solange es nur Gerede ist, aber noch keine Vorbereitungen beobachtet werden können, bleibt man noch im Charakter des Krieges, im modernen Charakter und fällt nicht zurück ins mittelalterliche Nature of War.
Auch hier wieder ganz klar, man muss eine Unterscheidung treffen, wie du das jetzt eigentlich schon getan hast. Da gibt es auf der einen Seite die Rhetorik, dazu sagt Milley.
Das finde ich schon mal sehr schön, dass du auch sagt.
Das sollte man nicht tun. Man sollte diese Rhetorik gar nicht bedienen, aber es ist jetzt nur Rhetorik.
Das hat man ja auch bei G20 jetzt eigentlich vereinbart. Also die Russen und die Amerikaner stimmten darüber überein, dass nicht nur der Atomwaffeneinsatz, sondern auch das Gerede darüber geächtet wird. Und der Russen haben natürlich nur Lavrov geschickt und er war dann auch nicht da, als das besprochen wurde, aber da war man sich doch recht einig.
Nochmal Milley jetzt, neben der Rhetorik gibt es auch die Handlungen.
Ich weiß, dass wir noch nicht 100% von allem sehen, aber wir sehen noch nicht physische Faktoren und Indikator der imitierten Nutzung eines Nuklearwebens in diesem Moment. Aber das ist keine Warnung, es ist nicht sogar eine Ergänzung, es ist nur eine Statement, ein Faktor, was wir so farb sehen. Wenn du über Nuklearwebens mit niedrigem Nutzung reden, dann reden wir über relativ kleine Teile von Erzeugung. Du kannst das nicht visuell sehen, oder hier reden und so weiter und so fort. Es wäre ein enormer Schritt, wenn jemand das tun würde.
Man kann gar nicht alles sehen. Wir haben eben erfahren, wir können alles sehen. Aber hier gibt es doch auch wieder Sachen, die man nicht sehen kann oder die man zumindest so verdeckt erst mal gestalten kann, dass man es nicht mitbekäme. Man nimmt es sehr ernst. Er hat es jetzt mehrmals formuliert so. Und wir haben Macron im Ohr, wir haben Kissinger im Ohr, wir haben Merkel im Ohr, die alle sagen, man muss den Putin sehr ernst nehmen. Und wir haben eine deutsche Debatte noch immer dadurch dominiert, dass man sagt, also wir wollen uns ja wohl mal nicht jetzt von unserer Angst treiben lassen. Jetzt aber nur mal mutig rein in das Manöver. Es ist für mich alles nicht nachvollziehbar. Wir haben es hier mit dem Experten überhaupt zu tun, der die ganze Zeit in großen Entscheidungen drinsteckt und das seit Jahrzehnten tut. Und der sagt, ja, wir nehmen das sehr ernst. Und der weiß auch, dass man nicht mal gerade was los tritt. Ich meine, das war ja etwas ganz Eigenartiges. Wir hatten ja mal kurz den 3. Weltkrieg auf Twitter in diesem Monat. Die, die nicht bei Twitter sind, werden das ja gar nicht mitbekommen haben. Es gab ja diese Raketen, die in Polen eingeschlagen sind. Und sofort waren Lammstorf, Strack-Zimmermann und dergleichen, waren alle sofort auf dem Trip. Jetzt müssen wir, als würde man sich gerade zu freuen, ob wir noch noch es schaffen, den 3. Weltkrieg anzuleihen. Und jetzt kommt diese tolle Pointe, meine persönliche. Ich war an dem Abend unterwegs, war nicht bei Twitter, mache morgens Twitter und hatte also auch von diesen Raketenmeldungen gar nichts mitbekommen. Stehe morgens im Hotel auf, mache ein Laptop an. Und da war der 3. Weltkrieg dann schon abgesagt. Und dann habe ich das retrospektiv nachvollzogen, war froh, dass ich es an dem Abend nicht mitbekommen hätte, weil es einen ja dann doch vielleicht ein bisschen aufbringt. Und da hat man gesehen, wie verantwortungslos solche Leute sind. Da kann man ja nur drei Kreuze machen, dass die jetzt keine entscheidenden Positionen haben, also entscheidende Position im Sinne von Entscheidungspositionen, wenngleich die ja auch deinen meditärausschüssen und ThinkTanks und was weiß ich sitzen. Es ist unverantwortlich. Deswegen hier nur ganz kurz die Antwort von Mark Milley, der ja auch gefragt wurde. Und wie bereitet man sich darauf vor? Und wie bereitet man sich darauf vor? Ja, man kommentiert es einfach nicht.
Man kommentiert es nicht. Nur als Frage in den Raum gestellt, Strack Zimmermann hat diesen Tweet gemacht und hat dafür auch auf den Deckel bekommen intern. Und ich hab seitdem auch nichts mehr von ihr gehört. Ich sehe jetzt hier so bei Google News, ja, sie hat sich nochmal zum Einbürgerungsrecht jetzt, FDP, Vizem, NTV, Frühstart, Strack Zimmermann hält neues Staatsbürgerrecht und so weiter. Aber ihr eigentliches Leib- und Magenthema hat sie so ein bisschen ausgespart seitdem, jetzt im November, glaube ich.
Ja, man ist ja etwas ruhiger geworden, vielleicht auch ein bisschen bunt getrieben.
Ja, das ist auch so bekloppt. Man findet gar keine Worte dafür, dass man auf Twitter, ich fand es auch, es ist vor allem so ein, also ich war in dem Abend klettern und dann habe ich so gesehen, in der Chatgruppe tauchte das so auf und ich so, ja gut, okay. Zwei Waffen, die irgendwo in, man hat ja dann relativ zügig festgestellt, es ist nicht mal ein Kilometer hinter der Grenze, also die können auch in der Luft abgeschossen sein, tun es oder unten.
Man fragt sich, ist Putin wirklich so doof, ist das denkbar?
Genau, ist es denkbar, ist es warum? Also es ist ja immer noch ein Krieg, da passieren halt so Sachen. Aber so sehr ich dann doch diesen, ja kann halt passieren, das war sofort so ein Rational, diesen Strack Zimmermann Tweet kann ich mir nicht erklären. Das ist so dumm, ich habe heute schon häufiger dieses Urteil gemacht, das ist so dumm, aber es ist wirklich so wahnsinnig dumm. Man sitzt doch nicht als Ausschussvorsitzende des Verteidigungshaushalts, des Haushaltsausschusses abends an Twitter und macht da Kommentierung für etwas, das man in den Nachrichten sieht, ohne mit irgendeinem mal kurz zu telefonieren, zu sprechen, nachzufragen oder sonstiges. Also jeder darf alles kommentieren.
Einfach nur auf der Fernsehzuschauerposition ist sie da, vergessen, dass sie Politikerin ist und sagt dann einfach auch, ja, hier brauchen wir aber eine Antwort.
Ja, vor allem, wie kann man denn in dem Moment, wo er hier sagt, schweigen, sagen, oh, jetzt mache ich eine kleine Show auf Twitter, das nutze ich so als Bitt.
Ja, denn sowas kann ja wirklich was auslösen. Also das können ja, es war ja, wenn man sich die Kuba-Krise ansieht, oft Missverständnisse, die nahe an den Amt kommen, haben das dann irgendein Militär aus Russland das verfolgt. Was die hier schreiben, sind wir da schon im Gefecht? Ja, dann legen wir mal los. Also es ist unverantwortlich. Wir kommen zu Milley noch einmal zurück. Und jetzt geht es darum, wann kann man mit Russland verhandeln? Darf man mit Russland verhandeln? Wir wissen, da ist die Position ja auch. Also wer Verhandlungen in den Mund nimmt, macht sich schon fast verdächtig. Mark Milley ist natürlich derjenige, der viel weiter denkt und viel größer denkt. Wir hören ihn.
Oder was sonst noch vorhanden ist, bevor du wirklich zu den Wettbewerben kommst?
Aber ich denke auch, es muss eine gemeinsame Beweglichkeit geben, dass die Militärwache in der wahrsten Sinne der Welt nicht durch militärische Gründe erzielt werden kann.
Ein militärischer Sieg ist nicht schaffbar für keine der beiden Seiten. Wenn man das sagt, dann macht man sich hochverdächtig, dann heißt es ja, willst du dann etwa nicht, dass die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnt? Und hier sagt jemand, ja im strengen militärischen Sinn ist das nicht machbar. Und jetzt führt er das aus und zwar anhand eines historischen Vergleichs.
Wenn du zurückkommst, wir verwenden die Welt als Beispiel.
Also wir sind jetzt im ersten Weltkrieg angelangt. Der Krieg, der Erste Weltkrieg, wurde sehr statisch und zwar sehr schnell. Übrigens dieses klappende Geschirr im Hintergrund. Das sind nicht wir, sondern das sind die Gäste bei diesem Forum, die gemütlich speisen und sich ein bisschen was vom Weltkrieg erzählen lassen.
Ja.
So, by Christmas 1914, January 1915, you got a war that is not winnable anymore militarily.
Das kann man alles im Westen nicht neu auch nachvollziehen. Die älteren, die da die Jungen ins Manöver schicken und sie selbst müssen eigentlich oder haben auch erkannt, dass der nicht militärisch zu gewinnen ist. Und zwar sagt jetzt Weihnachten 1914. 1914 war das schon klar.
Es gab schon.
Viele Menschen, die sich auf die Stimme aufstimmen, die sagen, ne wir müssen sehen, dass wir den Krieg beenden.
Wir haben schon zu viel investiert, das ist dann die Logik.
Hat man aber nicht gemacht und dann ging es folgendermaßen weiter.
Also wurde die Warsch von 1915, 1916, 1917, 1918 los. Menschen, die von August bis Dezember getötet wurden, wurden 20 Mio. Du hast die Zustimmung für den Wachstum von Nazismen, Faschismen und allem.
Besser kann man es nicht ausführen.
Also, da sitzt ja jetzt echt Mark Milley und sagt, Krieg ist echt das Dürmste, was sie machen können. Wenn sie mich engagieren. Ich hab's schon mal, Bruce Willis in dieser Rolle, in der Ausnahmezustand in New York, wo die sind, diese Angriffe statt, also wie Terror dann am zweiten, am 11. September, aber nicht so groß, sondern so mal hier, mal da. Busse werden gesprengt und dann sagt er den ja auch, so als Militärchef, versuchen sie bitte noch, alles außer mich zu engagieren, weil wenn sie mich engagieren, dann mach ich das hier militärisch. Dann richte ich hier Lager ein und sperre die Straßen ab und dann ist nichts mehr da und dann sagen die Politiker, komm wir machen das jetzt militärisch. Und ab dann ist das diese Eigenlogik inklusive, und das wird ja im Film ganz wunderbar dargestellt, die ganze Erzeugung der Wut, die dann auch zum zweiten Weltkrieg führte. Also das ist, so wie Mark Milley hier über den ersten Weltkrieg spricht, sollte man sich das echt noch mal anhören, wenn man zu leichtfertig über den Krieg in der Ukraine spricht.
Und auch dieser Bezug zum ersten Weltkrieg, der ja auch hier dann ein bisschen verpönt war. Nein, nein, man kann das nicht vergleichen. Und er macht das dann. Und es gibt nur eine Schlussfolgerung, und das ist auch der letzte Clip dann daraus.
Seize the moment. Das ist ja diese deutsche Vorstellung, beziehungsweise so gehen ja mal alle in Verhandlungen rein. Da ist ja Silensky ganz vorne dabei. Bedingungen, die dazu führen, dass man miteinander spricht, während man ja eigentlich reingeht. Wir sprechen erst mal einfach ohne Bedingungen.
Das war ja im Kalten Krieg so, dieses Sprechen, das gesprochen wird.
Kommunikationskanäle nutzen und es kann dann während des Sprechens sozusagen die Möglichkeit entstehen. Das ist ja im Westen nichts Neues. Das ist eigentlich nur Netflix-Film, oder? Kam der irgendwie noch mal im Kino so?
Der hatte nur so eine Kinopremiere, damit er auch für die Oscars sich qualifiziert, aber es ist ein reiner Netflix-Film.
Das ist ganz erstaunlich, wie Netflix sich da auch inhaltlich investiert, um das noch mal zu zeigen. Weil da kommt ja auch ganz wunderbar diese Dreigliedrigkeit. Man hat ganz unten diese einfachen Soldaten, die gar nicht wissen, was machen die eigentlich. Ach so, wir gehen halt alle so in den Krieg. Und dann ist man da plötzlich im Krieg. In so Schützengräben, wo keiner niemanden kennt und dann macht man halt so Befehle. Dann diese Mittelpositionen, also so irgendwelche Befehlshaber sind so in der Nähe, können Befehle zurufen und Motivationsreden halten, aber dann gehen sie zurück zum Tee und die jungen Leute gehen zum Krieg. Und dann völlig irgendwo fährt halt so ein Zug, wo wirklich diejenigen, die im Zweiergespräch sagen könnten, wir hören jetzt auf mit dem Blödsinn, nicht zueinander kommen, sich nicht vertrauen, stimmt die Übersetzung, was flüsterst du mir hier zu und so. Und da sieht man einfach, das ist die Gemengelage, die genau immer so ist, egal welches Zeitalter, welche technischen Möglichkeiten und so weiter. Diese Fußsoldaten, die müssen dann einfach da in den Krieg. Putin rekrutiert sie irgendwie aus dem Osten zusammen und bläst dann die große Rekrutierung in den urbanen Zentren ab, weil das hätte wahrscheinlich politisch nicht überlebt. Und die Ukraine, ja, uns mangelt es nicht an Menschen. Der Westen soll mal ruhig Material liefern, aber an Menschen mangelt es uns nicht. So, wir fehlen, uns fehlen nur Panzer. Also es scheint wirklich keinen Mangel an Menschen zu geben, so um so einen Krieg dann auch nochmal, also kann man sich jetzt auch schon vorstellen, wie das auch nächstes Jahr zu Weihnachten noch genauso weitergeht.
Ja, wenn man diese Perspektive sich mal von Mark Milley vergegenwärtigt, ja.
Die reine Strack-Zimmermann-Linie, wir machen das hier kriegisch, also wir fechten es aus, die führt dazu, dass wir auch 2028 wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie Kiew-Schwidersen-Raketen irgendwie runtergekommen sind. Also in deren Sicht ist das alles bekloppt. Wir haben ja eben schon über das Sterben gesprochen, weil Menschen sterben wollen. Manche sterben einfach, weil sie müssen, sie sind alt und so weiter. Es gibt noch eine Sterbetrenz. Vielleicht hast du es noch nicht gewusst. Ich habe es nicht gewusst. Es wird in meinem Umfeld recht wenig gestorben. Aber kurze Aufklärung, die Zahlen sind beeindruckend.
Putzen für den Feiertag. An alle Heiligen sollen die Gräber nicht nur hier in Wassenberg am Niederrhein ordentlich und aufgeräumt aussehen. Ein Friedhofsgrab ist nicht nur Gedenkort, sondern bedeutet schlichtweg auch Arbeit. Hecken schneiden, Unkraut jäten und immer wieder neue Pflänzchen. Doch viele möchten das heute nicht mehr. Zwischen den Doppelgräbern in Wassenberg klaffen deshalb diverse Lücken.
Wenn man früher um den Friedhof gegangen ist, gerade jetzt um die Jahreszeit, da war ein reines Kerzenmeer. Das ist heute vielleicht weniger geworden. Heute, wenn man über den Friedhof geht, die ganzen Leerstellen, da sieht man manchmal nicht so gut aus.
Beliebt ist stattdessen dieser neue Bereich mit Wiesengräbern. Mittlerweile entscheiden sich dafür 90% der Angehörigen.
Wir sind ja auch bedeutend globaler geworden. Die Leute leben teilweise, die Kinder oder Enkel, die leben hier gar nicht mehr, die arbeiten auswärts. Wenn man dann im heißen Sommer z.B. die Verpflichtung hat, 2- 3-mal die Woche das Grab zu pflegen, zu tränken, oder wie jetzt mit der Laubzeit abzuräumen, ist gar nicht zu bewerkstelligen.
Es gibt gar keine Sterbe-Friedhofskultur mehr in Deutschland.
Das wundert mich als Zahl. Ich weiß von diesem Trend, aber dass er so groß ist, das ist mir neu. Es sind genau die Gründe, die er aufführt, warum das so ist, und ich vermute, dass sich dieser Trend dann weiter durchsetzen wird. Ob es denn 100% sind oder nahezu. Ich will natürlich noch einen Stein haben. Ich will ja eine Erdbestattung und Stein.
Um den, was dich wohl selber kümmern müssen, denn alle anderen haben keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ja, das stellt sich ja dann bei mir. Du könntest ja immerhin noch deine Kinderliebpflichten und das testamentarisch festhalten oder so. Ich müsste dann so einen Fonds anlegen, dass da zehn Jahre draus jemand bezahlt wird, der dann diese Arbeiten verrichtet, die der Bestatter gerade aufzählt.
Ja, aus privatem Gespräch, wenn ich indiskritiziert sein kann. Aber letztens erst gehört, jemand wollte gesprengt werden. Das konnte natürlich nicht bewerkstelligt werden. Sprengungen von Urnen gibt es nicht in Deutschland, weil es breitet sich dann aus in der Natur. Aber es gibt verschiedene Trends. Und 90 Prozent sagen, Wiesengräber sind einerseits billig und die Tochter wohnt ja eh woanders und so. Daher auch keine Kerzen mehr, kein Kerzen mehr an Feiertagen. Der Soziologe Thorsten Benkel charakterisiert uns noch ein anderes Anliegen.
Der Friedhof verliert an Renomie und einen Schritt weiter geht es dann, wenn Menschen sagen, dieser tote Körper, der ist gar nicht mehr das Zentrum unserer Trauer und die Trauer muss sich darum gar nicht mehr bewegen. Also da wird der Friedhof weggelassen, da hat man auch nichts mehr zu Hause von diesem toten Körper, sondern da geht es darum, dass man sich einfach erinnert, mit Fotos, mit Videos und das ist der entscheidende Trend.
Das stimmt und ich kann es auch da an mir selbst sehen, selbst wenn ich jetzt so ein Verfechter des Grabsteins eben war. Ich bin natürlich auch keiner, der auf den Friedhöfen anzutreffen ist, wo ich der meinen gedenken kann. Das ist nichts, was für mich stattfindet an einem Grab.
Genau. Wir sehen ja kurz davor, dass wir alle ein Hologramm haben, ein Avatar, 3D und dann werden wir also konserviert, je nachdem. Facebook hat sich ja schon...
Wir sind ja konserviert. Wir schreiben Bücher, wir machen Podcasts, wir sind im großen Internetarchiv vertreten.
Wir können schon gar nicht mehr vergessen werden. Es geht ja für umso mehr Menschen, so mehr Zeit ins Land geht. Irgendwann wird man natürlich trotzdem vergessen, aber wir halten es mal fest, wir können nicht vergessen werden. Und genau, wir haben jetzt mit einem Trend zu tun, den Menschen reicht die Erinnerung oder ihr digitales Artefakt. Und damit sind wir beim Thema Ticketmaster. Was ist das Geschäftsmodell von Ticketmaster? So nennt sich der amerikanische Monopolist für Tickets. In Deutschland kennen wir Eventim. Gleiches Business, gleiche Monopolstellung. Noch anderes gebaren, aber wir gucken uns mal das amerikanische an, denn es ist wahrscheinlich trendsetend. Ticketmaster beschreibt sich selbst laut Werbevideo so.
Der Sound eines Gitarrenriffs bei 120 Dezibel. Wenn dein Star singt, was du fühlst und die Menge jubelt. Wenn dein Team den Titel gewinnt, zum ersten Mal seit 20 Jahren. Wenn du 738 Stunden darauf gewartet hast, dass sich der Vorhang hebt. Wenn du genauso sein kannst, wie du sein willst. Ticketmaster, dein Ticket für echte Emotionen.
So, du fühlst dich angesprochen, warum gehst du in die Oper? Weil du willst, dass dein Star singt, was du fühlst.
Buche ich aber über die Oper, nicht über Tickets, irgendwelche Dienstleister. Aber es ist, glaube ich, dann zum Teil auch damit wieder verbunden. Man wird dann weiter gelotst. Also bei der Oper Frankfurt weiß ich es jetzt immer noch nicht. Aber bei manchen wird man dann weiter gelotst. Und es sind viele Zahlungsdienstleister und sonstige Dinge, die da noch mit einer Rolle spielen, weshalb die Tickets dann teurer sind.
Ja, wir sagen das jetzt aus eigener Anschauung. Es ist nicht einfach, ein Ticket zu verkaufen, weil am Ende muss es irgendwie ankommen, vorzeigbar sein, es darf nicht übertragbar sein. Also alles, was wir so an Problemstellung haben, damit es am Ende auch funktioniert. Und man greift dann der Einfachheit halber so einfach auf Dienstleister zurück, dass ja eventim auch zum Beispiel sich anbot, das Impfen in Deutschland zu organisieren. Also diese Terminvergabe und so weiter. Da liegt also insgesamt recht viel drin. Und wir haben jetzt hier gehört, sowohl auf den Friedhöfen, das digitale Artefakt bleibt irgendwie dann doch noch ein bisschen präsenter und Ticketmaster verkauft sich hier selber als wir verkaufen Erinnerungen, Emotionen und so weiter. Davon will man ja auch was haben. Bevor wir nämlich jetzt in dieses Ticketmaster Problem einsteigen, was natürlich damit zu tun hat, dass Taylor Swift 52 auftritt im nächsten Jahr in Amerika und zwar nur in Amerika hat und die Ticketpreise dort zwischen 49 und 449 Dollar rangieren, was auf eine historisch beispiellose Nachfrage traf. Allein 3, 5 Millionen Menschen haben sich vorab verifiziert bei Ticketmaster, um überhaupt noch im Vorverkauf teilnehmen zu können. Und dann war alles so überladen, dass es nicht einfach nicht funktioniert hat. Und ihre Las Vegas Show Spitzenverkaufswerte auf dem Resale-Markt von 91.708 Dollar pro Ticket hervorbrachte.
Geben Menschen aus, um dann Taylor Swift live zu sehen.
Genau. Was dann dazu führte, dass die amerikanische Bundesregierung, allen voran David Cicillin, den kennen wir schon als demokratischen Kongressabgeordneten, der eine sehr gute Sitzung mit dem Silicon Valley damals geleitet hat und so, der dann hier mal twitterte, also Ticketmasters, überbordenden Wartezeiten und überhaupt diese ganzen Gebühren, die dann noch bezahlen sind, das ist ein echtes Problem und wir werden uns Life Nation Ticketmaster, da sind nämlich zwei Unternehmen vor zwei Jahren zusammengegangen, die jetzt dieses Monopol bilden. Mal anschauen unter Monopolgesichtspunkten, Breakup Ticketmaster, ist dann der Hashtag dazu und es ist so. Inzwischen treibt das Ticketmaster ganz schön weit, denn was in diese ganzen Diskussionen, in die wir gleich einsteigen, nicht Thema war, was aber super interessant ist, gerade beim Thema Sport hat Ticketmaster jetzt verkündet, diesen Monat, dass sie mit der Flow Blockchain zusammenarbeiten, von Dapper Labs, die Serious Business of Fun and Games on the Blockchain vermarkten. Und da fragt man sich, Fun and Games, Serious Business. Man geht zu einem Basketballspiel und weiß, also das Ticket kostet da eh vierstellig. Kleine Hallen und so, nicht so riesige Stadien. Und jetzt gibt es da einen Blockchain-Anbieter, der durch seine letzte Funding-Runde auf sieben Milliarden Bewertung kam. Was für ein Business steckt denn da dahinter? Und in dem Falle ist es mal nicht nur, wie bei FTX und so weiter, einfach nur die Verwaltung von Wallets oder so, sondern die haben ein echtes Angebot. Die verkaufen nämlich in Partnerschaft mit der NBA Spielmomente. Also du hast ja gerade in Deutschland auch wieder durch die Fußball-WM die Spielkarten, wo die Fußballspieler drauf sind und so weiter. Wie wär's denn, wenn man nicht nur den Spieler auf einer Karte hat, sondern das Spielmoment, sein Tor, sein Assist, sein was auch immer. Und beim Basketball fällt ja viel an. Also da kommt da mal ein Drei-Punkte-Wurf und da ein Dank und so.
Und das kann man dann kaufen und jemandem verschenken. Ja, man geht dann auf, kann ich sagen, hier unser Bremer Gold-Junge, der hat doch dieses tolle Tor gemacht. Bei diesem Moment hätte ich gerne. Dafür gebe ich 50 Euro.
Und ich empfehle euch allen, das euch immer live anzugucken. NBA-Topshot ist der Google-Suchbegriff. Dann kommt man auf die NBA-Topshot-Seite. Und dort gibt es so kleine digitale Zertifikate. Also sie sehen aus wie kleine Storys, so im 16 zu 9 oder 4 x 3-Format Hochkant, wo unten so Krimskrams draufsteht, wie auf so einer Pokémon-Karte. Und dann ein Bewegtbild drin ist von diesem Spielzug. Mal drei Sekunden, mal zehn Sekunden irgendwas. Und dann steht einfach ein Preis drunter. Und dann kann man das kaufen oder weiterverkaufen oder wie auch immer. Und die treiben das jetzt so weit, dass man sich halt bei dem Spiel war ich und diesen Spielzug und so weiter. Und dann hat man zu seinem Eintrittspreis von tausenden Dollar auch noch so eine Erinnerung, wo dann der eine eigene Name, also man kommt in so eine Galerie und da steht halt, wer ist hier gerade Besitzer und Käufer und wie auch immer. Und das rangiert auch alles so im vierstelligen Dollarbereich.
Wir haben ja schon mal damals im Zuge von NFTs über diese Fußballkarten gesprochen, die jetzt digital sind, die dann auf Börsen gehandelt werden und auch in limitierter Auflage scheinen. Jetzt gibt es auch noch diese Momente.
Genau. Und beim Sport ist das schon super beliebt, weil man das eben so runterbrechen kann auf dieser eine Spielzug. Und das war doch das Spiel, wo ich auch dabei war und so. Und das will eigentlich Ticketmaster gerade ausbauen, in dem sie nämlich sagen, wir machen jetzt NFT-Tickets, die hauptsächlich als Erinnerungsstücke dienen. Also das sind gar nicht Tickets, mit denen man sich Zugang gewährt. Das kriegt man weiter so als PDF, dass man dann auch einen Bildschirm aufzeigen darf, weil da ist ja nur ein Strichcode drauf. Sondern zusätzlich zum Event kann man sich nochmal NFT-Ticket als Erinnerungsstück holen, was dann über diese Flow-Blockchain mit der Ticketmaster jetzt, nachdem die NFA so gut mit denen zusammengearbeitet hat, auch machen möchte. Also das ist eigentlich die Richtung, in die Ticketmaster gerade gehen möchte. Wohin mit der ganzen Kohle, die man gemacht hat. Man muss ja investieren, um dann mehr Kohle daraus zu schaffen. Aber Ticketmaster wurde gerade scharf ausgebremst, denn wir haben hier ein Problem mit oder Ticketmaster, ein Problem mit Taylor Swift. Und das gehen wir hier mal durch. Wir haben sowohl das Problem, dem wir uns langsam nähern, als auch gleich die Lösung, denn interessanterweise war jetzt im November auch gleich Cory Doctorow am Start, der seinerseits gerade bei More Perfect Union am Start ist. Die wollen nämlich Schicksalsgemeinschaften gründen, also die Idee der Gewerkschaft wieder voranstellen. Und sie haben eine perfectunion.com, die ihrerseits mehr so Medienangebot ist. Also die verstehen sich so als Aktivisten und mediale Aktivisten. Die machen dann so YouTube-Videos. Wir zum Beispiel, Corey Doctorow zum Thema Ticketmaster. Dynamische Preisgestaltung bei Tickets. Hohe Nachfrage bedeutet, wir können dir dein Ticket nicht zu diesem Preis garantieren, wie bei den Hotels. Zum Beispiel bei Hotels. Ich bin auch ein bisschen verabschiedet, weil ich das nicht so gerne aus dem Kopf habe. Ich bin auch ein bisschen verabschiedet, weil ich das nicht so gerne aus dem Kopf habe. Ich bin auch ein bisschen verabschiedet, weil ich das nicht so gerne aus dem Kopf habe. Ich bin auch ein bisschen verabschiedet, weil ich das nicht so gerne aus dem Kopf habe. Ich bin auch ein bisschen verabschiedet, weil ich das nicht so gerne aus dem Kopf habe.
Ich habe die letzte Stunde und 15 Minuten versucht, Tickets zu kaufen.
Also John Oliver konnte damals aufgreifen, was in den sozialen Medien schon eine Debatte vorlag.
Die Leute beschweren sich und trotzdem haben die offenbar die Säle noch vollbekommen, trotz dieser Preise.
Genau wie das klappt, trotz der Preise, klären wir gleich. Ist auch einer dieser große Spandale.
Ich dachte, dass die Märzgrenze doch früher erreicht.
Ja, gerade jetzt, wo so viele Abschiedstouren sind und Elton John zum zehnten Mal auf Abschiedstour geht, denkt man sich, wenn ich heute nicht gehe, verpasse ich ihn und dann zahlt man auf 400.
Er hat auch nur noch an diesem Flügel hin und her geschoben.
Er lässt sich dann von Dua Lipa begleiten. Also es ist es geht drunter und drüber und alle bedienen sich hier an einer. Es gibt da schon eine Debatte entweder in sozialen Medien oder im Fernsehen. Hier brodelt doch irgendwas und The Young Turks, die man ja so ein bisschen als progressiven wir stehlen mal zurück Fernsehsender kennt, die haben ja auch ein kurzes Intro zum Thema, weil nämlich Fox News es auch zum Thema machte. Wir können uns überlegen, wenn jetzt sich Leute aufregen, darüber, dass sie zu viel Geld bezahlen, wie wird wohl der Fox News, die Fox News Einflugschneise in dieses Thema sein? Wir lassen uns aber langsam.
Taylor Swift hat erstmals erlebt, wie schottig ihre Plattform ist, wenn es um Tickets kommt, weil am Tag, die Pre-Sale-Tickets auf dem Site waren.
Am Freitag, als die Fünf auf Fox News die Frage ausgerichtet haben, haben sie sich in Befragung von Ticketmasters Monopoly umgebracht.
Bevor sie das jetzt dann spielt, wie Fox News sich dazu verhält, erklärt sie es auch kurz. Was das Problem ist, das müssen wir uns aber nicht anhören, wir können es alle verstehen. Also wenn ein Ticket 500 Euro kostet oder Dollar und überhaupt nur zu wenig in den Verkauf gegeben werden, dann funktioniert die Seite auch nicht. Man weiß gar nicht, kriege ich überhaupt ein Ticket, da muss man sich vorher registrieren. Den ganzen Blödsinn, das ist alles blöd. Und das geht auch nur, weil da ein Monopolist am Werk ist, der keine marktwirtschaftliche Gefahr von Konkurrenten entgegennehmen muss, erwarten muss. Und sie kommt dann danach darauf zurück, wieder, dass Fox News diesen Clip hat, den sie dann spielen möchte. Und damit haben wir dann auch die ganze Bandbreite von John Oliver mit Corrie Doctorow, die Young Turks und Fox News zum Thema.
Ich kann es nicht helfen, das zu bemerken, okay?
Und ich bemerke nur das. John Malone hat sich über den Prozess der Verwundung von den meisten seiner Unternehmen begonnen. Mehr als das wurde wieder einmal unter der Umbrille der Liberty Media verbreitet.
Wenn du etwas von dem, was die demokratische Partei in der Kontrolle hatte, plötzlich FTC-Kreise aufsteigen, frage Elon Musk.
Es ist einfach eine Beobachtung, aber es scheint ein Verbrechen zu sein. Es gibt einen Rhyme.
Es ist so interessant, dass sich hier einfach nochmal wiederholt, was du damals bei der Kongressangehörung vorgespielt hattest, als dann die Republikaner auch mal Fragen stellen konnten zu den Silicon Valley Monopolisten und die nur wissen wollten, ob wenn sie das und das bei Facebook posten, ob das dann gelöscht werden könnte oder nicht.
Also Fox News, das sind einfach die Voken, sich darüber beschweren. Das ist ja einfach nur Vokismus. Und klar, dann können wir es auch labeln. Also Cory Doctorow ist nun mal ein ganz Voker. Und er führt uns hier weiter fort im Thema und nutzt seine More Perfect Union, um das so ein bisschen medial aufzubreiten.
Dieses Ticketmuster hat die Kraft, die Venue zu zerstören, und die Künstler, die mit ihnen nicht arbeiten, haben sogar ihre eigene Rezellplattform und sie ermutigen und entfalten Ticketmuster-Reizler zu Fan-Zuverschöpfen. Live Nation CEO Michael Rapinoe hat 2017 70, 6 Millionen Dollar gemacht. Das ist einer der größten CEO-Pay-Pakete der Welt. Aber hier ist die Zwischenzeit. Dieses ganze Monopoly wurde mit unseren gewählten Leadern geholfen und genutzt.
Das ist doch mal Gewerkschaftsarbeit, wie man sie sich wünscht. Ein Thema, ein guter Host, den man einfach dazu nimmt.
Gleich die richtige Adressierung. Die Politik hat es ermöglicht, dass es überhaupt nicht kommen konnte. Dann wird Barack Obama eingeblendet. Und was hier auch so schön ist, noch mal zu sehen, wie reicht da durch? Einige werden. Und die Frage, die ich jetzt schon mal vorweg stelle, auch wenn du sie nicht beantworten kannst oder musst, wäre so was, wo wir jetzt ein bisschen über Mastodon gespottet haben, vielleicht zu unrecht, wäre so etwas nicht möglich zur Verfügung zu stellen, ohne dass solche Gewinne da gemacht werden. Also könnte man nicht sowas leicht aufmachen. Ich denke zum Beispiel an Tommy Schmidt und Felix Lobrecht, die ja, soweit ich es in Erinnerung habe, ihre Tickets für ihre Shows verkaufen über einen eigenen Service, weil sie genau diesen wahnsinnig mitmachen wollten.
Genau. In Amerika ist es ein bisschen komplizierter, weil du die Arenen nicht bekommst, die zum Beispiel Felix Lobrecht braucht, weil darüber auch Exklusivverträge laufen. Also es sind sowohl die Künstler als auch die Arenen, also die größeren Städte, als dann auch alle, die sonst noch irgendwie dazwischenhängen.
Politiker lieben ja so etwas, so gesamte Enhancements zu schnüren. Ich kenne das aus einzelnen Städten auch, dass man dann in Copens nur einen Konzertsaal buchen kann, wenn man auch das gesamte Catering von diesem merkwürdigen Anbieter bekommt.
Man kann es selber machen. Der Cars Communication Kongress nutzt ja eine eigene Software fürs Ticketing und nirgendwo funktioniert Ticketing besser als beim Cars Communication Kongress. Sag ich es dir hin, sag es dir in Code, fertig, alles geregelt. Man weiß, wie man es bezahlt. Die können das Ticket ordentlich verkaufen. Die haben ja auch immer eine Knappheit, sagen dann, dieses Ticket generiert immer einen Tag später ein nächstes Ticket, sodass dann nach und nach die Freundeskreise abgeklappert werden und nicht so wild rechts und links, sondern dass dann die Leute, die dort sind, auch sich kennen usw. Wir machen unsere Sachen in der Case auch über ein eigenes Ticketing, also der Mustafa, der das da alles organisiert, dem schreibt man einfach eine E-Mail in dem Fall und dann reagiert er darauf und sagt, hier ist dein Ticket. Also es gibt viele Wege, es selber zu machen, es sei denn, das Ticketing springt als eigenes profitorientiertes Unternehmen selber da rein und knäbelt alle mit Exklusivverträgen, was sich eben sehr anbietet, um solche, ja dann machst du doch nur die Hausmeisterei für die Venue und ich organisier das mit dem Ticketing und dann kriegst du einfach einen Festpreis und alles ist geregelt. Weil dann hat man, und das ist ja sozusagen, das ist ja so ein letzte Meile-Monopolist. Die haben wirklich die Kreditkartennummer der Kunden am Ende. Das bietet sich ja bei, so wie bei Amazon auch bei Eventim an, einfach jetzt wieder, ne ich hab doch einen Account bei Eventim, von können die mir nicht das Ticket verkaufen, weil dann ist es nur ein Klick, bevor ich wieder meine Adresse und alles eingalbe und so. Also diese Profilbildung und dieser Zugang zum Kunden ist ganz wichtig. Und jetzt hab ich auch schon gehört, der Oberchef von dem ganzen Laden verdient 70 Millionen im Jahr und führt damit die CEO-Liste in Amerika an. Wir sind also hier wirklich im Top-Level-Bereich. Das ist nicht einfach nur, ich geh mal ins Konzert oder so, sondern Ticketmaster verkauft 500 Millionen Tickets im Jahr. Und dann kann man ja hier ausrechnen, Durchschnittspreis irgendwie 49 Dollar oder so, wie viel Milliarden das einfach sind und auf wie viel sie da Zugriff haben. Und wie viel politische Hilfe man da auch braucht, um so ein Monopol aufzubauen und auf diese Geschichte geht er hier auch ein. At the time, the Obama DOJ's top antitrust cop was Christine Varney, who said, I understand consolidation has been going on in the industry for some time. The two most powerful companies in the live music industry join forces and it's not an antitrust concern.
Während wir bei den, unseren eigentlichen Themen hier, das Digitale usw. wo wir das häufiger behandeln und auch in Amy Klobuchar nachgelesen haben, ja, Antitrust braucht auch eine neue Bedeutung irgendwie, weil wir können es nicht an der Kunde ist einer Preisgestaltung ausgeliefert, weil man bezahlt ja nichts für Facebook und so weiter. Hier ist es ja ganz anders. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich, dass sie gerade hier auf diesem Feld und insbesondere den Demokraten meinten, nee, das ist ja gar nicht Antitrust. Hier hat man ja nicht mit einer Wettbewerbsverzerrung oder monopol missbräuchlichen Handlung zu tun, obwohl wir das so klar an den von dem Kunden am Ende bezahlten Preisen ablesen können. Das hat John Oliver mal kurz aufgezogen.
Die average Preis für populäre Content hat mehr als dreimal seit den 90er Jahren die riesige Inflation.
Von 25 auf 87 Dollar ist der Durchschnittspreis amerikanischer Tickets in 25 Jahren gewachsen.
Kann man was darüber sagen, wie viel die Stars bekommen? Denn das heißt ja, dass sie nicht besonders viel bekommen.
Oder mitverdienen, illegalerweise, also mit drin hängen. Es gibt es in alle Richtungen. Also wir haben es hier mit einer echten Preisexplosion, einer echten Inflation sozusagen zu tun, auf diesem Gebiet, ohne dass da bis jetzt die Monopolkommissionen mal eingestiegen sind. Hier hören wir noch mal Cory Doctorow zu dieser 12-jährigen politischen Entwicklung. Also 12 Jahre nachdem Life Nation und Ticketmaster damals zusammengegangen sind.
dass sie 5.000 Dollar Ticket verkaufen können, um den Jungen, der singt, zu sehen. Und der King ist nicht zufrieden, bis er alles regelt.
Das heißt, man kann sich Tickets besorgen und kann sie wieder über diese Resale-Plattform verkaufen. Das bedeutet, das ist nicht nur für Leute gedacht, die leider nicht können, weil sie gerade Corona haben, sondern daraus kann man ja auch schon ein ganz gutes Geschäft machen, wenn man weiß, was wird ausverkauft sein. So ein bisschen wie bei den Sneaker-Schuhen, über diesen Sneaker-Hypes und dann kann man die auch da auf den Resale-Plattformen verkaufen. Und Ticketmaster bietet jetzt noch mal eine Plattform an, also dafür auch die Plattform an. Das heißt, die verdienen dann an jedem Ticket zweimal.
Also es ist total verdreht. Wir werden auch diesen Problembereich gleich noch aufziehen. Resaling ist ja nur das eine. Diese Exklusivverträge sind das eine. Gebühren spielen auch noch eine Rolle, alles Mögliche. Zu dieser Geschichte ist noch zu ergänzen. Damals, 2010, Obama regiert auch die FTC, die Federal Trade Commission, die also diesen Merger gesagt hat, ja, ihr könnt das machen. Live Nation und Ticketmaster sind jetzt ein neuer Monopolist auf diesem Ding. Die haben sich damals, und das ist die politische Einflugsschneise, ja auch für Corey Dockdorf, zusichern lassen, dass dieses Monopol nicht missbräuchlich verwendet wird.
Der Verkaufsverkauf, das das Ticketmaster Live Nation Corporate Empire bekam, war ein Mix von strukturen und Konduktremedien, aber es hat eigentlich alle zu einem hübschen Schwerpunkt gebrochen. Die Kombinierung verweigerte ihren Verkaufsverkauf mit Unwahrheit, weil, wie ein Playground-Bully, sie eine Kulturen der Angst gegründet haben, wo niemand anderes in der Live-Musikindustrie gegen sie sprechen würde.
So, sie haben also damals zugesichert, ja wir haben ein Monopol, aber wir werden es nicht missbrauchen. Und dann, und das ist eigentlich das interessante, er sagt ja hier nochmal, ja die haben sich das dann über Knebelverträge und so weiter, Verschwiegenheit zugesichert. Denn das sind ja immer Verträge exklusiv mit der Venue, exklusiv mit dem Artisten und so weiter. Und keiner spricht darüber, weil sonst platzen diese Deals und dann kriegt man halt kein Publikum mehr. Und das ist ja jetzt erst so Thema geworden, nachdem wirklich die Letzten im Bunde, nämlich die Ticketkäufer, gesagt haben, also das ist irgendwie blöd, dass sie kein Taylor Swift Ticket bekommen. Von Taylor Swift ging das ja nicht aus und auch nicht von den 52 Veranstaltungsorten, sondern die wollten es ja einfach so durchziehen.
Ich habe das jetzt schon häufiger bemerkt, wenn ich ein paar Künstler angeklickt habe bei Instagram, dass sie immer mehr davor warnten vor Resale-Plattformen und sagten dann, bleibt lieber zu Hause, ich gehe nächstes Jahr noch mal auf Tournee oder wir gucken noch nach Zusatzterminen, aber macht das nicht mit. Das habe ich jetzt mehrmals schon gesehen von Künstlern.
Genau, Rammstein glaube ich, haben da auch Rechtsstreitereien schon gewonnen, dass dann irgendwie irgendwelche Plattformen nicht mehr die Tickets anbieten dürfen usw. Das ist jedenfalls ein echtes Problem. Und hier haben wir noch eins, diese Gebühren, vorgestellt von John Oliver.
It is no secret Ticketmaster is horrible, but exactly how it is horrible is genuinely interesting. Let's start with one of the things that infuriates people the most about them and that's the fees. They can come as a nasty surprise at the very end of a transaction and can range from the annoying to the completely bat shit. We found a ticket to a 2019 Kidzpop concert with fees that amounted to 75% of face value. For one ticket to a title of the creative show next week, the fees add an extra 78% and the fees on a $15 ticket to a monster truck rally in Houston were $16.41. That's more than the cost of a ticket itself.
Und das ist besonders irre, weil das hat er nur so verschluckt. $15. Gebühr. Man hätte ja nichts dagegen, wenn da einfach steht, das Ticket kostet 31 Euro. Dann könnte man sich gleich überlegen, macht man es oder macht man es nicht. Aber hier ist man ja schon im Kaufprozess drin und kriegt dann kurz bevor die bestellte Bestätigung von einem selber abgegeben wird. Ja, das kostet übrigens 16 Euro Gebühren. Macht man dann noch einen Rückzieher. Es ist also so ein Trick, um die Leute noch mal mit 15 Euro zu ködern und am Ende sind es aber 31. Und jetzt fragen wir sich, kann es nicht ein Gesetz geben, das einfach sagt, schreibt den Brutto-Preis hin, so wie im Supermarkt auch. Also Amerika hat es nicht ganz so gegeben.
Und was soll diese Gebührrechtfertigen?
Genau.
Was machen die damit? Kommt das mit der Brieftaube oder bringt das jemand persönlich vorbei in einem goldenen Umschlag?
Genau, also hier steht dann einfach Total Fees und dann kann man sich, ja, aber ihr könntet jetzt einfach in die Ticketkalkulation reinmachen. Wieso füllt ihr das nochmal extra auf? Ist doch totaler Quatsch. Und da gab es damals eine Erklärung des damaligen CEOs von Ticketmaster, der das vom Kongress erklärt hat.
Ticketmaster ist ein Geschäftsmodell, das als der Beste steht und alle anderen Spieler hinter ihnen hinstehen lässt. Oder du könntest das nicht sagen und Ticketmasters former CEO einfach direkt dem Kongress erlauben. Ja, das ist wahr. Ticketmaster ist sehr viel wie die IRS, weil es eine obäge Burekratie ist, mehr aus dem Geld herunterlässt, als du denken sollst, und es wird von Männern so katastrophal uncharismatisch, dass sie sich schlafen lassen.
Ja, wir wollen ja das Ticket billig verkaufen, aber dann kommen die noch rechts und links und sagen, das soll man noch mit da rein und dann ja müssen wir halt den Schwarzen Peter sozusagen spielen, um für den Endkunden, dabei sind es natürlich alles Gebühren, die die selber einstreichen, Vorverkaufsgebühr, Onlinegebühr.
Was soll das überhaupt sein? Man kann es ja sehen, wie günstig man bestellen kann. Wenn ich bei Amazon ein Buch für 20 Euro bestelle, kostet das 20 Euro. Da muss ich nicht nur eine Vorverkaufsgebühr zahlen oder noch irgendwas komisches.
Ausgedachte Gebühren.
Einfach nur, um nochmal den Ticketpreis ein bisschen... Ticketmaster, und das ist hier eins dieser zentralen Problemen, hat halt diese Locations exklusiv. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß das Problem in Deutschland ist, dass Felix Lobrecht es noch kann. Also Felix Lobrecht ist der King in seinem Genre.
Felix Lobrecht kann das nur, weil er direkt seine Leute adressiert. Also wie wir das jetzt im kleineren Maßstab auch machen können, alle Menschen, die den Podcast hören, gehen ja, also haben potenziell vielleicht ein Interesse daran, uns live zu erleben, aber niemand darüber hinaus. Das heißt, wir können nicht...
Wir haben ein gutes Laufpublikum.
Ja, wir müssen nicht irgendwo auftreten, und wenn man uns mal sieht oder wir müssen auch nicht sagen, wir brauchen dringend mal einen Auftritt bei Lanz, damit das Ticket sich gut verkauft oder so etwas. Oder wir brauchen die Werbung von Eventim, damit die Show sich verkauft, sondern wir erreichen direkt ein Publikum. Das ist bei Felix Lobrecht natürlich ein bisschen größer, und deswegen funktioniert das da. Genau. Und da funktioniert dann diese direkt zum Endkunden Direct-to-Consumer-Logik. Aber das funktioniert immer nur da, wo der Intermediär weitgehend ausgeschaltet wurde, dadurch, dass man eine direkte Fanbase oder ein direktes Publikum adressieren kann. Und das können aber, also ich würde sagen, dass Taylor Swift das natürlich auch schaffen würde.
Also Taylor Swift wird es schaffen, weil sie eben auch diese mediale Aufmerksamkeit bei sich hat. Sie hat ihre Social-Media-Kanäle selbst in der Kontrolle, so wie wir ja auch unseren RSS-Feed zum Beispiel oder lobrecht auch sein Instagram-Account. Und das macht ja diesen riesigen Unterschied. Denn so wie wir kein Laufpublikum hätten, dass wir mit einem Plakat auf der Straße irgendwie anziehen könnten, ist es ja super interessant, jetzt mit diesen Locations zu sprechen, weil die ihrerseits ganz fasziniert davon sind, dass die Podcasts die einzigen sind, die schnell ausverkaufen. Also du musst ja nur den Termin nennen und dann einen Tag später sind die ganzen Tickets weg. Es macht aber keinen Sinn, ins Programmheft zu schreiben, weil das Programmheft wird veröffentlicht, wenn die Tickets schon alle weg sind. Und wer das Programmheft liest, kennt die Podcasts nicht und hat dann auch keinen Bezug dazu. Also das ist auch für die Locations grad wahnsinnig neu, dass die Treue anders organisiert ist. Das hat der Journalismus damals auch erlebt, als er meinte, wir schreiben doch super geile Texte. Ja, aber die Treue der Leser gehört Facebook. Also ihr müsst auf der Facebookseite vorkommen. Was ihr dann für einen Text schreibt, ist egal. Ihr müsst halt auf der Facebookseite vorkommen. Aufmerksamkeit ist der King. Und so hat sich das hier auch ein bisschen verschoben. Was bedeutet, so kleine Podcastveranstaltungen haben es leicht, weil ihr alle aus der Hörerschaft alleine, was weiß ich, 200, 400 Leute rekrutieren könnt, die dann kommen. Pearl Jam zum Beispiel hat schon vor 20 Jahre riesige Probleme gehabt, diese Exklusivverträge mit diesen Locations irgendwie aufzustören, denn nur der Name alleine reicht dann immer gar nicht.
Auch bevor die Verkaufszeit, haben Pearl Jam, auf der Höhe ihrer Fähigkeiten, versucht, einen Tour ohne Ticketmaster oder ihre affiliierten Venen zu machen, aber ihr Manager hat gemerkt, dass sie damals an komischen Orten spielen müssen, wie ein Ski-Resort in Lake Tahoe und ein Fahrrad in San Diego. Und wenn Pearl Jam in den 90ern nicht den Macht hat, von Ticketmaster aus wegzukommen, dann niemand. Also wenn du fragst, warum kann nicht mein Lieblingsartist oder Magier... nur noch eine Ticketkampagne benutzen? Die Wahrheit ist, wenn sie einen Venum spielen wollen, der einen exklusiven Kontakt mit Ticketmaster hat, können sie das nicht tun.
So was gibt es in Deutschland ja auch, dass es da für Künstler nicht anders möglich ist, aufzutreten als zu partieren.
Die großen Hallen, die sind alle exklusiv. Die wollen ja auch Langfristigkeit in der ökonomischen Planung.
Und das ist ja wieder so erstaunlich. Diese kleinen Kabarettbühnen, die haben es jetzt schwer. Denen hat die Corona Hilfe oft nicht gereicht. Genauso auch bei den kommunalen Kinos. Du hast es mitbekommen mit Mainz. Ich muss da gerade mal diesen kleinen Exkurs machen. Mainz hat ja ein tolles Programmkino, oder zwei, Kapitol und Palatine. Da sind dabei jetzt Investoren eingestiegen. Du kannst mir vorstellen, wohin die Reise geht. Marvel? Nein, das Ende des Kinos, dass man da ganz andere Wohneinheiten, hochpreisige Wohnungen, sowas. Also das Kino stirbt damit. Und wir wissen, Mainz ist jetzt die reichste Stadt. Durch Biontech hat ja dann erst mal die Gewerbesteuer gesenkt, hat einfach Steuergeschenke noch oben drauf gelegt und kümmert sich nicht darum, dass diese Kinokultur in Mainz erhalten bleibt, zumal es dringend nötig ist. Denn Mainz ist eine der wenigen Städte, in denen es überhaupt eine Filmwissenschaft gibt. Es ist so skandalös und wie kulturlos diese Leute sind. Ich habe mir die Herrschaften da aus der Mainzer Regierung dann bei Google angesehen, da war mir alles klar.
Mainz hat jetzt den historisch und rekordhalterisch tiefen Hebesatz auf Gewerbesteuer. Das ist so skandalös. Weil ein Jahr mal die...
Ja, so läuft das. Wir haben nicht nur auf der europäischen Ebene diesen Wettbewerb der Staaten untereinander, der so irrsinnig ist, sondern wir haben auch den Wettbewerb der Städte untereinander, womit dann solche Unterbietungswettbewerbe eingezoghalten werden. Und das führt wieder dazu, dass solche kleineren Bühnen, 200, 400, 500 Bestuhlung, nach und nach kaputt gemacht werden, weil man dann sagt, ja das können wir uns jetzt nicht mehr leisten, oder hier können wir keine Gelder mehr geben. Und dann geht das zu Bruch. Und das ist das, was überall gerade passiert.
Wir sind anscheinend nicht reich genug in Deutschland.
Irgendwie...
Ja, wir müssen nicht, dass wir anders stärken.
Wir müssen nochmal mit dem Bundespräsidenten darüber reden. Nächstes Problem, das hier auch noch thematisiert wird, Ticketmaster verkauft gar nicht einfach so Tickets. Wenn jetzt Justin Bieber irgendwie eine große Runde dreht und so. Ja, da macht er natürlich viele Witze, wie lange braucht sie denn für ihren Lippenstift, aber 20.000 Tickets in 30 Sekunden verkaufen. Also wir haben bei Taylor Swift jetzt gesehen, nee das ginge gar nicht. Also das kann der Ticketmaster gar nicht so schnell machen. Machen sie auch nicht. Tatsächlich ist die, wir geben es mal in den freien Marktrate, erschreckend krank.
Selling 20.000 Seats in 30 seconds would be crazy, if that's what Bieber did, but he didn't. And that's by no means a one-off. For many top shows, less than 25% of tickets are initially released to the general public. And in an audit of the Blaisdell Center in Honolulu, they found that when Janet Jackson played there in 2015, only 8% of all tickets went to the general public. And when Mariah Carey played there, the next year it was just 7 percent.
So, wo gehen die anderen 93 Prozent hin?
Sind das Firmengeschenke? Ist das so was, wo man sagt, guckt mal hier.
Zum Beispiel, es gibt mehrere Antworten, aber es betrifft wirklich bei MyRailCarry 93 Prozent der Tickets.
Und es ist ja zum Beispiel so, erzählt mir ein Freund, der einen American Express hat, dass man, wenn da irgendwas ausverkauft ist und man ist da so hoch gerankt, also gibt viel Geld für diese Karte aus, so laut einen entsprechenden Umsatz, dann kann man da anrufen beim Concierge Service und sagen, ich würde ja schon gern noch hin. Und dann werden Dinge möglich gemacht. Offenbar funktioniert das ganz stark so, dass da ganz viele Kontingente halten.
Genau, das ist die Rätselslösung. Überall, wo du nochmal extra absahnen kannst, wird es gemacht.
Und oft geht eine große Menge an Kreditkart-Kompanien, wie du es weißt, aus Ad-Sites wie diese. Boring. Wenn ein bäuerlicher Typ unsere Breakups benutzt, als Ausgabe, um ein Kreditkart zu signieren, damit ich ruhig auf der Strasse stehen kann während eines Alicia Keys Konzerts und eine auf Papier sensibelere Entscheidung, dann schaff ich mir, dass ein bäuerlicher Typ das nicht tun würde, Lauren. Ich warte auf deine Verkaufs-Konfirmation.
Die Kreditkartenfirmen machen also dasselbe wie Ticketmaster selbst, sie verkaufen ja nicht nur eine Kreditkarte, sondern auch die Möglichkeit, Emotionen zu erleben. Und Alicia Keys hat hier mitgemacht in den Werbespot. Sie wird ja wohl wissen, für was sie hier geworben hat. Steht davon aus. Also die ganze verquere Ticketlogik, da stecken die Artisten also mit drin. Das ist das eine, Werbegeschenke oder beziehungsweise nochmal diesen besonderen Resale über die Unternehmen oder dann sehr nah an dem Starcom, dass man hinter die Kulissen kann, Abendessen gehen, mit Opernsängern. Das war schon in den 90ern immer mal wieder da, irgendwelche Pakete, die dann nochmal Vorzüge mitbringen. Oder es ist eben dieser Resale-Markt.
Wir sollten wahrscheinlich über den Sekundärmarkt reden. Es gibt Sites wie SeatGeek, StubHub und überraschend, Ticketmaster wieder. Diese Sites wollen dich nicht so gut als Fan-to-Fan-Marktplätze denken. Ticketmaster beschreibt sogar sein Resale-Marktplace wie dieses.
So, also gleich mal Refinanzierungsideen für ach, dein Babysitter kann nicht, na dann hast du doch das Recht, hier nochmal ordentlich abzusahnen. Um wie viel teurer sind die Tickets per Resale im Schnitt? Kann sich jetzt jeder mal überlegen. Wird schon ein bisschen teurer sein.
Re-Sale Sites sind nicht nur Fan to Fan. In der Regierung hat ein Bericht gefunden, dass Professionelle Broker die Mehrheit oder die überwältigende Mehrheit der Ticket-Sales an diesen Sites sind. Aber manchmal mehr als 1000% und in einem Fall 7000%. Das war für einen Einrichtungskonzert.
Also 50% mehr, die Hälfte mehr im Schnitt bis Faktor 10. Muss man schon damit rechnen, wenn man da nochmal mit dabei sein möchte.
Ich bin so verwundert, dass Leute solche Summe ausgeben. Also die Klassikbranche ist jetzt auch nicht günstig, aber dadurch, dass die Karten ja mit subventioniert wird, gibt es da dann natürliche Grenzen. Wenn ich jetzt an die Kölner Philharmonie denke, da sind dann so die allerteuersten Konzerte, wo dann das größte Symphonieorchester aus, weiß ich nicht, wo anreißt, plus Stargeigerin, plus Stadirigent, da sind es, glaube ich, dann 160 Euro auf dem besten Platz. Das heißt, das ist viel Geld. Das ist für mich dann auch nicht so mehr reizvoll, da zu sagen, ach, das ist mir das jetzt wert. Und dann wird das ja noch groß subventioniert. Aber dass Leute bereit sind, einfach nur, um da irgendwo dabei zu sein, Tausende Euros lassen.
Ja, es ist verrückt. Peter Gabriel ist noch mal auf Tour, habe ich gesehen.
Ich kann aber das auch gar nicht so nachvollziehen, dass man die alle noch mal sehen will.
Denn stimmen werden ja nicht.
Also ich habe, ja, ich gestehe jetzt mal. Ich habe es aber schon erzählt. Ich habe ja zwei, drei Stars, die schon ein bisschen älter waren, gesehen. Einmal Vicky Leandros, da war sie ja Ende 60, herausragend. Dann Nana Muscuri, Schwierigkeiten in der Mittellage, aber sie ist halt Nana Muscuri. Und Mireille Mathieu, erstaunlich perfektionistisch. Aber das waren ja Kartenpreise unter 100 Euro. Und da bin ich aus so einem Fable hingegangen, fand es aber schon, als ich da saß, merkwürdig natürlich. Aber ich dachte, gut, geh mal hin, eines Tages wirst du es in einem Podcast erzählen können. Aber dass es so ein Fable dafür gibt, dass man die ganz Alten noch mal sehen will, die Musik machen, die ganz stark mit Jugendlichkeit, mit Vitalität und auch mit einer stimmlichen Vitalität verbunden ist. Und das kann ja nicht mehr eingelöst werden von denen. Also ich habe mir dieser Alten John auch angesehen. Und ich wünschte, ich könnte wenigstens so gut singen. Aber das ist natürlich gar kein Vergleich mit dem, was der vor 25 Jahren konnte.
Ja, aber du hörst dir ja keine Originalaufnahme aus einem Studio in dem Moment an, wo du weißt, die ist jetzt wirklich perfekt und zählt mal wiederholen dafür.
Der Unterschied ist in der Oper. Wenn wir in der Oper sind, dann möchten wir eigentlich die Qualität hören, wie wir sie von den Aufnahmen kennen oder noch besser, weil wir wissen, das schafft eine Aufnahme gar nicht zu bannen. Und dann waren wir in Frankfurt etwas enttäuscht oder ich war etwas enttäuscht von der Königin der Nacht zum Beispiel, weil ich dann sagen würde, das geht besser oder auch, ich will jetzt gar nicht alle durchgehen, aber ich bin bei einem klassischen Konzert meist in der Lage, dass ich nicht sage, naja, es ist halt live nicht so gut, sondern es ist live mindestens so gut wie auf der Aufnahme eher besser. Es sei denn, es hat jetzt jemand einen schlechten Tag, kann natürlich mal passieren. Ich war jetzt auch in Bonn, der Oper, da war der Sänger indisproniert.
Du fandest es aber sehr gut.
Die Oper an sich, das war gelungen, das war eine selten gespielte Oper, Asrael, das war sehr gelungen. Aber wenn der Sänger dann und das wurde angekündigt, indisproniert ist, aber er ist der Einzige, der diese Rolle überhaupt singen kann, weil die nie jemand einstudiert hat, dann ist das so und dann kann man damit leben. Aber in der Regel ist es ja so, dass man dort Topqualität erfährt und es ist nicht so, dass man sagt, naja, ich war noch mal dabei. Also da ist das Klassikpublikum ein ganz anderes als das Popkulturpublikum, das sagt, ich will Elton John noch mal sehen. Wir wissen ja auch bei Britney Spears Konzerten, 20 Lieder wurden gesungen, ein einziges davon live.
Also alle Hörer wissen jetzt, was sie am 20. Dezember erwartet. Wolfgang mit seinem Anspruch des klassischen Konzerts. Ihr werdet ihn in Bestform sehen. Ich werde einfach kommen und sagen, hier bin ich. Ihr könnt gerne noch ein Foto mit mir machen, aber ihr wolltet mich ja nur mal sehen. Es ist aber tatsächlich so, Peter Gabriel, wir kennen hoffentlich alle seine 1994er Secret World Live und so weiter gibt es bei YouTube. Anzuschauen diesen jungen energetischen Peter Gabriel werden wir nicht bekommen, aber es ist trotzdem Peter Gabriel. Das Werk und die Geschichte und die Person steckt da drin. 450 Euro oder so bei Eventim. Teuer.
Sting. Auch hier in Deutschland 450 Euro.
Messerhalle, glaube ich, also feste Halle, ein bisschen kleiner Sting. Großer Aufzug in Wiesbaden auch über 100 Euro. Und Herbert Grönemeyer kündigt sich jetzt an hier im Stadion auch natürlich über 100 Euro auf den guten Plätzen unten. Tokyo Hotel 40 Euro. Ich habe also zugeschlagen und ich wollte in die alte Oper anhalten. Treppko übrigens, einen alten Oper, 140 Euro oder so im Duett mit irgendwer.
Mit dem Mann nehme ich an.
Das kann sein, ich weiß nicht.
Aber da gehst du nicht hin.
Nee, ich wollte zu einem Weihnachtskonzert, irgendeinen Chor. Ja. Und die alte Oper macht ihr eigenes Ticketing und ich musste die Person für das zweite Ticket benennen. Dann musste ich in der Oper Frankfurt auch immer. Das Problem ist, ich weiß ja nicht, mit wem ich da hingehe. Ich lebe hier.
Ich schreibe einfach was drauf.
Nein, das geht ja nicht. Ich kann weder meinen eigenen Namen noch mal wiederholen, weil... Ja, denn du musst am Ende wirklich zeigen, dass du nicht irgendwie Resailermäßig das weiter vertickert hast, sondern die Person muss dann wirklich da sein. Das ist dann... Du kannst nicht einfach mit einem Ticket dahin kommen. Also im Zweifel gucken die nochmal nach. Und das ist ein echtes Problem, weil ich weiß nicht, mit wem ich nächste Woche in ein Konzert gehe. Hier in so einem urbanen Zentrum, wo man nicht genau weiß, wie sich die Tinder-Chats entfalten. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass diese Ticket... Ich habe mir ein Ticket gekauft.
Wiederverkauft werden das doch. Also ich trage einfach immer irgendwas ein.
Ich schreibe immer was ich will. Es steht dann einfach eine Name auf dem Ticket und man kann damit nichts machen, außer reingehen. Man kann es dann nicht... Zum Beispiel... Das ist ja Resale-Sperre dann in dem Moment. Das hat mich geärgert, weil ich hatte dann keine Lust, das Ticket zu kaufen. Jetzt kriege ich ein 30 Euro Chor-Konzert weniger. Ich hätte es aber gerne mal gesehen. Ich hoffe, es gibt auch außerhalb von Weihnachten nochmal Chor-Konzerte. Na ja, in einer finalen Diskussion wird hier nochmal die Sicht der Frage angenähert, die wir uns eben auch gestellt haben. Ist es nur Ticketmaster oder gibt es hier auch noch ein paar Künstler, die sagen, was nützt 1000 Euro für ein Ticket? Kann ich da auch mal ein bisschen noch absahnen. Wir gehen aber erstmal die Diskussion, wie sie John Oliver eigentlich beenden würde, durch. Nämlich Preisfindungsmechanismus ist immer schwierig hier besonders.
Wir haben ein Ticket für Adele gefunden, das auf SeatGeek verkauft wurde, für 1.690 Dollar plus 538 Dollar in Kosten. Wenn jemand über 2.000 Dollar, z.B. für ein Ticket für Adele, will, dann ist das wert, so gross wie das klingt. Aber wenn Adele nicht auf das Geld will, wird es ein Gap zwischen dem Fortschritt des Tickets und dem, was jemand dafür bekommen kann. Und die ganze Industrie wird sich in die Arbeit nehmen. Und leider sind die Live-Events unheimlich vunerbar, weil sie sehr selten sind.
Genau, da ist besondere Knappheit.
Und das betrifft ja jetzt alles vor allem, die mit diesen horrenden Preisen, die Superstars. Das ist ja das große Drama, dass wir gerade bei den kleinen und mittleren das Problem haben, dass die Säle nicht voll werden und dass das da nicht an Ticketpreisen liegt, sondern dass sie kaum Publikum adressieren.
Das sind die richtigen Topprozente.
Wir haben das ja jetzt auch rezipiert gehabt im Sommer mit Helene Fischer. Helene Fischer kann fünfmal in der Stadt auftreten und jedes Mal ist das Stadion voll, während es die kleineren, mittleren Künstler unglaublich schwer haben, überhaupt noch stattzufinden, überhaupt auch wahrgenommen zu werden. Und das ist so traurig, also wie sehr sich das homogenisiert. Wir haben die Spotify-Hit-Liste mit zehn Liedern in der Top Ten, alle von Taylor Swift und ähnliches erleben wir hier beim Ticket auch. Also diese Monopol-Bildung von Ticketmasters, natürlich auch dann so eine Oligopol-Bildung bei den Stars, die nicht nur die ganze Aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen, sondern die so viel Geld auch dann abziehen und offenbar so eine Sucht entstehen lassen, dass Leute bereits 2000 Euro für Adele auszugeben, dass dann natürlich kein anderes Geld mehr da ist für die anderen Dinge. Da würde ich auch jedem nur raten, lieber zehn kleinere Events wahrnehmen, die schöne Erlebnisse sind und dann das ganze Jahr über, als einmal im Jahr das eine machen, das trägt einem nicht über das Jahr. Das kann nicht sein und weil ich jetzt ebenso die Klassik lobe, es gibt natürlich auch der Klassikbranche solche Superstars, die schon seit vielen Jahren grauslich singen, wie zum Beispiel Placido Domingo und trotzdem bekommt er immer noch die Hallen voll und nimmt enorme Kartenpreise.
Man ist in diesem 1% Bereich, wo die Leute wirklich bekannt sind, einfach Funk und Fernsehen. Ich habe das jetzt gesehen auf Plakaten, ich wundere mich immer noch darüber, ich habe es nie vorher gesehen. Helene Fischer spielt glaube ich in Frankfurt und Mannheim oder Darmstadt oder so, keine Ahnung, ich glaube Mannheim. Und jeweils so eine Woche, mehrere Termine und die überschneiden sich aber. Die hat also ihr Set zweimal aufgebaut und ist dann ein Abend hier, ein Abend da, dann ist wieder ein Abend hier, ein Abend da. Also sie macht noch so einen Wechsel drin. Das ist wirklich verrückt. Die einen können sich halt komplett erlauben, einfach zwei Venues da anzumieten gleichzeitig und die anderen hangeln sich dann da so nicht die Kleinkunstbühne. Und wenn man einmal oben mitspielt und feststellt, ich könnte mein Ticket auch für zweieinhalbtausend Euro verkaufen, gibt es einige Bands, die das dann noch machen.
Ein paar Jahre zurück hat Live Nation Metallica direkt auf den Rezellmarkt gesucht, obwohl ein paar andere Künstler und Künstler in den letzten Jahren diese Aufgabe beantragt haben. Ja.
Ja, also hier wird Metallica direkt genannt. Das ist einfach komplett boykottieren. Also in dem Moment hat so eine Band bei mir komplett hofer Spielen. Das ist wirklich so. Dann sollen sie ihren Preis einfach nennen, hoffen, dass sie auf direkten Wege ihre Tickets verkaufen, aber nicht so hintenrum irgendwie nochmal diese Ausbeutermasche machen. Das ist wirklich, das ist das Allerletzte. Wir lernen uns also den politischen Forderungen. Zum einen, Cory Doctorow weist ja nochmal darauf hin, es ist natürlich nicht nur das Ticketing, was uns die Live-Events und die Emotionen, das Emotionsbusiness und die Musik und so weiter vermisst.
Live-Musik ist nicht die einzige kreative Industrie, die sich auf einen riesigen Monopoly gebrochen hat. Diese Labeln haben die Streamingindustrie, die von Spotify dominiert wurde, die selbst von diesen drei Labeln teilweise ausgebildet wurde. Jetzt, dass Disney 21. Die Publisierer-Industrie ist von fünf großen Unternehmen kontrolliert. Das Nummer war 6, als wir unser Buch geschrieben haben. Ja, es ist immer schwer, ein Künstler zu sein. Aber die Unterschiede heute ist, dass die Firmen die maximale Kapital von dem Künstler-Kraft ausbreiten.
Ja, es ist diese typische, wie man es immer hatte, irgendwer kommt mit einer guten Idee wie Google, dann wird erstmal alles weggegrast, alle Bücher digitalisiert, das Suchverhalten analysiert und überhaupt und dann hat man halt dieses auch über technische Hoheit einfach so ein Monopol, was sicher Ticketmaster auch genommen hat, was ja überall wieder vorfinden.
Jetzt sag mal, Taylor Swift hat ja schon häufiger gegen diese Monopole geschossen. Hat sie sich jetzt gegen Ticketmaster direkt in Stellung gebracht oder wie sah das aus?
Also, wir hören gleich nochmal einen Clip dazu von Scott Galloway, denn das ist ja eine super interessante Frage, gerade bei Taylor Swift. Die hat ja zum Beispiel ein Album von sich selber nochmal neu aufgenommen, weil sie zwar die kreative Urheberschaft da hatte, aber irgendwer hat ja...
Ist recht an der Aufnahme.
Genau, die Produktion gemanagt. Und da gibt es ja die, wie heißen sie, Springer hat ja auch plötzlich darum gekämpft, das sind dann die, wie auch immer, das Leistungsschutzrecht. Genau, das Leistungsschutzrecht garantiert ja da auch denjenigen, die technisch die Hoheit über so Produktion haben, solche Sachen. Und sie hat dann das Album einfach nochmal neu aufgenommen, um es vermarkten und spielen zu können, also dass es im Radio gespielt werden kann, ohne dass die dann immer noch, sondern es klingt genau wie vorher, und in deren Sicht, mal sehen. Ich habe jetzt noch nichts dazu gehört, wie sie es organisieren. Wir hören aber gleich eine Scott-Galloway-Einschätzung, oder die können wir eigentlich auch vorziehen, dass wir die zuerst hören in unserem kleinen Finalreigen. Denn wir haben es hier mit einem Monopol zu tun, das ja nicht ohne Grund da ist. Es macht den Leuten halt sehr viel, sehr einfach und ja klar, jetzt wird man so ein bisschen drauf geschaut, aber... Ja, es ist so ein bisschen wie bei Neil Young und Spotify oder wie auch immer. Also du kommst da nicht drum rum, wenn das der direkte Weg zum Kunden ist, sei es das Ticketding oder in die Ohrhöre, ist das der Weg. Da muss ganz schön viel passieren. Da reicht es jedenfalls nicht einfach nur mal kurz einen technischen Glitch zu haben, einen Ausfall oder so, sondern dann muss halt wirklich auch politisch eingegriffen werden. Aber er betont hier nochmal, klar, Taylor Swift kann zurück zu Ticketmaster gehen und die können das dann darüber abwickeln, aber sie ist ja auch erstmal weggegangen und hat damit den Fokus drauf gelegt.
Die unerwartete Regulierung für Metta war Tim Cook und ich beginne zu glauben, dass die unerwartete Heide der DOJ Taylor Swift sein wird, weil das, was hier zu beachten ist, dass in 2010 Live Nation und Ticketmaster ein Behemmungsgerät gegründet wurde, das 70% von Live-Event-Tickets kontrolliert hat.
So, 70%, also 500 Millionen Tickets, es bleibt dabei. Wir haben erst mal nur eine mediale Aufmerksamkeit, noch keine politische. Oder jedenfalls keine, auch die Politik reagiert erst mal nur mit Aufmerksamkeit. Sie macht das zum Thema. Weshalb wir hier Cory Dock darauf zum Finale hören, der dann nochmal den Fokus auf dieses eine Dokument auch legte, was ja damals die beiden Unternehmen unterschrieben. Wir werden unser Monopolien nicht missbrauchen. Sie haben es ja jetzt missbraucht.
Die Biden-Administration, ja, die Biden-Administration, hat eine starke Beweglichkeit gegen Monopolienmöglichkeiten. Erinnerst du dich, als wir über die Verwaltung von Bork und die Theorie des Antifrusses gesprochen haben, dass wir nichts tun sollten, wenn die Preise auf den Weg gehen? Diese Administration hat sich gegen diese Art von Denken ausgeführt und handelte eine Exekutive-Order dar, die die DOJ an Polizistinnen und Polizisten und für die Konsumentautonomie und Privatsität verhinderte. Das ist eine Erkenntnis, dass Monopolien mehr als nur Preise sind. Wenn sie sich das ernst nehmen, muss die Monopolie der Ticketmaster auf der DoJ-Agenda sein. Die DOJ von Biden sollte diese Begabte aufsteigen und in der Verkaufsrunde der Ticketmasters in ihrer Verkaufsrunde weiterverdienen.
Sehr guter Hinweis, der fehlt überall sonst. Nur Corey Dottorf hat ihn gebracht. Es gibt dieses Consent Agreement. Ihr dürft zusammengehen, wenn ihr. Und sie haben halt damals unterschrieben, wir werden unser Monopol nicht missbrauchen. Und das kann man ihnen nachweisen und die Unterschrift gilt halt. Deswegen kann man ihnen auch einfach Vertragsbruch anhängig machen und da eigentlich relativ locker eingreifen im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Problemen, die schwieriger zu beendigen sind.
Stefan, versuchst du deine Mails möglichst zeitnah zu beantworten und kannst du einen unordentlichen Posteingang nicht ertragen?
Nein.
Normalerweise beginnst du keine Gespräche?
Organisiert zu sein ist dir wichtiger, als anpassungsfähig zu sein.
Halb halb.
Sie sind für gewöhnlich hoch motiviert und voller Energie.
Halb halb. Tendenz zu hoch motiviert.
Ich könnte weitermachen. Es sind insgesamt 60 Fragen. Ich habe sie für mich beantwortet, denn wir sprechen jetzt über Persönlichkeitstests. Persönlichkeitstests sind seit längerer Zeit im Trend. Ich befürchte, dass ich es tun werde. Ja, und dieser Trend ist sehr sichtbar, wenn man bei YouTube verschiedene Persönlichkeitstests nachsucht, was man da so alles findet. Man merkt, dass es Podcasts dazu gibt. Man sieht es aber auch zunehmend bei Instagram. Und ich habe dann mit Freunden gesprochen, die sagten, im Dating spielt der Persönlichkeitstest eine wichtige Rolle. Und wir nähern uns dem mal langsam. Wir hören jetzt hier von einem offenbar so klingt des österreichischen Kanal, wie so einzelne Persönlichkeiten, die sich dann herauskristallisieren, dort zu charakterisieren.
ESFJ-Consul in 180 Sekunden erklärt.
ESFJ sind als Cheerleader der Gesellschaft bekannt. Und was machen wir jetzt damit? ESFJs lieben die Interaktion mit Menschen. Wenn man jetzt an den Wert Extravertierter denkt, dann sind es perfekt die Typen, die jeder in sich hat, wenn er an den Typen denkt. Extravertierte Menschen, die gern rausgehen, reden, Spaß haben, andere wirklich anfeuern und einfach super gute Motivatoren sind. Also ihnen geht es wirklich darum, in der Gesellschaft mit dabei zu sein, so viele Menschen wie möglich um sich zu haben, beliebt zu sein. Das ist ihnen sehr, sehr wichtig und sie sind in der Regel auch sehr beliebt, weil sie eben für die Menschen da sind.
Monument heißt der Kanal und da ging es jetzt um die Persönlichkeit Konsul. Sie bekommen dann immer so einen Namen. Wir hören jetzt mal die Persönlichkeit Protagonist und da gibt es dann auch immer eine Buchstabenkombination. Also der Protagonist ist ENFJ. Das heißt, man versucht, aus verschiedenen Merkmalen dann eine Person zusammenzustellen. Man hat also eine Person, die aus vier Typen besteht, also vier Dimensionen, so heißt es dann. Also da geht es einmal um Antrieb und Motivation, dann um Aufmerksamkeit, dann um die Frage, wie trifft jemand Entscheidungen eigenständig? Fragt man sich, was wird der andere wohl denken? Und dann noch mal fragen, des Lebensstils in wie weit man Optionen haben will oder lieber auf lange Sicht bleibt. Und daraus stellt man dann immer so etwas zusammen. Und jetzt hören wir mal etwas zum Protagonisten.
Erstens, wer sind Protagonisten oder ENFJs? Und ENFJs sind oft die feinfühligen Mentoren unserer Zeit, wie man so schön sagt. Man findet sie oft als Lehrer, als Coach, als Mentor, die jungen Leuten gerne mal einen Weg aufzeigen und das auf eine sehr emotionale und tolerante Art. ENFJs sind sehr tolerant, die immer an das Gute im Menschen glauben und sind immer bemüht, dass eine komplette Gesellschaft und ihre wichtigsten Mitmenschen, dass es denen gut geht. Das ist oft ihr größtes Anliegen, dabei vergessen sie sich selbst.
Ey, eben wollte ich noch Konsul sein, jetzt lieber Protagonist, mal gucken, vielleicht werde ich gleich Kommandeur besser.
ENFJs sind von Haus aus Führungskräfte und wenn man sie in einem Wort beschreiben kann, ist das Verantwortung. ENFJs lieben es, wirklich Verantwortung im Leben zu übernehmen und es gibt nichts, was sie im Zufall überlassen. Sie haben eine innere Vision, die sie jeden Tag antreibt, haben das Gebart mit einem starken Wertesystem und versuchen, was in ihrem Innenleben passiert, in die Außenwelt zu tragen. Er ist sehr dominant, er ist sehr durchsetzungskräftig als Manager, da findet man sie an. Sie sind Führungskräfte und wenn man weiß, wie man mit ihnen umgeht, kann man sie sehr viel erwarten.
Und die typischen Eigenschaften von einem Commander sind wieder da, wie wir schon gesagt haben. Sie sind natürliche Leader, leben in einer Welt voller Möglichkeiten, sind Visionäre.
Und Stefan, du hast gerade einen vor dir. Denn bei mir ist tatsächlich rausgekommen, dass ich ein Kommandeur bin. Das ist was Seltenes, stand dann da. Zwei bis drei Prozent der Menschheit sind nur Kommandeure. Du bist nur eine Idee. Es wird aber auch gesagt, das sei gut. Denn zu viele Kommandeure geht nicht. Wer war auch Kommandeur? Steve Jobs. Wird einem dann gleich mit angezeigt. Und dann gibt es auch ein Steve Jobs Zitat. Ihre Zeit ist begrenzt. Vergeuden Sie sie nicht darauf, das Leben anderer zu leben. Lassen Sie sich nicht von Dogmen einsperren. Und dann wird der Kommandeur natürlich genau charakterisiert, um welche Beziehungen er eingehen soll. Intuitive Persönlichkeiten sind zu bevorzugen, wenn man Kommandeur ist. Der Witz ist nur, ich habe diesen Test jetzt gemacht in Vorbereitung auf diesem Podcast und habe ihn aber schon vor einer Weile schon mal gemacht. Und da kam irgendwas ganz anderes raus. Das heißt, man beantwortet Fragen mal so, mal so.
Oder du bist beides.
Oder ich bin beides. Oder wir stellen schon mal fest, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen sehr reduktionistisch, was hier passiert. Was passiert denn eigentlich hier? Wie kommt überhaupt so ein Test zustande? Dieser Sixteen-Personalities-Test ist der beliebteste. Der wurde sehr stark geprägt von CG. Jung. Das waren zwei Damen, Mutter und Tochter, die mit Namen heißen Katherine Cook Briggs und Isabel Myers. Die haben sich in den 40er Jahren aus eigentlich einer Laune heraus und ohne eine wissenschaftliche Grundlage diesen Test erarbeitet. Der wurde dann immer ausgefeilt, man hat dann Leute befragt. Sie sind sehr stark durch CG. Jung geprägt. Der sagte, es gibt extrovertierte und introvertierte Personen. Aber das muss man CG. Jung dann zuguthalten. Er hat das nie in dieser Weise so absolut gesehen, wie das dieser Test macht. Denn CG. Jung sagte dann auch, wenn jemand nur so wäre, dann kann man, also wenn es ihn gibt, dann findet man ihn vielleicht in einer Nervenheilanstalt. Aber eigentlich gibt es das in dieser Weise nicht. Aber natürlich diese Idee von den Archetypen bei CG. Jung, das ist schon was, was sehr präsent ist, was ja auch in der amerikanischen Popkultur präsent ist. Hollywood hat dieses Buch rezipiert, Der Herr aus den tausend Gestalten. Da geht es um so Heldennarrative, darum, wie Archetypen durch die Narrationen hindurchwandern. Das ist ein Buch, das von Spielberg über George Lucas und Weiß Gott wohin alle rezipiert haben. Stark auf CG. Jung aus Spielberg. Da kannst du es immer sehen. Da gibt es immer solche Nachtmeerfahrten in den Filmen, dass es CG. Jung und wenn man jetzt an Jordan Peterson denkt, dann haben wir es da auch mit einem Jungianer zu tun. Wir wollen jetzt gar nicht herausarbeiten, in wie weit das original CG. Jung ist oder CG. Jung pervertiert. Es zeigt sich auf jeden Fall, dass man auch ohne eine große wissenschaftliche Grundlage einen Test erstellen kann, der so beliebt ist, dass der millionenfach monatlich in aller Welt angewendet wird.
Man will ja auch endlich mal wissen, wer man eigentlich ist.
Richtig. Man möchte Orientierung haben. Und wir schauen uns diese verrückte Welt an. Noch einmal ganz kurz diese zwei Jungs, die da was erklären, wer wer so ist. Wir hören noch eine Person. Vielleicht, Stefan, bist du ja auch der Logistiker.
Zehn Dinge, die du bei einem ISTJ, dem Logistiker, auf keinen Fall machen solltest.
Platz Nummer zehn, Unpünktlichkeit. Also das kennt man. ISTJs sind von Hause schon mal sehr, sehr genau in ihrer Herangehensweise, egal, wo man sie jetzt findet. Und Unpünktlichkeit, das geht schon mal gar nicht.
Das sind ja Aussagen, die treffen auch fast alle Leute, würde ich sagen, zu, dass Unpünktlichkeit nicht gern gesehen wird. Bei mir zumindest nicht. Also vielleicht bin ich auch ein Logistiker am Ende. Wer weiß es schon.
Das ist ja auch vielleicht eine Antwort für diejenigen, die dann immer zu spät kommen. Sei doch nicht so ein Logistiker.
Sehr gut. Beziehungsweise kannst du, wenn du zu spät kommst, ja sagen, ja, ich bin ja kein Logistiker. Ich bin ja die und die Person nicht. Und darum geht es. Du nimmst jetzt schon viel vorweg. Wir nähern uns dem langsam. Wir hören in einem Podcast sein, der ist schon zwei Jahre alt. Luisa Gaffka und Moin Yamina, also Influencerinnen, unterhalten sich jetzt auch über diese Tests.
Manche Leute, die machen das mit den 16, wenn man es wirklich super genau machen möchte, dann wäre es besser noch, man teilt auf auf 512. Das ist jetzt so das, was mir Forschungsmäßig am besten gefällt. Wenn schon Schubladen, dann sollten es kleine Schubladen sein, weil je kleiner die Schubladen werden und je präziser, wann da jemand einschätzen kann, desto ähnlicher werden sich dann auch die Leute, die da innerhalb dieser Gruppe sich bewegen. Tatsächlich ist es auch so, die reden gleich, die haben dieselbe Tonlage dann und sehen sich teilweise auch super krass ähnlich.
Das finde ich dann halt immer so toll.
Also du hast das total arg. Der sieht dem ähnlich und die sieht ihr ähnlich. Oder haben einen ähnlichen Vibe, hattest du gesagt.
Ja, genau, so die Energie und so die Verhaltensweisen.
Eigentlich ist das algorithmisches Denken, dass man sagt, dieses Produkt könnte ihnen auch gefallen, denn sie haben ja schon das andere gekauft.
Das ist auf Dating-Plattformen. Ich habe das letztens in irgendeinem Podcast gehört, wo auch noch mal, weil ihr immer das eine Geschlecht, das andere nicht seht, man kennt das eigene Profil und sieht dann immer nur die Profile des anderen Geschlechts. Und man hält sich in dem Moment natürlich immer für wahnsinnig individuell, weil man ist ja der Mann oder die Frau und da leider Männern oder Frauen dabei sehen, aber die anderen natürlich einen selber nur in so einer riesigen Riege, wo man so durch und am Ende ist alles dasselbe. Also man sitz ja so durch, sind die drei Urlaubsbilder und so. Aber wo hast du dich denn hier rumgetrieben? Was ist das für ein Podcast? Das klingt ja, waren die da im Dschungel oder was?
Ich bin gar nicht komisch, das ist einfach voll normal. Das geht einfach zu meinem Charakter sozusagen dazu. Ist es eigentlich möglich, dass man rein theoretisch sich was komplett Neues antrainiert und man dann nach zehn Jahren ein ganz anderes Buchstab, also ganz andere Buchstaben hatte?
Es kann vorkommen, dass du jedes Mal ein neues Ergebnis hast beim Test, wenn du halt einen Selbsttest machst. Was nicht passieren kann, ist, dass du deinen tatsächlichen Persönlichkeitstypen änderst. Das kann nicht passieren. Du kannst Funktionen besser ausbilden, die du ohnehin schon in deinem Kit hast. Du kannst immer besser darin werden, dass man von außen auch immer weniger sehen kann, wo deine Schwachstellen liegen. Aber du kannst dich nicht komplett umstülpen. Und was man jetzt eben auch rausgefunden hat mittlerweile, dass das halt in unseren Genen tatsächlich auch beankert ist. Also man wusste vorher schon, also schon Carl Gustav Jung, also auf dem baut es alles so auf. Der hat damals auch schon gewusst, dass man das schon seit der Geburt hat.
Ja, der hat das gewusst. Der hat es einfach gewusst. CG. Jung ist ja dadurch bekannt, dass er sich durch mit Freud überworfen hat, weil Freud CG. Jung vorgeworfen hat, nicht wirklich wissenschaftlich zu sein. Und das zeigt sich zumindest bei seinen Epigonen besonders deutlich, dass man dann behauptet, Persönlichkeit liegt jetzt einfach in den Genen fest. Und daraus folgt dann für die natürlich auch, dass man sagt, wir können uns ja eh nicht ändern.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn Luisa und wer auch immer ihr Gesprächspartner ist, in Mojna Mina, in dem gleichen Podcast zu einem anderen Thema reden, dass sie dann total überzeugt sind, dass das Geschlecht natürlich nicht in den Genen einprogrammiert ist, selbst wenn man es sehen kann in phenomenologischer Ausprägung, weil das natürlich ansozialisiert ist. Während sie hier in einem Buch lasen, das vor 100 Jahren war, jemand reingeschrieben hat, ist in den Genen einprogrammiert. Deswegen ändert sich auch gar nichts durch die soziale Konstellation oder das eigene Verhalten oder den Erfahrungshorizont.
Das ist ein totaler Determinismus, aber sonst sind wir absolut auf gegen Trippseite entworfen.
Meine Freundin hat der Chef diesen Test an alle Mitarbeiter gesendet, was ich total schlau finde, weil wenn du da von jedem, der da arbeitet, diesen Test, diese Testauswertung hast, dann kannst du auch schaffen, dass diese Mitarbeiter viel besser arbeiten und viel produktiver sind und viel besser miteinander arbeiten, weil du jetzt die verschiedenen Charaktere auch kennst. Ich glaube, das könnte auch voll gut angewandt werden, was auch immer in der Arbeit, zwischen Freunden, in Partnerschaft, in der Familie, was auch immer. Wenn man sich selbst besser kennenlernt und die anderen besser kennenlernt, und dann kann man besser damit umgehen und hinterfragt nicht mehr so viel, und will immer was verändern.
Ja, mit solchen Gedanken kommt man auch auf eine über 100.000er Reichweite, habe ich dann bei Instagram gesehen.
Wieso macht die Welt sowas nicht?
Die Welt macht es ja. Es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass ganz, ganz viele Arbeitgeber diese Tests anwenden, um Teams zusammenzustellen. Und tatsächlich wurde von Briggs & Myers dieser Test auch damals so angelegt, dass er angewendet werden kann für den Arbeitsbereich. Deshalb hat man die Beschreibungen der Typen alle positiv angelegt. Also du hast ja eben schon richtig reagiert und gesagt, ach ja, klingt auch gut, klingt auch gut, wäre ich auch gern.
Das ist wie so ein Arbeitszeugnis.
Man will also nur erst einmal aufzeigen, welche Persönlichkeiten es gibt und dann kann man die zusammenmischen und tatsächlich arbeiten. Assessment Center nicht nur in den USA, sondern auch hier verstärkt mit solchen pseudowissenschaftlichen Persönlichkeits-Tests, die bei jeder Empirie sind, die höchstens so ein Körnchen Wahrheit beinhalten oder was. Klar wird man jetzt, wenn man mich auf einer Bühne erlebt und ich unterbreche noch dreimal Personen und spiele mich in den Vordergrund, sagen, ja das ist so eher der Commander-Typ. Logisch. Und wenn ich aber irgendwo zurückgezogen sitze und nicht gestört werden will, ja ist wohl eher der Introvertierte. Das sind ja viele, die gerne lesen.
Genau. Du musst es immer super generalisieren, um aussagekräftig zu sein, sonst weiß man ja nicht, womit hat man es jetzt zu tun. Was aber so super interessant ist, diese Art der Überzeugung, mit der die das gerade vortrugen und dass die Unternehmen das natürlich auch so als Management Methode wirklich anwenden. Es kommt ja immer einer auf die Idee, das mal zu machen mit diesen Tests und dann so wie sie hier sagt, ja ist total klar, dann kann man die Team zusammenwürfeln. Dann kommen die Berater rein und sagen, nee, du musst das Team aber gegensätzlich komponieren. Also ja, die Testergebnisse zählen, aber du darfst nicht die gleichen, sondern musst die unterschiedlichen, damit die sich ergänzen.
Nicht nur Kommandant zusammen.
Genau, damit die sich ergänzen. Dann kommt ein Jahr später wieder der nächste und sagt dann kommt das Jahr drauf. Jemand sagt, nee, das ist der psychologische Ansatz. Wir machen jetzt mal den sozialen Ansatz. Dann hast du wieder jemanden, der irgendwas von sozialen Hierarchien rabelt. Dann nächstes Jahr kommt dann jemand, der dir sagt, nee, du musst klare Beweisungsbefugnisse und so weiter verteilen. Und dann nach fünf Jahren, so wie Luhmann dann sagt, der an der Reform dient vor allem dazu, zu vergessen, was man vorher gemacht hat. Kommt dann wieder jemand mit den Persönlichkeitstests und alle so, das haben wir noch nie gehabt. Und dann geht es wieder von vorne los. Also man kann das in jeder Richtung. Das ist dieser typische Fall von Bauernregeln. Es gibt immer auch genau die gegenteilige Bauernregel, aber sie wird so lange ausgeblendet, bis sie halt keiner nennt. Und solange ist man total überzeugt von dieser Bauernregel, dass nämlich die Kombination von erstens wir machen diesen Persönlichkeitstests und hauen dann alle gleichen ins gleiche Projekt, dass das die richtige Lösung ist.
Und es ist ein zwei Billionen, also zwei Milliarden Dollar Geschäft hat Forbes errechnet mit diesen Tests, mit den Anbietern, denn auf der Seite, auf der ich das gemacht habe, bin ich natürlich jetzt auch erstmal nur bei dem kostenlosen Test gewesen. Es wird mir aber gleich dann offeriert. Wenn du jetzt mal richtig in deine Persönlichkeit eindringen willst, wenn du wissen willst, wer du bist, dann musst du jetzt auch noch was bezahlen. Und das bieten selbstverständlich dann auch diese ganzen Coachings an oder es gibt dann Agenturen, die diese Tests vermitteln. Es wird eingesetzt bei Datingseiten, bei der Paartherapie. Sogar wird über die Tests in Erfahrung gebracht, welches Haus dir zu dir passt oder auch für Diäten wird das herangezogen. Wir hören jetzt erstmal, bevor wir in das Geschäftliche weitergehen, mal so eine radikalisierte Form davon. Ich habe schon Jordan Peterson erwähnt. Der hat ja Epigonen oder Leute, die zumindest Ähnliches machen, deterministische Weltbilder verbreiten und maskulinistisch das Ganze untermauern. Wir hören jetzt hier den YouTuber Chase S. Joseph, der sich obsessiv mit diesem Persönlichkeitstest beschäftigt und der sagt zunächst einmal, dass wir uns aus diesen Persönlichkeitsanteilen zusammensetzen.
Die Testung ist nur 25% der E kvation. Es hat keinen Befund für dein Ego, es hat keinen Befund für dein Subkontraz, dein Unkontraz oder dein Super Ego, die vier Säulen der menschlichen Wettbewerb sind. Und die vier sind eigentlich ihrer eigenen Type.
Das stimmt natürlich, in die Richtung kann man es dann auch noch treiben. Der Test aber dahinter, die Hinterbühne der Persönlichkeit und so weiter muss ja auch noch zu kennen kommen.
Und einige von diesen Charaktern sind Introvert. Und einige sind extravert.
Jetzt sind wir da schon mal einen Schritt weiter in der Verwirrung, aber nicht in der Klarheit. Das innere Kind in dir, da gibt es doch noch einen.
Ich will noch zu diesem Clip sagen. Wir hatten damals in der FAZ so ein, ich kenne das Unternehmen nicht mehr, die haben Persönlichkeitsanalyse gemacht hinsichtlich E-Mail-Verkehr und so weiter. Da ging es vor allem darum, für juristische Fragestellungen so Inhalte zu generieren. Beispielsweise, was weiß ich, irgendwer hat so ein Seitbusiness aufgezogen und hat sich irgendwie bereichert an seinem Unternehmen. Dann hat man so eine Mail bekommen, die stand drin, sie werden hier vorgeladen, Personalabteilung und so weiter. Dann wird gesagt, die Ermittlungen sind schon eröffnet, aber wir wollen vorher noch mal mit ihnen reden. Man weiß überhaupt nicht, worum es geht. Die fragen einfach, warum haben sie damals im März aufgehangen, mit dem und dem Mittag zu essen und so. Man denkt, keine Ahnung, spielt das eine Rolle? Die Software sagt, ja, das spielt eine Rolle. Denn damals hast du da und da Kontakt gesucht und da und da ein bisschen abgebrochen oder gedimmt und so weiter. Und das war doch auch dieser Moment, als die Bilanzen ein bisschen unscharf waren. Und dann guckt man sich so an. Und in diesen Momenten, dadurch, dass in Amerika kein Datenschutzrecht gilt, jede E-Mail, die du an deinem Computer schreibst, für die Arbeit darf von jedem gelesen werden, der in der Organisation gehört. Und da haben wir komplett sein Profil ausgeliefert. Also da spielte man als Person gar keine Rolle mehr. Man hat auch nicht verstanden, eine Stunde lang, um was es in diesem Gespräch ging. Sondern die wollten einfach nur ihren aus den Profilen, die durch die Software produziert wurden, einfach nochmal nachprüfen und das Bild ergänzen. Aber ohne es, demjenigen, der da eigentlich als die Person hinter dem Profil dann wirklich leibhaftig vorhabe, sah es irgendwie verstanden, worum es da ging. Und das fand ich ja auch wieder. Wenn er hier sagt, nee, nur weil du dich so verhältst und dann jemand dich so beobachtet, heißt das noch nicht, dass das deine echte Persönlichkeit ist. Sondern die haben wir schon für dich ermittelt, in dem total standardisierten, durchoperationierten Test. Dein Verhalten spielt ja gar keine Rolle mehr. Das ist dann die Lüge oder sowas. Du spürst doch was im Schilde. Und eigentlich bist du vier Personen, du weißt das gar nicht und du verstehst es. Er hat ja ausdrücklich gesagt, wenn wir den Leuten sagen, sie sind eigentlich vier Personen in einer, dann verstehen die das gar nicht. Aber wir verstehen es. Wir verstehen die Personen besser als die sich selber. Und solche Sachen in solchen management-vulgärt theoretischen Aufarbeitungen sind immer so pervers. Wenn man das so hört, ist ganz schlimm.
Und es bleibt nicht nur beim Management, es ist ein hervorragendes Beispiel. Wir springen mal gerade zu einem Clip vor, den ich für später gedacht habe. Und zwar gibt es da von CES zum Dating eine Aussage. In Sekunden, nämlich kann man da schon etwas erkennen. Also erstmal diese Typisierung funktioniert in Sekundenschnelle.
Und wenn du verstehst, wie die Interaktionsstile mit den Temperamenten interagieren, kannst du in Sekunden jemanden typen. Und du beobachtest einfach ihre Interaktionsstile. Wenn du ihre Interaktionsstile identifizieren willst, dann sagst du einfach, ist er ein Guardian, ist er ein Künstler, ist er ein Intellektualist oder Idealist? Imagine, ich werde eine Frau wie eine Frau für das erste Mal dateieren. Und ich lege sie auf und ich weiß, dass sie super kompatibel mit mir ist. Und ich verstehe sie einfach.
Das ist alles Quatsch. Ich möchte hier gerne auf Grund eigener Erfahrung jetzt sagen, worum es wirklich geht beim Dating. Erstens sich selber kennenlernen und dann die andere Person. Man lernt sie wirklich nur kennen, wenn man ihr leibhaftig gegenübersteht und Zeit verbringt. Das ganze Online Dating kann das anbahnen, dass es zum Termin kommt, sich zu begegnen, aber kann das nicht ersetzen und man weiß vorher nicht, was man will. Man ist selber von sich überrascht, also muss man sich darauf einlassen und es gibt nur einen guten Tipp von der lieben Konstanze, die hier auch zuhört. Die Gefühle haben immer recht, aber man muss ihnen eben auch folgen und sich nicht verirren lassen, hier von solchen komischen Typologisieren oder was auch immer. Am Ende geht es doch darum, den einzigartigen Menschen zu finden oder, und das ist das Wichtigste überhaupt, die soziale Beziehung, die man eingeht, einzigartig zu machen. Man geht also nicht los und sucht den Sinn, sondern man erschafft den Sinn und das ist doch das Wichtigste überhaupt.
Und hier hat man den Eindruck, da müssen nur irgendwie Adapter zusammengebracht werden. Mehr ist es ja nicht mehr. Es ist eine ganz technizistische Idee, wie die menschliche Psyche funktioniert, wie der Mensch an sich funktioniert. Alles, was ein Mensch ausmachen kann, kann man zusammendampfen auf ein paar Formeln, auf am Ende vier Buchstaben. Und dann weiß man auch schon alles, dann kann man das zusammenbringen. Und die Verwundung wird dann am Ende groß sein, wenn es dann nicht geklappt hat. Die Buchstabenkombination war doch richtig. Und ein jeder, deswegen finde ich das so erstaunlich, dass sich das so durchsetzt. Ein jeder hat doch die Erfahrung, dass man sich innerhalb eines Lebens mehrmals in Menschen täuscht. Dass man jetzt, das muss gar nicht der große Betrug oder irgendwas sein, aber das ist wirklich positiv wie negativ. Dass man sich wirklich täuscht. Und da zeigt sich doch so vieles dran. Also wie ambivalent das menschliche Zusammenleben ist. Ein Bestseller, den wir ja auch kennen oder aber nicht gelesen haben, glaube ich, das Innere Kind, in die er soll Ruhe finden. Ich habe es nicht gelesen, aber das ist so etwas, was ganz stark rezipiert wird. Und auf dieses Innere Kind zielt jetzt auch dieser CS Joseph ab, der uns da auch sehr merkwürdige Anschauungen präsentiert.
It's where a person's innocence is. If someone were to attack the child function of another human being, that is akin to child abuse. That would be like telling an ENTP or an ESTP that they're uncaring and that they're the most selfish people in the world. That would be like telling an INTP or an INFP that they are the most disloyal people on the planet. That is child abuse.
Also, Child Abuse, es gibt natürlich Erlebnisse, die eine Persönlichkeit auf pathologische Weise beeinflussen. Dafür haben wir aber ein Medizinsystem, in dem nämlich katalogisiert ist und auch klar ist, wie das diagnostiziert werden kann und was es geht. Und dann kann man da auch therapeutisch eingreifen. Bei allem anderen würde ich sagen, und ich habe diese ganzen Stark, diese ganze Stark Literatur, auch ihr Podcast, Stahl heißt sie Stahl, Stephanie Stahl, wie auch immer, das Kind, den dir muss Frieden finden oder so. Ich habe sehr viel dazugehört von ihr und ich finde das alles total illustrativ. Und man hört da auch gerne zu. Man lernt vor allem ganz schön viele, auch so ein paar krasse Lebensgeschichten kennen, wenn man so einen Podcast folgt. Aber am Ende bin ich doch wieder, und ich kaufe mir wenig Bücher auf Papier, aber hier habe ich eins in der Hand. Es hat 923 Seiten und es ist einfach eins dieser gesammelten, es gibt drei davon gesammelten Werke-Dinger von Alfred Adler, wo einfach Alfred Adler im Originalton, wie er das damals aufgeschrieben hat vor 100 Jahren, auch so ein bisschen im Wettstreit mit Freud und so, wo einfach klar wird, nee, am Ende muss man ihm auch nicht folgen. Aber es gibt auch für diejenigen, die das brauchen, das Angebot von vergiss einfach deine Vergangenheit. Du kannst einfach jetzt entscheiden, komm, Blick nach vorne, such dir ein Ziel, mach irgendwas, probier was aus. Du musst nicht die ganze Zeit dein inneres Kind suchen, dir davon irgendwie was erhoffen, wenn du es dann gebändigen kannst oder wie auch immer.
Wenn du es gefunden hast, der innere Kern.
Genau, einfach nach vorne gehen. Die Möglichkeiten, Handlungsmöglichkeiten sind da. Klar, es gibt aber ökonomische Grenzen und so, um seine Persönlichkeit dann doch nicht so auszuprägen, wie man es möchte, aber man kann auch einfach, also sozusagen genau der Gegenentwurf zu Freud. Freud immer dieses, wenn du nicht bei Vater oder Mutter angekommen bist, dann hast du dich noch nicht verstanden in deiner Persönlichkeitsentwicklung. Und Alfred Adler so, nee, sag einfach jetzt nur noch nach vorne. Und dann geht man halt nach vorne. Und es gibt sozusagen auch, ich will das nur als, auch mal Literatur noch mal nennen, ich hab ja schon oft Alfred Adler gelernt, aber hier noch mal ausdrücklich gegen diese ganzen Suchbewegungen, die uns hier vorgestellt werden.
CS Joseph träumt jedoch von einer neuen Welt.
Wenn du mehr Kognition hast, kannst du mehr Probleme lösen. Das ist die ultimative Schätzung, die die ultimative Unität kreiert, die uns die Rasse ermöglicht, ohne Probleme zu bekommen.
So baut man keine menschliche Gesellschaft, sondern eigentlich ein Zoo. Dann sagt man, die können zusammen ins Gehege, die anderen aber nicht. Und wenn das alles schön fein voneinander separiert ist, also das ist so ein Identitäts-Ethno-Pluralismus jetzt nur auf die Psychologie aus. Und dann bleibt jeder bei sich bzw. die, die kompatibel sind, die können dann zusammenarbeiten. Es ist kurzum eine faschistoide Psycho-Gesellschaft, die er da herbeigeführt.
Wir können ja so einen Trend starten, während man bei methodisch inkorrekt sich zu Weihnachten gegenseitig Periodensysteme der Elemente schenkt, wo die Elemente echt drin sind. Sagen wir uns, ja dann sammeln wir jetzt alle 16 zusammen. Also du hast gerade gesagt, du bist ein Kommandeur und nur jeder 50. ungefähr ist ein Kommandeur. Da kann ich ja schon mal einen Haken dran machen. Sehr viele werden sehr viel länger nach dem Kommandeur suchen müssen, weil es ja nur jeder 50. Also Sammlung schon.
Da musst du mir auch gehorchen.
Aber sag mir Bescheid, wenn ein Test was anderes zeigt als Kommandeur, dass ich dich da wieder raus streiche.
Ich glaube, das ist die einzige Art und Weise, man muss sich darüber lustig machen, wenn es nicht so traurig wäre, denn auch der Sohn von CS Joseph wird typisiert.
Wir haben unseren Sohn vor dem Geburtstag auch noch Typen gemacht. Mein Sohn ist ein Bewegungstyp, meine Tochter ist ein Triple-Movement, also sind sie beide Bewegungstypen. Aber dieses Kind war noch viel mehr Bewegung in der Wurme als sie. Wenn sie fressen würde, hat er keine Freude.
Er hat keine Freude, wenn sie fressen würde. Er hat natürlich noch eine Hierarchie drin. Also es gibt auch wichtigere Leute, die man besonders braucht. Ich glaube, Protagonisten oder so braucht man besonders. Darauf wollen wir gar nicht weiter eingehen. Wir springen jetzt mal wieder und schauen uns das Geschäftsmodell an. Merv Emra war im TED Talk zu Gast und spricht mal über dieses Geschäft und auch über die Fehlerhaftigkeit.
Heute wird die Persönlichkeiten eine multibillionäre Industrie von Individuen, Schulen und Unternehmen verwendet. Aber keine dieser Tests, die MBTI, die Big Five, die DISC-Ansatzung, die Kommunikationsmodell und das Enneagramm, zeigen die Wahrheit über die Persönlichkeit. In der Tat ist es in der Debatte, ob die Persönlichkeit ein stabiler, mittlerer Teil eines Individuen ist.
Die Sounds sollen uns natürlich nicht stören, sondern eigentlich dann nur untermalen die Veranschaulichung. Das können wir aber dann jetzt nicht gerade sehen. Aber wir hören hier jetzt von Emre, dass es ja eigentlich jeder wissenschaftlichen Grundlage entbehrt. Trotzdem sind diese Tests weit verbreitet. Millionenfach werden sie in den USA gemacht.
Und hier geht es mal um die Fehlerhaftigkeit.
Also genau das, was bei mir passiert ist, irgendwann mal gemacht, weil ich das Thema schon mal auf dem Schirm hatte, muss ich zur Entschuldigung sagen, nicht, weil ich mich für meine Persönlichkeit interessierte. Und da kam was anderes raus als jetzt. Das kann man ja auch sehen, wie man sich weiterentwickelt oder auseinanderdividiert, wie Freundeskreise von früher einem nicht mehr so interessant sind oder man keinen nennenswerten Grund kennt, warum man zu einem Klassentreffen gehen soll, welcher Austausch soll da tatsächlich stattfinden. All das zeigt ja, dass wir unser Ich auch als etwas sehr Prozesshaftes erfahren sollten. Nun sprechen wir über das Business insofern, als mit Liebe und Sex ja viel Geld zu verdienen ist. Wir haben ja schon über Dreamlovers gesprochen im Salon. Und es gibt eine App, die heißt Sinkt, die anders funktioniert als Tinder. Denn es geht darum, dass man die Menschen zusammenbringen will, die wirklich auch zusammen gehören. Und man hat dann so einen Love Calculator. Ich zeig dir das mal hier, Stefan. So ein Love Calculator, da kann man dann zum Beispiel eintragen, welche Buchstabenkombination man hat. Und dann bekommt man ausgespuckt, nach wem man suchen soll. Also ein ISFP sucht dann einen ESTP. Und tatsächlich ist es so, als ich auf dieses Thema aufmerksam wurde, ein Freund hat mich auf dieses Thema aufmerksam gemacht. Daraufhin fragte ich in meinem Bekanntenkreis, ob das schon Leute gemacht haben. Und ich fragte, ob ihnen das irgendwo vorgekommen ist. Und die Jüngeren, die ich gefragt habe, haben alle gesagt, auf Datingportalen ist das jetzt ganz häufig, dass neben dem Nickname auch die Buchstabenkombination angezeigt wird. Also setzt sich das offenbar sehr durch. Und das sind ja Leute, die diese Tests offenbar sehr ernst nehmen. Sonst würde man das ja nicht noch extra zum Profil hinzufügen. Deswegen hören wir jetzt mal, was Synct uns verspricht.
Warum sind nicht Datenapps, die.
Also bei Tinder mehr über mich. Ich finde, das ist ja so eine totale sinnlos. Wie empfängst du liebe? Du mir das so ein bisschen mitgebracht hast. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du mir das so ein bisschen mitgebracht hast.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du mir das so ein bisschen mitgebracht hast. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du mir das so ein bisschen mitgebracht hast. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du mir so ein bisschen mitgebracht hast. Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass du mir so ein bisschen mitgebracht hast. Wir hören weiter in diese tolle Sync'd App hinein, was sie so alles kann. Deeper Matches werden hier schon versprochen.
Und es hat eigentlich nur so viel Sinn gemacht, wie du sagst, es gibt so eine Korrelation.
Also die beschäftigen sich dann aufgrund dieser Bricks Geschichte damit und sehen dann plötzlich, ja, so habe ich Beziehungen geführt oder ich habe falsche Beziehungen geführt. Es gibt noch eine andere App, die heißt Birdie, die funktioniert ähnlich und da wird auch erklärt, was jetzt das Besondere da ist. Also man spricht dann so von einer Post Tinder-Ära, die eingesetzt hat. Denn Tinder bietet zwar das jetzt auch an, aber Tinder ist ja so oberflächlich. Da geht es ja um Bilder und hier geht es ja darum, sich zu erkennen und den anderen zu erkennen. Und da heißt es dann, warum Birdie so besonders ist. Julia Zwan, das ist die Gründerin, Die Neuen Zwanziger. Wir hören weiter jetzt bei Sync'd.
Dies gibt den Kunden dann ihren Personaltyp und einen Personaltyp-Profile, der ihre Stärken, Weaknisse, idealen Date-Recommandanten hat und dann auch wirklich ihre besten Matches, ihre besten Personaltyp-Matches. Und das ist unser einzigartiges Matchalgorithm. Aber wir verpfeilen die Personaltypen in diese Kompatibilitätververgabe.
In seinem Buch Lob der Liebe hat der französische Philosopher Lambert Yu eine Werbekampagne sich angesehen von Meetig, eine Datingplattform in Frankreich, und die warb mit dem Slogan Falling in love without the fall. Also man möchte alle Dinge, die die Liebe und die Leidenschaft, wo ja Leiden auch drinsteckt, gleich wegnehmen. Aber man vergisst dabei, dass man natürlich damit auch die Liebe ausrangiert. Und so findet es hier auch statt, dass man glaubt, man könnte Menschen in dieser Weise reduktionistisch betrachten. Und dass das auch eigentlich eine gute Voraussetzung ist, um dann mit so jemandem eine Beziehung zu führen. Also wenn man einen solchen Blick auf die Welt hat, also wenn mir jemand kommen würde und glaubt, mit diesem Reduktionismus mich zu erkennen, dann ist ja eines schon mal klar, das ist ja die falsche Person.
Ja genau. Also das ist ja sowieso, das ist hier so ein bisschen wie, also Heiratsmarkt und Arbeitsmarkt ist ja sowieso manchmal so ein bisschen kühl gegenübergestellt und das ist hier dieses Äquivalent von ja, was möchtest du jetzt eigentlich später werden? Du hast ja bald deinen Schulabschluss. Was will ich denn werden? Vielleicht Lehrerin, aber nur als Beamte und dann weiß ich auch, was ich mein Leben lang mache und dann weiß ich auch, was mein Gehalt ist, weil dann kann ich in der Tabelle nachgucken und das ist eigentlich das Beste, wenn ich sozusagen nicht in den Arbeitsmarkt falle, sondern einfach schnurstrackster aufgenommen werde und dann ist alles gut. Aber so lohnenswert das ist, ist ja dieser Liebesweg ja genau eben anders konzipiert. Da braucht man eben diesen kleinen göttlichen Funken, diese Divine Intervention, ohne die es eben irgendwas anderes ist, aber eben nicht das, worum es geht. Und das können die Apps natürlich so nicht bieten.
Und selbst wenn man jetzt nicht die Liebe sucht, also auch der Modus des Flirts geht ja vollkommen kaputt, wenn man in dieser Weise herangeht.
Insbesondere, ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, bei Corona haben die Franzosen noch diese Werbekampagne gemacht mit diesem Bild, wo sich so ein paar leidenschaftlich küssen. Und dann hieß es, mit der Impfung kannst du das wieder erleben. Das fanden ja die Deutschen total beeindruckend, weil da so auf Emotionen abgestellt wurde.
Wir hatten die Uschi Klaas.
Genau, wir hatten so diesen deutschen Blitz. Und jetzt meintest du ja gerade, das ist eine französische App, die dieses Falling in Love... Meeting war das, ja. Es ist natürlich traurig, das jetzt zu hören, dass die Franzosen...
Ja, aber die Franzosen haben es dann gleich philosophisch aufbereitet, dass das so nicht geht. Also um die Franzosen mache ich mir keine Sorgen. Wer wird denn jetzt mit wem zusammengebracht?
Wir haben die Menschen mit einigen Änderungen geschehen, damit sie eine starke Beziehung erarbeiten können und dann ein paar Unterschiede, um wirklich einen Spark zu machen.
So eine kleine Pseudowissen-Kraft haben sie sich daraus gewassert. Also es erinnert so ein bisschen an das, was wir hatten, als wir über die alternativen Fakten gesprochen haben, so Leute, die sich mal selbst ausgedacht haben, wie das mit der Impfung wohl sein wird und was das so bringen kann und das ist so und so und so. Dann eigentlich verhält sich das.
Eigentlich wissen die alle, dass am Ende der Tanz-T das Ding war. Nirgends hat es besser funktioniert als dieses, ja wir sind jetzt, haben uns alle hier versammelt, weil unsere Eltern das wollten und wir wissen, worum es geht. Tja, machen wir es halt ironisch, aber machen es trotzdem so ungefähr. Und das gibt es heute nicht mehr. Und jetzt gibt es Begegnungen online und jetzt versuchen die, das irgendwie zu organisieren. Wahrscheinlich auch mehr unter dieser Maxime. Nur noch die anschreiben, bei denen es sich lohnt oder so. Weil beim Tanztag, klar, es war übersichtlich. Jetzt ist es halt kompliziert, weil es viel ist. Aber das ist doch alles Hanebüchen.
Die schalten jedenfalls auch Werbekampagnen, sind dann bei einem großen YouTuber, Frank James heißt er, über eine Million Abonnenten, der dann solche Comedy-Videos macht, zu den Fragen ziehen, gegensetzt sich eigentlich an. Wir hören da nur kurz rein. Und das ist aber eigentlich die Werbung für genau diese Dating-App dann.
Ooh, let's find out. For our first date we've set up a fashionista with an entrepreneur. These two will bond over a dancing lesson. Perhaps a little motion will be enough to jumpstart their hearts. Alright everybody, it's time to dance. Cause you kinda seem like you don't wanna be here. It was then that I realized that he didn't really wanna be there. Right, well it was nice meeting you, but I hate dancing, so I'm gonna go home and chat on Discord until 3 a.m. Wait, you can't know you hate something until you give it a fair shot. Ich tue das immer.
Selbstverständlich hat man gewisse Merkmale oder Dinge, die einig gehen. Du wirst mich nicht mehr dazu bekommen, dass ich in einen lauten Club gehe und am Ende sogar noch sagen würde, es gefällt mir hier. Das wird nicht passieren.
Man muss sich ja schreien müssen.
Es gefällt mir hier.
Nur ist das ja nicht meine gesamte Persönlichkeit oder die Rückschlüsse, die dann man ziehen kann, sind vielleicht auch eher geringere. Aber dieser Wunsch nach Kategorisierung ist schon dieser Wunsch nach Orientierung in so orientierungslosen Zeiten. Und ist der Wunsch, dass man auch eine Festigkeit hat, wo sie zum Beispiel durch etwas Transzendentes nicht mehr geboten wird, wo mir gesagt wird, so ist der Mensch und dorthin wird er einmal gehen, wenn alles zu Ende ist im nächsten Leben. Oder um ein frommer Mensch zu sein, muss man dreimal die Woche in die Kirche. Diese Dinge sind nicht mehr gegeben. Und jetzt versucht man da, einen Halt zu produzieren und versucht dies so pseudowissenschaftlich zu unterfüttern.
Ja, es ist vor allem, es sind zu viele Menschen, gerade in so urbanen Zentren, wo sich junge Menschen rumtreiben. Und hier schwingt also diese Idee mit von, irgendwo gibt es den Traumprinzen. Ich habe ihn nur noch nicht getroffen. Und das Problem ist aber, den Traumprinzen gibt es nicht, bis man ihn getroffen hat, weil er entsteht erst durch das Treffen. Und dieses gemeinsame Geschichteschreiben wird ja hier so ein bisschen ausgeblendet. Sondern die Idee, die hier warm gehalten wird, ist ja, es gibt da schon jemanden. Und es ist aber ist eben nicht so.
Ein Deterministisch, man trifft sich oder man trifft sich nicht. Und man ist so und man kann sich auch nicht ändern. Also diese Frage, wie denn eigentlich Beziehungen funktionieren, lassen sich ja auch dadurch ganz gut beantworten, dass man miteinander die Beziehung führt. Wenn man aber hier mit diesen Gegensätzen arbeitet oder beziehungsweise mit diesen Typologien arbeitet, wo man so ist, wie man eben ist, dann ist ja auch kaum etwas denkbar.
Das ist ja eh dieses, das ist genau diese Ideologie. Du kannst sein, wie du also jeder weiß doch, wenn man verliebt ist, biegt man sich ganz schön hin und zurecht um und dann ist man nicht mehr ein Mann selber, sondern man entdeckt sich dann gerade neu und so. Und dieses, ja ich muss jetzt jemanden treffen, den ich so leidenschaftslos nicht hinterherrenne, dass er sich komplett meiner Persönlichkeit anpasst, dass es eigentlich von Anfang an so langweilig ist. Das geht ja gar nicht auf, die Losungen, die die hier propagieren.
Das ist aber wieder eine perfekte Überleitung zu einem neuen Rollenmodell, von dem ich noch bislang nichts gehört hatte, aber darauf stößt man dann, wenn man diese Persönlichkeitstests und all das mal ein bisschen ermittelt. Diese Alpha-Männer, das kennen wir schon von den Hip-Hopern, Kollegen oder wer das war, die dann sagen, man muss so ein Alpha-Mann werden, also der Anführer sein in der Gruppe, vor allem auch Frauen gegenüber. Das ist auch natürlich sehr stark bei so einem CS Joseph Misugune. Er erklärt dann auch ganz genau, warum es so sein muss, dass Männer z.B. immer zuerst essen sollten. Die müssen vorrangig bedient werden. Also ganz, ganz obskure Theorien. Was wir uns aber jetzt noch ansehen, ganz kurz, ist der Sigma-Mail. Hast du von dem schon gehört?
Ich habe YouTube-Videos gesehen, wo er beschrieben wird. Und die lieben alle unter dieser Maxime. Sei doch so wie der.
Ja, vielleicht kann man ihn ein wenig so sich veranschaulichen, wie George Clooney in Up in the Air. Man geht so geschmeidig durch die Welt, ist souverän. Man kann durchaus sich investieren in etwas, aber nicht zu sehr und kann sich wieder rausziehen. Oder alles perlt so von einem.
Immer so ein bisschen ambivalent bleiben.
Der Mensch als hartschalen Rollkoffer. Nummer 6.
Wollen wir nicht alle ein bisschen Sigma sein?
Ja, wir wollen alle auch ein bisschen so sein. Und wenn man das dann nicht schafft, dann kann man sich immer noch damit beschäftigen, wie wohl andere Menschen sind. So gibt es dann von zig Politikern Datenbanken, in denen die Community versucht herauszufinden, wer wer ist. Also wer ist Anna-Lena Baerbock? Wer ist Doreen Farbeck? Und tatsächlich hat mir besagter Freund auch einen Link geschickt. Da wurde ich analysiert. Irgendjemand hat so ein Profil erstellt auf so einer Database und dann wird spekuliert darüber, wer ich wohl sein könnte. Und wir hören jetzt noch rein in Psychology Refresh. Da gibt es auch tolle Erkenntnisse zu den Persönlichkeitstests.
Die größte Motivation für ISFJs ist, dass sie oft zu dem Punkt der Verschleißung sind. Auch wenn sie stark interpersonale Fähigkeiten haben und eine Präparantität für Analyse haben, sind sie eher sozialistisch als ordinary Introvert. Sie sind kind und beherrschendigend und geben oft ihre ganze Leben zu denjenigen, die sie brauchen. Der berühmte historische Charakter mit diesem Personality-Type ist Queen Elizabeth II.
So, wir hören noch eine Persönlichkeit, die uns gefiltert wird.
Menschen mit einem ISFJ-Personality-Type wollen aufstehen und die Welt verändern.
Klingt doch erstmal gut, oder?
Sie sind idealistisch und haben eine starke Moralität.
Das klingt auch gut.
Das ISFJ-Personality-Type ist auf die komplexe Welt der Menschen entstanden. Das berühmte historische Charakter mit diesem Charakter ist Adolf Hitler.
Das ist eine sehr gute Pointe.
Und dabei belassen wir es, glaube ich.
Die passt ganz wunderbar zu diesem Thema. Unglaublich ist das alles. Gut, schließen wir mit dem Thema Klima. Ich habe unendlich viele Clips. Wir gehen aber nur ein paar durch. Wir müssen glaube ich keinen Clip hören zum Thema. Dieser Oktober ist einer der wärmsten. Wir liegen derzeit bei 11, 4 Grad im Jahresdurchschnitt. Kachelmann wie es heute Morgen per Tweet drauf finden, das ist bislang noch das wärmste. Klar, es kommt noch ein etwas kühlerer Dezember, aber wir werden wohl wieder Top 3 einrangieren. In Deutschland fehlen trotz aktuellem Regen, fehlten im August 39 Milliarden Tonnen Grundwasser. Wir hören jetzt also auch in den Medien so neue Kategorien. Das war in dem Falle die Tagesthemen, die uns das gesagt haben. Und sagen, hey, Milliarden Tonnen Grundwasser. Also wir haben noch keinen Maßstab dafür. Ich bin immer wieder fasziniert, dass dann so langsam doch so Inzidenzen gemeldet werden. Wahrscheinlich kriegen wir noch so ein paar beim Thema Klima. Und wir wollten aber ein paar interessante Clips. Zum einen von der Klimakonferenz haben wir eine 10-Jährige. Es gibt eine neue, eine neue Greta. Jetzt bin ich schon nicht mal auf den Namen gekommen. Greta Thunberg. Also es gibt eine neue Greta. War sie eigentlich da bei der Klimakonferenz? Ich habe sie gar nicht gesehen.
Also Lisa Neubauer.
Greta hat auf jeden Fall ein großes Buch jetzt. Habe ich gesehen, das Klimabuch oder sowas liegt in allen Buchhandlungen aus. Eine 10-Jährige fordert von den Klimasündern Payments.
Seit knapp zwei Wochen sitzen fast 40.000 Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer in Ägypten beieinander und haben viel geredet. Und jetzt hat eine junge Klimaaktivistin aus Ghana genug. Nakeyat Dramani Sam ist zehn Jahre alt und nimmt ihren ganzen Mut zusammen. Sie bekommt Standing Ovations der versammelten Welt im Raum. Aber Applaus allein wird nicht reichen.
Genau. Payment overdue.
Also die Zahlungen sind überfällig.
Genau. Es ist ja eine der Neuerungen, die es jetzt gab, dass es ein Klimaentschädigungsfonds gibt. Wir hören gleich mehr dazu. Ich würde sagen, hier haben wir es natürlich, sie wurde eingeladen und so weiter. Es war vor allem wohl ein deutsches Bemühen. Also es war ja total kompliziert, überhaupt diese Klimakonferenz zu folgen. Man hat mir gehört, es ist total chaotisch. Niemand weiß irgendwas. Die ägyptische Präsidentschaft macht so irgendwie. Es gibt keine geschriebenen Zettel, alles geht runter und drüber. Timmermann ist so völlig planlos, hat ja dann Lisa Neubauer in seinem Instagram-Video gesagt, die Afrikaner müssen das selber wollen. Wir können nur Anreize schaffen. Aber die EU-Kommission ist wohl ohne Pläne da hingefahren, bis Annalena Baerbock sagte, ja komm, wir machen mal das mit den Entschädigungsfonds oder so. Dann wurde das, weil die Europäer da mit Lücken im Programm hingefahren sind, zu einem europäischen Thema. Und am Ende wurde das irgendwie aber ohne Zugkraft. Aber das ordnen wir gleich noch mal ein. Joe Biden hat dort mit starken Worten zumindest, würde ich aber nicht sagen, heiße Wurst, heiße Luft noch hinterlassen.
Es sind nicht nur immer intensivere Hurricanes wie in Florida. Immer häufiger, immer härter spüren die USA die Klimazange. Hochwasser, Fluten im Osten des Landes. Hitze, Feuerwellen im Westen, in Kalifornien. Und extreme Trockenheit. Der Mississippi, wichtige Handelsroute. So niedrig wie seit drei Jahrzehnten nicht mehr. Klimaschäden sind auch Wirtschaftsschäden. Auch deshalb verspricht Joe Biden immer wieder, die USA zum führenden Weltklimaschützer zu machen. Denn klar ist, die USA sind mit China weiterhin der größte Treibhausverursacher. Wenn es um die Bekämpfung des Klimawandels geht, werde ich kein Nein als Antwort akzeptieren. Ich werde alles in meiner Macht stehende tun, um Luft und Wasser sauber zu halten, unsere Gesundheit zu schützen und saubere Energie zu fördern.
So, das war im Juli und der große Auftritt wurde natürlich da hart ausgebremst durch die Wahlergebnisse, die sie zeitgleich im Kongress eingefahren haben. Keine Mehrheiten mehr. Also in der Hinsicht, was soll der amerikanische Präsident schon noch machen jetzt? Ihm sind da politisch die Hände gebunden.
Du möchtest uns aber nicht, weil ich jetzt schon sehe, welche Clips da sind, du möchtest uns aber nicht den Clip von Claudia Roth vorenthalten.
Wo siehst du ihn? Claudia Roth?
Den möchte ich schon hören, den hier gesagt hat.
Wir machen also einen Unterkapitel auf Klimaproteste. Es gab ja Proteste. Entweder hat man sich irgendwo festgeklebt oder hat Farbe, nicht Farbe, sondern Essen im Museum ausgekippt oder ja die Straßen blockiert und so weiter. Und Claudia Roth, wir haben hier zwei Clips von ihr.
Zum einen, das ist der Grund, europaweit Klimaaktion gegen die Kunst, laut starke Proteste um die Welt zu retten, wie es heißt. Monets Heuschuber, Handelswert 111 Millionen Euro, geschützt dem Potsdamer Museum Barberini nur durch eine Glasscheibe.
Aber wozu die Anschläge?
Ich verstehe die Sorge, ich verstehe auch die Verzweiflung. Aber bitte attackieren an der richtigen Stelle.
Ich frage mich da so ein bisschen, wo ist die richtige Stelle? Soße auf eine Glasscheibe ist nicht die richtige Stelle. Wo ist denn dann die richtige Stelle? Wann wäre man denn zufrieden mit einem Klimaprotest? Und was wäre dann noch der Protestteil daran?
Sie war ja die Managerin von Tonsteine Scherben, die man in keinem Artikel müde wird, zu schreiben. Nun hat ja Tonsteine Scherben gesungen. Die haben Kulturveranstaltungen gemacht. Da kann man auch sagen, ist das der richtige Ort für Protest? Warum sind die eigentlich nicht in den Bundestag und haben das damals erzählt?
Es versteht doch niemand. Also das ist total Banane. Und es ist nur das eine. Der andere Spruch von ihr ist der.
Die letzte Generation hat eine Frage gestellt. Sie hat die Frage gestellt, was ist mehr wert? Kunst oder Leben? Und ich glaube, man muss die Frage umdrehen. Man muss es anders formulieren. Man muss sagen, Kunst ist Leben. Und deswegen muss man mit Kunst und auch mit Kunst gegen die Klimakrise angehen.
So, ich will es gar nicht zu tief, aber...
Kunst ist nicht Leben.
Ich will nur mal auf dieses. Man muss mit Kunst gegen das Klima angehen.
Das heißt nicht, wir singen irgendwo was Gemütliches.
Ich finde, eine Tomatensauce auf dem Van Gogh zum Beispiel ist doch Kunst. Die sind doch ins Museum gegangen und haben Kunst produziert, oder nicht, würde ich jetzt sagen.
Ja, also man kann das als eine solche Performance sehen. Wir reden ja jetzt über Rezeptionsästhetik. Wenn du das Publikum sagst, das ist Kunst, dann können die gewollt haben, was sie immer wollen. Aber wenn du das unter Kunst siehst, dann ist das so. Was sie hier möchte, ist ja genau das, was die Dokumenta geboten hat. Sie hat ja lange Zeit da beide Augen zugedrückt. Und das ist ja genau das, dass man in der Dokumenta dann gemütlich mal durchgeht, an den Artefakten den Hinweis bekommt, hier eigentlich kämpfen wir für die Frauen in, weiß ich nicht wo.
Bitte lest diesen Text erstmal, bevor ich das kurz anschaue.
Das.
Ist ja eine Kunst, die sich hyperpolitisch gibt, aber in Wahrheit völlig unpolitisch ist, weil nichts daraus resultiert. Und hier haben wir eine direkte Verbindung von Kunst und Politik. Das geht aber dann der Ministerin für Kultur zu weit.
Vor allem mit ihrem Spruch Kunst ist Leben. Also wir tun ja Kunst in ein Museum, um die Kunst zu schützen, damit sie nicht einfach mitten auf der Straße steht und da umgefahren wird.
Sie schützen die vor dem Leben.
Im Grunde irgendwie so muss man ja wenn schon Einflugsschneise finden. So mit diesem jetzt hören wir Götz Ali, der sich gedacht hat ja Kunst ist Leben, keine Ahnung was die Ministerin und so weiter. Ich sag mal ja ich weiß wo ich Kunst finde, gehe ich nämlich ins Museum rein. Wenn ich mir aber mal nicht nur die Kunst angucke, sondern auch der Ort, wo ich die Kunst finde, dann muss ich doch eine Feststellung machen.
Zunächst hat diese junge Generation wirklich jedes Recht zu protestieren.
Götz Ali ist ein renommierter Historiker. Der 75-Jährige hat sieben Enkel.
Für ihn war seine damalige 68er-Rewalte ein Kinderspiel gegen die Probleme von heute.
Vor einer Woche bin ich um Freiburger Münster gegangen, das ich sehr gut kenne. Die Umweltschäden, die dort täglich stattfinden durch unsere Abgase, das ist viel mehr Kunstzerstörung als diese symbolischen Aktionen.
Ob ich mir direkt die Glasscheibe vornehme oder die Mauer, die ich um das Gemälde drum rumbaue, ist doch eigentlich egal. Er hat hier einen Schaden begutachtet, den alle anderen übersehen, und die anderen haben in Anführungszeichen Schaden hergestellt, um etwas zu symbolisieren. Das ist ja kein echter Schaden, anders als die Mauer draußen. Und jetzt kommt das Deutscheste überhaupt. Ich war außer mir. Wir haben das letzte Mal über Van Goghs, und zwar nur über Van Gogh. Ich habe ja nur über Van Gogh geredet. Und da habe ich ja dazu gesagt, die in London haben genau fünf Stunden gebraucht, Bild gereinigt, Glasscheibe abgeputzt, wie man es halt so macht, wieder hingehangen, öffentlicher Betrieb wieder, alles to die. Dann dasselbe ist ja mit Kartoffelbrei in Potsdam passiert. Und jetzt hören wir uns das mal an.
Das Potsdamer Barberini Museum ist seit der Attacke vor einer Woche geschlossen. Das ist die schlechte Nachricht. Die gute, ab morgen soll die Ausstellung Verzauberte Moderne wieder zu sehen sein.
Mit Monets gereinigten Bild ohne Kartoffelbrei.
Und die machen eine Woche Pause. Und das war ja nicht nur das eine Bild da ausgestellt. Das ist absurd.
Das ist so typisch deutsch. Wir haben Corona. Leider müssen wir die Bibliothek zumachen. Wir hatten eh nie Lust, die Bücher zu sortieren. Immer der Scheiß und so. Ach, Corona ist vorbei. Na ja, wir geben euch die trotzdem nur im Counter. Weil bevor ihr in die Regale geht...
Das war ja auch dann, wenn im Sommer durfte man dann während Corona öffnen, alle Veranstaltungen fanden statt. Und die Theater haben nichts anderes zu tun, als dann ihre Sommerpause zu machen, nachdem sie drei Monate oder fünf Monate pausiert haben. Und das ist hier auch genau diese Denkweise.
Das ist wie in den Schulen. Schulbetrieb, wir machen erst mal eine Konzeptionswoche. Die müssen die Kinder noch mal zu Hause lassen. Die Lehrer müssen erst mal konzeptionieren. Was wird's machen? Das ist wirklich ein... Das ist das Museum eine Woche zu machen.
Also wenn das Museum ja richtig klug gewesen wäre, also wenn ich jetzt vom Marketing wäre, dann hätte ich gesagt, ist irgendwas hier gefährlich? Kann da was passieren mit dem Kartoffelprey an dem Bild? Hängen lassen, eine Woche lang. Und dann können die Leute reingehen und können sich das ansehen. Also damit sie es als Kunst rezipieren können. Wir machen jetzt Kunst daraus. Ich wette, in diesem Museum wären mehr Zuschauer denn je gewesen.
Ganz genau. Was ist man? Banksies komischen hat nicht ganz das Papier zerrissen, sondern nur zwei Leute in der Ecke.
Und hier hätte man endlich was gehabt.
Genau. Viele Chancen verpasst. Einen Clip, den habe ich schon mit Mick im Fernsehpodcast, aber er ist so lustig, so deutsch. Wir müssen ihn nochmal und jetzt werden wir ihn dann auch ergänzen. Denn wir müssen uns hier nochmal anderes Personal anhören. Aber wir beginnen mit dem Clip, den vielleicht einige schon kennen. Umfrage unter Museumsbesuchern reportiert in den Tagesthemen.
Heute ist die Welt im Potsdamer Museum Barberini wieder in Ordnung. Halbwegs. Monets, Getreideschuber, hängt wieder. Gereinigt, neu gerahmt und gesichert. Sichtbar mehr Sicherheitspersonal, Rucksack, Handtaschen und Jackenverbote. Die Meinung hier und heute über Kartoffelbrei-Würfe auf weltberühmte Kunst?
Also die Aktion finde ich total bekloppt. Vor allem schon deswegen, weil die Leute argumentieren, ja die Glasscheibe schützt ja das Bild. Aber kein Mensch weiß doch, ob die Glasscheibe und der Rahmen verklebt sind. Also aus meiner Sicht könnte da doch sogar Flüssigkeit durchlaufen.
Aus seiner Sicht könnte da sogar Flüssigkeit durchlaufen.
Das gab es ja sogar noch, die Argumentation, man spielt ja nicht mit Essen.
Das hat ja Hermann, der Innenminister von Bayern bei Anne Will auch gesagt. Also ihre Leute machen ansonsten auch hier, wir nehmen das den Supermärkten und so weiter und spielen nicht mit Essen, werfen es nicht weg. Und jetzt hier wird das Essen rumgeworfen.
Ja, Stefan, du bist auch schon mal bei McDonalds gewesen, ich weiß es ganz genau. Du hast hier gar nichts mehr.
Wir hören uns noch den zweiten Rentner an, der geht ein bisschen schneller und dann kommen wir auf den Generaldirektor des Naturkundemuseums in Berlin zu sprechen.
Nein, es ist einfach total eine unnötige Aktion und das bringt überhaupt nichts.
Das finde ich am besten. So alte Männer, die dann nochmal, das ist total unnötig, was sie hier machen.
Das bringt überhaupt nichts.
Die Kategorie unnötig ist wirklich, die beste überhaupt, die man da anbringen kann. Diese Not habe ich gar nicht gesehen, das ist unnötig, dass sie das hier machen. Gut, das ist Kunst. Sie haben sich ja im Naturkundemuseum in Berlin, das kennt bestimmt jeder, das ist direkt am Bahnhof und so. Ich war auch mal da, weil die damals so holographiert haben. Also die haben so aus allen Richtungen, so matrixmäßig ihre Bestände, die sie da hatten, einmal 3D holographiert, um die digital ausleihen zu können, an andere Forscher. Also so tiefschürfend wurde das da gemacht. Und ich kannte aber den Generaldirektor nicht. Und jetzt haben sich da aber auch welche mit Kleber am Dino festgeklebt, also an so einem Dinoskelett.
Aber du gibst schon zu, dass es jetzt so langsam ein bisschen sich tot läuft, ne? Also das ist jetzt...
Das ist jetzt bei einer Aktion gelassen.
Genau, du wolltest diese eine Aktion und das ist jetzt, ach ja, das wird gerade gewünscht, dann kommen wir dem nach. Es gab ja auch diese eigenartige Aktion in irgendeinem Philharmonie-Konzert, als man sich ans Dirigentenpult klebte, aber nicht wusste, dass es einfach hin und her zu schieben ist, wie das hier ist. Und das sind so Dinge. Und da würde ich auch jetzt mal sagen, diese Hochkultur als Angriffsziel, das funktioniert, wenn das symbolisch aufgeladen ist bei Van Gogh. Sonst ist das so eine marginale Gruppe, die er da attackiert, in der Oper, in dem Philharmonie-Konzert sitzt nicht das Ölgeld, das Gasgeld, das ihr meint, die sind gerade auf der Weg in irgendein Szenerestaurant oder die sind anzutreffen an tollen Flughäfen. Die sitzen nicht im Kammerkonzert. Das ist so ein altes Bild von reiche Menschen, tragen Anzüge oder sowas.
Ja, wir gehen in die Oper. Also wir sind schon überzeugt. Bitte nicht die Oper Frankfurt blockieren.
Ja, danke. Dann hört aber auch hier der Spaß auf.
Dann werden wir auch hier sitzen und sagen, jetzt ist aber Schluss mit diesen Klimaklebern. Klebt euch gerne am Eurozeichen fest. Klebt euch gerne am Eurozeichen fest. Das vor der Oper steht vielleicht. Das stellt man dann auch fest. Das ist mobil und dann kann man es mal wegtragen. Das wäre ja nochmal eine Erneuerung. Also du hast recht. Ich will es auch nochmal ausdrücklich sagen. Wir haben letztes Mal ausführlich, und es bezog sich wirklich nur auf die Tomatensauce in London, auf Van Goghs, Sonnenblumen. Alles andere. Für mich muss auch niemand, Pommes oder sonstiges in Potsdam rumwerfen. Oder Kartoffelbrei.
Das finde ich diese anderen Aktionen, die tatsächlich auch viel mutiger sind, was wir da in München erlebt haben. Leute, die jetzt einfach in Haft gesteckt werden, auf Verdacht sind. Das ist ja alles. Das ist ja, das erfordert richtig viel Mut. Und gerade da, wo es dann darum geht, Dinge zu blockieren oder so, das finde ich dann tatsächlich interessant in der Aktionsform, weil das die reine Sphäre des Symbolischen überschreitet.
Also in München führen die gerade die Justiz so richtig vor. Hermann war ja außer sich. Die legen ja gar keine Rechtsmittel ein. Und wenn wir die fragen, was macht ihr denn, wenn wir euch rauslassen, ja, dann kleben wir uns fest. Auf der Straße, also wirklich grandios. Ja, also jetzt der Generaldirektor. Ich würde auch sagen, ja, das muss alles nicht sein, dieses Geklebe, also der symbolische Effekt, der mediale Effekt ist vorbei, aber sie sind durch Zufall eben an diesen Generaldirektor im Naturkundemuseum. Vielleicht kannten sie ihn auch nicht, keine Ahnung. Aber er zeigt sich doch hier auf eine ganz erfrischende Art und Weise.
Im Naturkundemuseum ist noch der Klebstoff zu sehen, sonst nichts. Das Haus ist voll wie immer, die Saurier beeindrucken wie immer. Der Leiter des Hauses sieht sich selbst als Kämpfer für den Erhalt der Tier- und Pflanzenwelt, ein gewisses Verständnis für die radikalen Aktionen schwingt bei ihm mit.
Wir sehen das für uns als eine Herausforderung, noch stärker zum Ort des Dialoges, des Miteinander zu werden. Und wir laden die Politik und die Aktivisten ein, hier hinzukommen, damit wir gemeinsam über diese Sachen reden.
Gut, und nicht der Bundespräsident.
Ich würde sagen, das ist ja hier all in. Er nutzt ja geradezu die Gelegenheit, lässt den Kleber auch an der Stange, um zu sagen, hier haben sie sich festgeklebt und so. Das war meine Gesprächsaufforderung. Ich lade alle hiermit herzlich ein. Also das ist wirklich sehr gut. Wir kriegen hier eine kleine juristische Einschätzung im heutigen Journal zu den Klimaprotesten als Notwehr.
Also man kann nicht sagen, man protestiert und das sei eine Notwehr. Eine Notwehr ist nur, wenn ich wirklich angegriffen werde, beispielsweise mit einem Messer, dann darf ich zum Gegenschlag ausholen. Aber die Erderwärmung ist eben kein Messerangriff im juristischen Sinne. Deshalb ganz klar, der Zweck heiligt nicht die Mittel.
Was hat denn der Staat in der Hand gegen diese Proteste? Greift der aktuell durch oder lässt er eher gewähren?
Der Staat hat das Strafgesetzbuch in der Hand. Nicht weniger, aber eben auch nicht mehr. Heißt ganz konkret, wenn ein Bild beschädigt wird, strafbare Sachbeschädigung, wenn eine Strafe blockiert wird, ist es im Zweifel eine strafbare Nötigung. Aber man darf nicht, weil es jetzt politisch erwartet wird oder weil der öffentliche Druck groß ist, an Klimaaktivisten Exempel statuieren. In jedem Einzelfall muss die individuelle Schuld der Protestierenden beurteilt werden. Man darf nicht sagen, zur Abschreckung bestrafen, wie sie jetzt besonders hat. Das geht nicht.
Ja, also, was in München läuft, ist Unrecht, wie man hier so aus dieser Einrichtung hört.
Und was der Rest erfordert, ist erst recht bescheuert. Also das sind ja alles hanebüchende Sachen. So, also dieses eine Thema Klimaentfädigungs-Schaurentschädigungsfond, das gehen wir noch mal kurz durch, denn das ist wirklich interessant. Zum einen, wir sind jetzt direkt bei der Veranstaltung und hören den Präsidenten der Bahamas und von Pakistan auf der Bühne. Und wir erinnern uns noch mal, Pakistan war da nicht irgendwas. Ach ja, da war ja irgendwas. Und zwar, da kann ich sogar diesen Einklip mal spielen. Ingo.
Blicken wir nach Pakistan auf eine Katastrophe, die kurz unsere Schlagzeilen bestimmte, dann aber recht schnell in Vergessenheit geriet und bei der sich zeigte, welche Auswirkungen der Klimawandel haben kann, als wochenlang die Monsoon-Regenfälle so ungewöhnlich stark waren, dass mehr als 1500 Menschen starben und viele nur das Allernötigste retten konnten. Ende August stand etwa ein Drittel des Landes unter Wasser.
Ein Land, das gut zweimal so groß ist wie Deutschland. So, und in dem dreimal so viele Menschen leben, also 200 Millionen oder so. Und jetzt hören wir hier den pakistanischen Präsidenten als zweites auf der Bühne.
I'm asking, what is it worth to you to prevent millions of climate refugees from turning into tens of millions and then hundreds of millions, putting pressure on borders and security and political systems across the world?
Das stimmt.
Sehr, sehr gut, die beiden.
Das halbe Land steht unter Wasser. Damit haben wir gar nichts zu tun. Wir haben das Klima nicht geschädigt, dass es einfach über uns hereinkommt. Und seid ihr mal bereit dafür zu bezahlen? Erstmals wird hier in den PBS-Nachrichten gesagt, wird also ein Schadensgelderregister irgendwie eingeführt.
This week, several European nations did pledge for the first time ever tens of millions of dollars for a fledgling fund to compensate nations for past damages and losses. But those totals pale in comparison to the need. Studies have estimated that the developing world is facing climate-related damages in the hundreds of billions of dollars now, a total that could rise to a trillion or more by 2050.
The price tag is many orders of magnitude bigger than what is being offered. What is being offered today is a few tens of millions, which is a hell of a lot better than zero.
Also ein Professor aus den betroffenen Regionen sagt so, naja gut, gestern haben sie uns gar nichts angeboten und jetzt ein bisschen mehr. Das ist also ein bisschen mehr. Mehr als nichts, mehr als zero, ja. Wir hören ja mal Olaf Scholz dort auf der Bühne.
Auftritt Olaf Scholz. Er verspricht etwas Neues, eine Art Klimaversicherung, damit die meist gefährdeten Staaten beim nächsten Extremwetter nicht noch mehr Schulden aufnehmen müssen.
Als G7-Präsidentschaft wollen wir gemeinsam mit den Vulnerable 20 einen globalen Schutzschirm gegen Klimarisiken aufspannen. Für diesen Schutzschirm und die Klimarisikofinanzierung stellt Deutschland 170 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ist das genug? Ja, da könnte man im Ahrteil schon wieder zwei Brücken bauen. Was soll die Antwort darauf sein? Wir haben ja auch bei der Seenotrettung, dass jetzt mal bewilligt wurde, dass man acht Millionen im Jahr investieren will. Acht Millionen, das ist ja eine Zahl, das ist ein Sechste des Haushalts des Bundespräsidenten. Also dafür, dass der seine Türchen durchs Land machen kann. Und da wird jetzt ein Sechstel für ausgegeben, für die Rettung auf dem Mittelmeer. Und hier redet man von 170 Millionen.
Ja, also das ist natürlich um den Faktor 1000 mindestens zu wenig. Das ist einfach völlig absurd. Und naja, es gibt jedenfalls diesen Klimafond. Er ist zumindest institutionell eingerichtet. Und wir hören hier noch mal, bevor wir uns zwei Aspekte da besonders rausgreifen, eine semantische Drehung, die bei der COP noch mal eine Rolle spielt.
Für die Afrikaner ist klar, was die Industrieländer da versprechen und wie sie gerade handeln, das sei alles einfach nicht glaubwürdig. Wir müssen Entschädigungen verlangen. Denn Deutschland hatte uns doch gesagt, dass es mit der Kohle aufgehört hat. Aber es hat eben nicht alle Kohlekraftwerke dichtgemacht. Da ist sie die Klimaungerechtigkeit. Ich weiß, dass Kanzler Scholz nicht darüber reden will. Für ihn zählt nur sein ökonomisches Kalkül. Aber das macht er auf dem Rücken der Afrikaner. Die Vertrauenskrise zwischen Nord und Süd, sie schwelt schon so lange, dass sie die gesamte Konferenz aus den Angeln heben könnte.
So, Deutschland hatte doch versprochen und so weiter. Sie sprechen hier von Reparationen. Das ist natürlich nicht verkehrt. Wir kennen das aus dem Krieg, aber das macht ja keinen Unterschied. In dem Falle, die Schäden sind ja da. Und im Deutschlandfunk Politik Podcast gehen sie jetzt mal zwei Sachen durch. Zum einen sagt der Georg Ehring hier, der Entschädigungsfonds ist ja da, lädt aber auch wieder dazu ein, zu sagen, ach so, wir können jetzt Entschädigungen zahlen. Es gibt da ein Beispiel von Stefan Kühl, Funktional-Äquivalent, aber ganz anderes Thema. Du hast einen Kindergarten, der hat 17 Uhr Feierabend. Und die Eltern kommen aber immer zu spät. Was macht man? Man sagt den Eltern, wenn sie ihr Kind morgen auch zu spät holen, kostet es extra. Was machen die Eltern? Ach so, na dann. Und dann kommen viel mehr Eltern zu spät, weil jetzt können sie es einfach bezahlen. Und damit ist das Ding erledigt. Sie haben sich aus der Nummer rausgekauft. Genau das Gleiche droht beim Klima auch.
Es ist ja eine erstaunliche Kehrtwendung der Europäischen Union und auch Deutschlands. Vorher hat man ja auch noch zu Beginn der Konferenz auf der Seite gestanden, wir schaffen Kassen, aber wir schaffen keinen Fond, der dafür da ist. Das ist uns dann doch zu viel. Aber wir zahlen Entschädigungen auf verschiedenen Wegen. Das war ja am Anfang die Position der Europäischen Union. Und dann hat man diesen Fond in einer Kehrtwende durchgebracht und das auch sehr erfolgreich. Das ist für mich auch eine große Leistung. Vielleicht musste man auch da bei den Emissionen zurückhaltender sein, also weniger drängen. Aber man muss sich klar sein, damit macht man das 1, 5 Grad Limit wirklich kaputt.
Das primäre Ziel wäre gewesen, kommt Leute, wir machen das CO2-Ziel nicht im Sinne von wir entschädigen euch, sondern wir schädigen uns. Wir gehen das wirtschaftliche Minus jetzt wirklich ein. Hat man aber nicht gemacht. Stattdessen klebt man so ein Flästerchen drauf mit, ja, aber wir entschädigen euch doch jetzt. Also man hat sich so ein bisschen moralisch rausgekauft damit. Plus man hat sich nicht nur moralisch rausgekauft, sondern auch juristisch.
Wir hatten in Vorabbriefings so die Erwartung bekommen, die ersten Tage könnte diese Konferenz komplett gelähmt werden, weil man sich über die Tagesordnung nicht einigt. Und das hat Ägypten tatsächlich abgeräumt mit dem Kompromissvorschlag, der auch von der ägyptischen Präsidentschaft stark gekommen ist. Okay, wir reden über loss and damage. Wir reden aber nicht über die Frage einer juristischen Verantwortlichkeit der Industrieländer nach dem Verursacherprinzip, weil das eine rote Linie für die Industrieländer ist und die Entwicklungsländer vorab darauf bestanden haben. Und dann war der Kompromiss, okay, wir reden drüber, aber wir reden über freiwillige Zahlungen. Damit war das auf der Tagesordnung und das hat Ägypten abgeräumt.
Ja, und das ist besonders perfide, weil man jetzt den Leuten, die da einfach sagen, Deutschland hat auch gesagt, die steigen aus der Kohle aus und sie verpesten trotzdem weiter die Welt und machen bei uns Hochwetter, Unwetter. Ja, dann wende dich an den Entschädigungsfonds. Lass Deutschland in Ruhe. Das ist jetzt das Ergebnis dieser Klimakonferenz. Wir haben uns einmal moralisch und juristisch daraus gekauft, machen ansonsten weiter wie gehabt und sagen, ja, es gibt heute ein Entschädigungsfonds, an die müsst ihr eure Briefe schreiben, wenn ihr irgendwas wollt. Das ist wirklich die Bankrotterklärung.
Nicht die ganze Berichterstattung, also nicht die Berichterstattung, sondern das, was an Ergebnissen zu Tage derart frustriert, dass ich auch dachte, ich will gar nichts mehr dazu lesen, weil man muss es dann immer wieder tun, weil einem permanent eingeredet wird, dass es doch dann super gelaufen ist, haben noch mal einen kleinen Fortschritt gemacht, einen großen Fortschritt gemacht. Es ist alles nicht so. Wir sind, glaube ich, am Ende, diese Politik, aber auch am Ende dieses Podcasts für den Monat zumindest, deswegen möchte ich mit etwas Heiterem noch schließen. Es gibt noch einen einzigen Clip. Und zwar fragen wir uns ja schon die ganze Zeit, wir haben so viele jungen Leute im Bundestag sitzen. Was bringen die eigentlich rein? Wie wird es jetzt aussehen? Livia Gerster, ich glaube die Tochter von Petra Gerster, war bei Kulturzeit zu Gast, hat ein Buch geschrieben über die jungen Wilden im Bundestag. Ich habe es nicht gelesen. Wer hat es noch nicht tun? Denn mir reicht dieser Ausschnitt. Wie charakterisieren wir die jungen Leute, die jetzt im Bundestag sind?
Diese Neuen im Bundestag, welche gemeinsame Generationen Erfahrung haben die denn?
Die kennen zum Beispiel alle miteinander die Welt aus Harry Potter. Also ich glaube, wer heute zwischen 25 und 35 ist, der hat auf jeden Fall diese Bücher gelesen von JK Rowling oder die Filme gesehen und das merkt man auch im Bundestag. Also da heißt dann plötzlich das Paul-Löbe-Haus mit den Abgeordneten Büros ist dann das Haus Gryffindor. Und wenn die Jusos zum Beispiel vor einem Jahr unbedingt wissen wollten, wird jetzt Kai Lauterbach Gesundheitsminister, dann haben sie zum Beispiel den entsprechenden Hut gefragt.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche dann im Salon und vielleicht auch dann nicht mit Harry Potter, sondern mit was ganz anderem, nämlich mit Ulrike Herrmann. Was ich jedenfalls schon sagen kann, was ich vorstellen möchte, ist Pazifismus, eine Verteidigung von Olaf Müller, ein Buch, ein Büchlein eines Philosophen, das jetzt erschienen ist bei Reclam, eine Streitschrift. Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, noch nicht gelesen, aber werde ich auf jeden Fall für uns besprechen. Hast du auch schon was auf dem Schirm, was kommen wird?
Ich habe mir sehr vorgenommen, Bonus-Surrender mitzubringen.
Das werden wahrscheinlich alle Abonnenten abspringen, dann dauerhaft.
Ich könnte schon allein, er gibt gerade sehr gute Interviews, also ich sehe sie wahnsinnig gerne.
Du hast es noch nicht gelesen. Ich habe von jemanden erfahren, der tatsächlich damit was anfangen kann mit der Musik und sagt, das sei ganz furchtbar.
Ich bin gespannt.
Eine Selbstbeweihräucherung ohne Gleichheit.
Ja, ich finde, Bono ist als Figur dadurch, dass er nicht nur Resonanz erzeugen kann, sondern seit Jahrzehnten Leute, die das wollen und den Ticketpreis bezahlen können, auch zuweilen in Ekstase versetzt. Das ist ja eine Gabe, die schaffen nur wenige. Ist dieses Leben so reich an irgendwas, dass ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass dieses Buch, was eine Aussage des Autoren dieses Lebens sein kann, scheitert? Selbst wenn es scheitert, ist das Scheitern selbst schon wieder irgendwie mittels Wert. Ich bin wahnsinnig fasziniert, von dem Buchtitel Surrender. Einfach, weil jemand, der Milliarden verdient und dem alle zu Füße liegen, der dann von sich sagt, nee, mein Leben hat erst dann richtig Fahrt aufgenommen und auch für mich sinngestiftet, als ich mich entschied, auch mal mich zu ergeben, es auch mal sein zu lassen, sozusagen sich mal hinzugeben und so. Und das finde ich eine wahnsinnig faszinierende Einladung. Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass dieses Buch nicht auch ein bisschen mithält, was es verspricht, dadurch, dass da auch viele Leute vorab mitarbeiten und überhaupt. Und das ist so ein richtiges Projekt ist und nicht einfach nur so ein, wie soll man sagen, Lust- und Leidenschaftsprojekt, sondern er verbindet ja was damit. Und das reicht mir völlig, um das auch gegen dich durchzukämpfen hier.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst. Wir werden sehen, wir werden jedenfalls primär über das Buch von Ulrike Herrmann debattieren. Wir sehen uns im Salon, im Salon dann auch die Ankündigung, welche Termine wir im nächsten Jahr waren, wie man an die Tickets kommt. Außerdem dann auch im Dezember Salon wird zu hören sein, der Auftritt aus Frankfurt und noch mal der Hinweis, man kann den Salon, wenn man möchte, auch verschenken. Eine schöne Zeit, einen guten Monat und bis dann.
Es beginnt die Vormeinachtszeit, versucht es anzunehmen.